ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAKER NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
ACOSTA AGUIAR-CURRY ALLEN
ARAMBULA BAKER.
BERMAN BIGELOW BLOOM.
BONTA BROUGH.
BURKE CABALLERO CALDERON
CARRILLO CERVANTES CHAU CHAVEZ
CHEN DAVID CHIU CHOI.
KANSEN CHU COOLEY COOPER
CUNNINGHAM DALLY DALY EGGMAN
FLORA FONG [inaudible]
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN GABRIEL
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ FLETCHER
GRAY.
GRAYSON HARPER HOLDEN IRWIN
JONES SAWYER KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KILEY LACKEY LEVINE LOW MOAN LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY
MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE
O'DONNELL PATTERSON QUIRK.
QUIRK SILVA REYES REVISE
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO
STEINORTH STONE.
THURMOND AND TING VOEPEL.
WALDRON WEBER WOOD MISTER
SPEAKER
REPORTS OF THE FLOOR WE
HAVE A HEAVY DAY IN FRONT OF US.
PLEASE REPORT TO THE FLOOR
IMMEDIATELY
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS
PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE ASK THAT OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER.
AND IN THE GALLERY PLEASE STAND
FOR THE PRAYER.
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER
MEMBERS.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN.
THE REVEREND BOB OSHITA RIVER
NEXT.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION. ONE LAST REFLECTION
ON DUO CON TYCOONS HAIKU
[inaudible]
SHOWING FRONT SHOWING BACK MAPLE
LEAVES FALL.
THERE IS NO PRETENSION INDIA
KHAN'S HAIKU.
THIS HAIKU REFLEX EVERY AUTUMN
THAT HUMANKIND HAS KNOWN.
AND WE QUIETLY EMBRACED THE
NATURALNESS OF THE MOMENT.
A TRUE HAIKU IT'S AN EXPERIENCE
YOU'LL COMMENTARY ON THE NATURE
OF THINGS JUST AS THEY ARE.
AND THERE IS NO FEELING THAT A
PERSON IS EVEN SPEAKING.
THERE'S A SELFLESS QUALITY OF A
TRUE HAIKU.
AND THERE WAS A SELFLESS QUALITY
OF DUAL CON TYPE GREW.
INTERESTINGLY ALTHOUGH IN THIS
LIFETIME HE REFUSED TO BE
HONORED AS A POET A TEACHER OR A
PHILOSOPHER.
STILL OVER TWO HUNDRED YEARS HE
CONTINUES TO BE ADMIRED AND ON
NEW.
IN A VERY DEEP WAY.
YUKON'S LIFE REFLECTEDTHE TRUTH
OF THE PERSIAN SPIRITUAL POET
RUMI.
MANY WOULD SAY.
WHEN WE STOP ADMIRING OURSELVES
THEN ALL WE DO WILL BECOME
ADMIRABLE?
ALTHOUGH SEPARATED BY FIVE
HUNDRED YEARS AND HALF A WORLD
AWAY.
DO ALL KINDS LIFE AND HIS
SELFLESS POETRY EMBODIED THE
WISDOM SHARED BY RUMI.
THEY BOTH REMAIN INSPIRATION AND
REMINDERS THAT WE MUST TRY TO
LIVE.
WITHOUT PRETENSION AND SELF
CENTERED ADMIRATION.
NOW MORE NEED THEM WITH KINDNESS
AND GRATITUDE BEYOND.
THANK YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING.
AND JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COOLEY AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE MISTER COOLEY
[inaudible]
COLLEAGUES I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG [inaudible]
CHIRAC [inaudible]
VISIBLE.
THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO THURSDAY AUGUST NINTH
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE SEVEN MINUTE
NINETY M. I WILL KEVIN MULLIN
SPEAKER PRO TEM OF THE ASSEMBLY
PROVIDING CHEAP LUCKY DOT THE
WALLS AT THE DEATHS REQUIRE
KATHLEEN I'M LUIS READING THE
ROLES CALLED.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER NEWSLETTER
CALDERON MOVES.
AND DOCTOR CHEN SECONDS.
AT THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE.
THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR THE
DAY THERE ARE NO.
ABSENCES TODAY.
MOVING TO PROCEDURAL MOTIONS
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHORS PLEASE MOVE THE
FOLLOWING BILLS TO THE MAC THE
FILE ITEM. TWO SIXTY TWO S. B.
SIX TWENTY NINE MCGUIRE AN ITEM
THROUGH A SB TENS OF THE SEVEN
WILK.
THE CLERK WILL KNOW
.
MEMBERS PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE SEVENTY SEVEN POINT.
TWO I AM RE REFERRING.
THE FOLLOWING BILLS TO
COMMITTEES.
ITEM NUMBER FIFTY FIVE A. B.
SEVEN SIXTEEN O'DONNELL TO
EDUCATION AND THEN TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ITEM.
FIFTY EIGHT AB TWELVE A FIVE
JONES SAWYER TO THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE.
I NUMBER.
FIFTY NINE AB TWELVE FORTY SEVEN
THIS AREA AND TO BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS.
ITEM NUMBER SEVENTY FIVE AB
TWENTY THREE FORTY SIX QUIRK.
UTILITIES AND ENERGY.
ITEM NUMBER.
EIGHTY SEVEN AB THIRTY ONE FORTY
THREE LOW TO THE BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY EIGHT AB
THIRTY ONE FORTY FOUR LOW ALSO
TO THE BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE.
ITEM NUMBER NINETY FOUR AB NINE
NINE EIGHT GRAYSON TO PUBLIC
SAFETY.
ITEM NUMBER NINETY FIVE AB TEN
NINETY TWO COOLEY. TO THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE ITEM NUMBER NINETY SIX
AB ELEVEN SIXTY FIVE CABALLERO.
TO ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND
TOXIC MATERIALS ITEM NUMBER
NINETY SEVEN AB TWELVE FOURTEEN
STONE TO THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE.
AND FINALLY I ITEM NUMBER ONE NO
FIVE AB TWENTY NINETY EIGHT
MCCARTY. TO EDUCATION AND THEN
TO THE HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
MEMBERS PLEASE FLOOR AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE WE ARE TAKING UP
BUSINESS WE'RE TAKING A BUSINESS
ON THE DAILY FILE [inaudible]
SECOND READING.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY JOINT RESOLUTION FIFTY
TWO WITH AMENDMENTS FORTY FOUR
WITH AMENDMENTS SENATE BILL FOR
NINETEEN SIX OR SEVEN WITH
AMENDMENTS TEN TWELVE WITH
AMENDMENTS FOR SIXTY WITH
AMENDMENTS. ONE THIRTY FOUR
SEVEN SEVENTY FOUR AND TWELVE
THIRTY FIVE ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED
.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO BEGIN.
AT SENATE THIRD READING.
WHERE TO BEGIN AT SEVEN THIRD
READING?
WE'RE OING TO PASS TEMPORARILY
ON FILE ITEM.
ONE FIFTY EIGHT WE ARE GOING TO
PASS AND RETAIN ON FILE ITEM.
ONE FIFTY NINE WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO FILE ITEM.
ONE SIXTY THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE
SIXTY S. B.. NINE FIFTY EIGHT
FIVE MS AGUILAR CURRY.
CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL NINE FIFTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR DODD AND ACTUALLY TO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS MS AGUIAR-CURRY.
GOOD MORNING MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS TODAY I AM PRESENTING SP
NINE FIVE EIGHT ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR DODD.
SP NINE FIVE EIGHT IS THE
DISTRICT BILL THAT WILL PROVIDE
A SMALL BUT MEANINGFUL INCENTIVE.
REPUBLIC EDUCATORS AND SCHOOL
STAFF TO LIVE IN THE COMMUNITY
OF DAVIS WHERE THEY WORK.
IT IS IMPERATIVE THE TEACHERS
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR THEIR
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT ROLE THEY
PLAY IN SERVING THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
THIS BILL CREATES A NARROW PILOT
PROJECT TO SUPPORT TEACHERS AND
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES IN DAVIS I
ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS AIR CURRY.
SAYING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM.
CLICK LOVE THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARAB VOCAL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF A ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE
SARAJEVO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
MEMBERS PLEASE REPORT TO THE
FLOOR IMMEDIATELY WE HAVE LOTS
OF BUSINESS BEFORE THE BODY
TODAY.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE
MS AG AIR CURRY MOVES A
CALL
[inaudible]
MEMBERS VOTES COME TO THE FLOOR
MEMBERS WE ARE AT FILE ITEM.
ONE SIXTY ONE THIS IS SB
[inaudible] FOURTEEN FIFTEEN
COOPERATE.
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN FIFTEEN BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE AND ACTUALLY THE
HOUSING.
MISTER BONTA YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES PLEASE PRESENT S. B.
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR MCGUIRE.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THE SENATE GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE COMMITTEE HELD.
TO LEGISLATIVE HEARINGS AND
CONVENE A WORKING GROUP TO
EXAMINE LOCAL CODE ENFORCEMENT
AND FIRE PREVENTION ACTIVITIES
TO ANNOUNCE.
LOCAL TOOLS TO PREVENT FUTURE
TRAGEDIES AS A RESULT OF UNSAFE
BUILDINGS.
S. B. FOURTEEN FIFTEEN IMPROVE
THE PROCESS FOR IDENTIFYING AND
FIXING DANGEROUS BUILDINGS FROM
START TO FINISH.
IT BEEFS UP LOCAL INSPECTIONS BY
INSURING THAT SPACE IS OFTEN
USED AS ON PERMITTED RESIDENCES
ARE REGULARLY.
INSPECTED AND ALLOWS LOCAL
OFFICIALS TO CHARGE A FEE TO
COVER THOSE INSPECTIONS IT
ENSURES ACCOUNTABILITY BY
REQUIRING WERE REPORTS.
ON INSPECTIONS ALREADY MANDATED
BY LAW TO PROTECT TENANTS IN THE
PROCESS BY EXTENDING THEM
RELOCATION BENEFITS THIS IS THE
SOUND MEASURE.
IT'S AYE IMPROVEMENT ON THE
CURRENT PROCESS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOU AYE VOTE COLLEAGUES.
THANK YOU MISTER BONTA SEEN NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLARK WILL OPEN THE ROAD ALL
MEMBERS VOTE.
WE DECIDED THAT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK.
WILL CLOSE THE ROLL EYES.
FIFTY TWO KNOWS ONE THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
WHAT A PASS RETAIN ON FILE ITEM?
ONE SIXTY TWO FILE ITEM ONE
SIXTY THREE S. B..
FOURTEEN SIXTEEN COOPERATE
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN SIXTEEN BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE AN EXCELLENT
LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
SURE BONTA YOU MAKE AN OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES SP FOURTEEN SIXTEEN
IS THE SECOND OF TWO BILLS THAT
TAKE SUGGESTIONS FROM THE SENATE
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE COMMITTEE
HEARINGS.
AND THE WORKING GROUP.
IT ALLOW CERTAIN FINES LEVIED
DUE TO UNSAFE CONDITIONS TO BE
COLLECTED THROUGH A LIEN ON THE
PROPERTY MAKING NONCOMPLIANT
PROPERTY OWNERS PAY.
AND ALLOWING CITIES AND COUNTIES
TO RECOVER THEIR COSTS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER BONTA SEEING
THEIR DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM.
CLERK WILL OF THE ROLE.
ON MEMBERS VOTED TO SARAH VOTE
ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE
AYES FORTY FOUR KNOWS TEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM.
ONE SIXTY FOUR IS S. B. TWO
SEVENTY THREE COOPERATE SENATE
BILL TWO SEVENTY THREE BY
SENATOR HELEN OTHERS AND
EXPLAINED AMERICAN DOMESTIC
PARTNERSHIP.
THIS GONZALEZ FLETCHER HAS A
BUNCH OF FOLDERS.
MS GONZALEZ FLETCHER RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
S. B. TO THIRTY SEVEN ALL
PROTECT MINERS FROM BEING FORCED
OR COERCED INTO MARRIAGE BY
PROVIDING INCREASED COURT
OVERSIGHT.
UNDER CURRENT LAW IN MOST CUT
COUNTIES A MINOR JUST NEEDS TO
GET A COURT ORDER A PERMISSION
FROM ONE PARENT TO GET MARRIED.
ESPY TWO SEVENTY THREE
IMPLEMENTS BEST PRACTICES
ALREADY IN EFFECT IN COUNTIES
LIKE LOS ANGELES IN REQUIRES AT
THE MINOR AND THE ADULT
INTENDING TO MARRY.
BE INTERVIEWED SEPARATELY BY
FAMILY COURT SERVICES AND THE
JUDGE IN REQUIRES THE JUDGE
CONSIDER WHETHER THERE'S
EVIDENCE OF COERCION OR UNDUE
INFLUENCE ON THE MINOR.
THESE REFORMS WILL HELP PREVENT
SITUATIONS WHERE MINORS ARE
FORCED OR PRESSURED INTO
MARRIAGE AGAINST THEIR WILLS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU IS GONZALEZ FLETCHER
SEEING NO DISCUSSION.
OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE.
ZARA VOTE MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT
ICE [inaudible]
FIFTY TWO NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM ONE SIXTY FIVE IS S. B.
[inaudible] EIGHT SIXTEEN WE
WILL PASS TEMPORARILY.
THAT BRINGS US FILE ITEM.
ONE SIXTY SIX S. B. NINE
SEVENTEEN RECOVERY.
SEVERAL NINE SEVENTEEN BY
SENATOR JACKSON IN ATLANTA
INSURANCE [inaudible]
MISTER COOLEY.
COLLEAGUES AND PLEASE PRESENT
SENATE BILL NINE SEVENTEEN WHICH
RELATES --
TO INSURANCE COVERAGE.
WHEN YOU HAVE A LOSS OR DAMAGE
CAUSED BY A LANDSLIDE MUD SLIDE
MONTH OR DEBRIS FLOW?
IF THOSE THINGS WERE TRIGGERED
BY SOME OTHER COVERED PAYROLL --
THIS BILL HAS BEEN AMENDED SINCE
HAVE ENTERED OUR HOUSE EXCLUDING.
ALL LAND MOVEMENT WHICH IS
ACTUALLY A CONFUSING
[inaudible]
A CONCEPT BECAUSE IT COULD GET
INTO ISSUES OF EARTHQUAKE.
SO THAT IS NO LONGER PRESIDENT
THE BILL.
SAKSHI VERY IMPORTANT
CLARIFICATION BECAUSE OF THE
CENTER FORM INSURANCE POLICY IN
CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
IF SOMEBODY.
PROBABLY IS A RISK OF A COVERED
BECAUSE THEY COULD HAVE A DUTY
TO MITIGATE.
CONFUSION PRESENTLY HAS.
SURROUNDING THIS TYPE OF CLAIM
LEFT POLICYHOLDERS UNSURE OF
COVERAGE SO THIS ACTUALLY VERY
NARROWLY TAILORED BILL BASED ON
AMENDMENTS TAKEN.
IN OUR HOUSE IT ALIGNS WITH THE
STANDARD FORM FIRE POLICY
NATURE'S COAT AYE URGENT AYE
VOTE.
THEY WAS COOLEY SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLARK LOVE THEIR ALL.
ON THE RECEIVER.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE ON THE
NUMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS HAD A VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE
SURE COOLEY MOVES A CALL
.
MEMBERS WE ARE JANA FILE ITEM.
ONE SIX SEVEN AS WELL AS ONE
SIXTY EIGHT OR GOING TO PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ON ONE SIXTY
NINE PASS RETAIN ON ONE SEVENTY
AND ONE SEVENTY ONE THAT BRINGS
US TO FILE ITEM.
ONE SEVENTY TWO S. B. ELEVEN AND
NINETY FOUR CORKERY.
SENATE BILL ELEVEN NINETY FOUR
BY SENATOR LARA AND ACT LIKE
PRIVACY.
MISTER STONE EMAIL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS S. B.. ELEVEN NINETY
FOUR WHICH I'M PRESENTING ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR LARA IS TO
REALLY ENHANCE THE PRIVACY OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE USING
PRIVATE.
BUS SERVICES AND LODGING
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IT PROHIBITS THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS FROM SHARING.
THAT THE NAMES OF THE FOLKS WHO
ARE USING BUSES OR USING.
THEY THE LODGING TO ANYONE OTHER
THAN CALIFORNIA LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THERE TOO MANY EXAMPLES ACROSS
THIS COUNTRY NEWMAN OUT IN THE
WEST WHERE.
MOTELS AND HOTELS AND PRIVATE
BUS COMPANIES ARE PROVIDING
NAMES OF HISPANIC SOUNDING
GUESTS.
TO ICE AND FOR ICE ENFORCEMENT
AND TOO MANY PEOPLE ARE NOW
GETTING SWEPT UP OR HAVING THEIR
PRIVACY VIOLATED EVEN THOUGH
THEIR CITIZENSHIP MAY OR MAY NOT
EVEN BE IN QUESTION.
OBVIOUSLY THIS ISN'T A TECHNIQUE.
THAT ICE IS USING TO TARGET
SPECIFIC INDIVIDUALS THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT CALIFORNIANS
DESERVE TO BE PROTECTED FROM SO
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON SB.
ELEVEN NINETY FOUR THEY MISSED
DOWN MS BAKER YOUR RECOMMENDS
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I SAW THIS --
LEGISLATION IN THE PRIVACY
COMMITTEE AND I JUST WANT TO
POINT OUT AN IMPORTANT CHANGE
THAT WE HAD IN THAT COMMITTEE
THAT THE CURRENT FORM OF THE
BILL DOES NOT ADDRESS.
AND THAT IS HOW CENTRAL LODGING
AND BUS SERVICES AND
TRANSPORTATION IS TO HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
AND HOW IMPORTANT THAT IT IS
THAT WE NOT SET UP BARRIERS
BETWEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT
DIFFERENT LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT
IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO FIGHT
HUMAN TRAFFICKING. ONE OF THE
HOT SPOTS FOR IS AT HOTELS IT'S
AT LODGING ESTABLISHMENTS IT'S
IN OUR BUS SERVICE THAT'S GOING
ACROSS STATE LINES SO I OF AS I
MENTIONED TO THE AUTHOR WHEN HE
CAME AND TESTIFIED THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE FIND A WAY TO FIX THAT IT
DIDN'T HAPPEN IN THE BILL HUMAN
TRAFFICKING IS THE FASTEST
GROWING CRIMINAL ENTERPRISE IN
THE UNITED STATES AND ITS SEVERE.
ALL OVER CALIFORNIA WE HAVE
THREE OF THE FBI'S TOP THIRTEEN
HOT SPOTS.
MAKING BARRIERS BETWEEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN LODGING AND
TRANSPORTATION IS EXACTLY HOW WE
GO BACKWARDS IN FIGHTING HUMAN
TRAFFICKING I VERY RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR NO VOTES.
THANK YOU MS BAKER.
SEEN NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION.
ON THE ITEM MISTER STONE YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
JUST TO POINT OUT THIS IS NOT
PREVENT THAT INFORMATION FROM
GOING TO CALIFORNIA.
LAW ENFORCEMENT HUMAN
TRAFFICKING IS A VERY CRITICAL
ISSUE WITH TYPICALLY CALIFORNIA
LAW ENFORCEMENT IS.
INVOLVED IN THAT THIS ARISES
FROM TOO MANY OF THOSE NAMES
BEING GIVEN THE ICE.
TYPICALLY AS AN IN AS A CUSTOMS
ENFORCEMENT NOT HUMAN
TRAFFICKING I THINK IF THE
HOTELIERS AND THE BUS SERVICES
WERE LITTLE WORTH IN FACT FOCUS
ON HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND NOT
JUST ON CUSTOMS ENFORCEMENT.
THIS WOULD BE A DIFFERENT ISSUE
UNFORTUNATELY THIS IS A TREND
THAT WE'RE SEEING AND
CALIFORNIANS DESERVE BETTER I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
WITH THAT CLARK LOCAL ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE TOWN ABOUT AYE AYES
[inaudible]
FORTY SIX KNOWS.
EIGHTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
BACK TO FILE ITEM [inaudible]
ONE SIXTY FIVE S. B.. EIGHT ONE
SIX CORKERY.
SENATE BILL EIGHT SIXTEEN BY THE
COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION AND ACT
LIKE THE ELEMENTARY AND
SECONDARY EDUCATION MISTER
O'DONNELL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER SP
EIGHT SIXTEEN IS THE ANNUAL
EDUCATION OMNIBUS BILL.
WHICH INCLUDES NON CONTROVERSIAL
TECHNICAL AND CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS TO THE EDUCATION CODE
I ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE.
NAME IS SHORT ON SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.%
CORD BLOOD THE ROLL-ON.
RESERVE ON ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE
.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE WHAT
I SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO TAKE UP.
FILE ITEM.
ONE SEVENTY THIS IS S. B..
ELEVEN TWENTY NINE CORPORATE.
SENATE BILL ELEVEN TWENTY NINE
BY SENATOR MINING AND I PLAN TO
SUPPORT ORDERS.
MISTER CHIU.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES S. B. ELEVEN TWENTY
NINE ON BEHALF OF CENTER MONEY
WILL CORRECT AN INJUSTICE FOUND
IN CALIFORNIA'S CURRENT FAMILY
LAW WHERE ONLY CERTAIN SURVIVORS.
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ARE
PROTECTED FROM BEING FORCED TO
FINANCIALLY SUPPORT THE ABUSIVE
SPOUSE AT THE END OF A MARRIAGE.
CURRENT LAW SHIELDS VICTIMS OF
ATTEMPTED [inaudible]
SALT FROM HAVING TO PAY THEIR
ABUSER SPOUSAL SUPPORT ATTORNEY
FEES AND FUTURE INCOME FROM
INTEREST IN THEIR PENSION A
RETIREMENT.
SURVIVORS OF OTHER FORMS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE HOWEVER DO NOT
RECEIVE THIS PROTECTION.
THIS BILL WOULD ADDRESS THIS IN
EQUITY BY EXPANDING ELIGIBILITY
OF PROTECTIONS FOR ALL SURVIVORS
THROUGH BIFURCATED SYSTEM THAT
PROVIDES THE COURTS WITH
GUIDANCE ON HOW AND WHEN TO
AWARD SUPPORT.
UP BASED ON FEEDBACK FROM THE
DIFFERENT MEMBERS ON THIS FLOOR
RECENT AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL
ADDRESS CONCERNS ABOUT THE
POTENTIAL UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES.
OF THESE PROHIBITIONS BY
PROVIDING THE COURT WITH
DISCRETION TO SET ASIDE THE
BILL'S PROHIBITIONS UPON REVIEW
OF DOCUMENTED EVIDENCE OF THE
CONVICTED PERSONS OWN HISTORY.
AS A SURVIVOR OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE WITH THAT RESPECT WE
ASK DR VOTE.
THE REST YOU SEEN NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE.
CLUB CLUB IN THE ROLE.
ON MEMBERS.
IS A LITTLE MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE AND TALLY VOTE.
I FIFTY THREE THOSE ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES
.
MEMBERS WHERE FILE ITEM.
ONE SEVENTY THREE S. B..
ONE HUNDRED SEPARATE.
SENATE BILL ONE HUNDRED BY
SENATOR DELEON AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO ENERGY.
HE'S GONZALEZ FLETCHER YOU MAY
OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS IT'S CALIFORNIA BEGINS
TO GRAPPLE WITH THAT UNFORGIVING
CONSEQUENCES OF CLIMATE CHANGE
WE NEED TO TAKE STEPS TO FURTHER
SLOW THE CRISIS A METER. TWENTY
THIRTY CLIMATE GOALS A
CENTERPIECE OF OUR CLIMATE
STRATEGIES HAS BEEN CLEANING UP
OUR ELECTRICAL GRID.
WELL THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IS
PUSHING CALL A SUPER POLLUTANTS
THAT'S NO LONGER COST EFFECTIVE.
CALIFORNIA DECIDED YEARS AGO TO
SLOWLY AND STEADILY REDUCE OUR
DEPENDENCE ON FOSSIL FUELS TO
POWER OUR ECONOMY.
EVERY TIME CALIFORNIA HAS SET A
TARGET FOR CLEAN RENEWABLE
ENERGY WE HAVE BLOWN RIGHT
THROUGH THAT TARGET. THREE YEARS
AGO WE SET OUR PS SCHOOLS AT 50%
BY TWENTY THIRTY AT THAT TIME WE
THOUGHT GOING FROM 33%.
BY 202250% BY TWENTY THIRTY WITH
AMBITIOUS BUT WE WERE WRONG.
THE FACT IS THAT MANY ENERGY
RETAILERS ARE ALREADY NEARING
THAT 50% RENEWABLE ENERGY A FULL
DECADE AHEAD OF SCHEDULE.
GIVEN THE SUCCESS OF THIS
PROGRAM WE NEED TO KEEP GOING IN
AIM HIGHER.
S. B. ONE HUNDRED BILLS ON
SIXTEEN YEARS OF SUCCESS AND PUT
CALIFORNIA PASSED A 100% CLEAN
AND RENEWABLE ENERGY BY.
TWENTY FORTY FIVE SPECIFICALLY
THIS BILL WOULD ACCELERATE OUR
CURRENT 50% TARGET FROM TWENTY
THIRTY TO TWENTY TWENTY SIX IN I
WOULD ESTABLISH A NEW RPF
BENCHMARK BY.
AB 60% BY.
TWENTY THIRTY THIS MEASURE WOULD
THEN CREATE A PLANNING GOAL
PUTTING CALIFORNIA PATH TO REACH
A 100% RENEWABLE ENERGY BY
TWENTY FORTY FIVE USING A
TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL STANDARD
WHICH MEANS WE ARE EXCLUDING.
CHEAP AND PLENTIFUL
HYDROELECTRIC CAPACITY THAT WE
ALREADY HAVE.
THERE'S ALSO A FINAL 40%
PLANNING GOAL THAT STATES THAT
THE PLAN TO REACH A 100% MUST BE
ACCOMPLISHED IN A MATTER THE
PROTECT THE RELIABILITY OF THE
GRID.
IT WOULD NOT RESULT IN ANY AND
REASONABLE PRICE INCREASES ON
RATEPAYERS.
THE 40% GOAL CONTAINS NO
MANDATES AND NO PENALTIES BUT
DIRECTLY ADMINISTRATION TO
DESIGN A PLAN THAT WOULD REACH
THAT GOAL.
ONCE THE ADMINISTRATION DESIGNS
THAT PLAN IT HAVE TO BE BROUGHT
BACK TO FUTURE LEGISLATURE SO
THOSE FOLKS WHO HAVE SAID TO YOU
DO NOT GIVE AWAY YOUR POWER.
IT COMES BACK HERE.
WHILE THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
IS BUSY ATTACKING THE LUNGS OF
ALL AMERICANS CALIFORNIA CAN AND
SHOULD MOVE FORWARD.
GETTING RID OF ALL DIRTY ENERGY.
CLEAN ENERGY IS A PILLAR OF OUR
ECONOMY AND IT'S HERE TO STAY.
I HOPE WILL LEAD THE WAY TODAY
THIS IS OUR CHANCE NOT ONLY TO
LEAD THE WORLD IN FIGHTING
CLIMATE CHANGE BUT TO STRENGTHEN
OUR MIDDLE CLASS FOR DECADES TO
COME WITH QUALITY JOBS.
THAT CAN SUPPORT FAMILIES AND
LIFT UP COMMUNITIES.
PASSING SB ONE HUNDRED SAY IT'S
NOT ONLY POSSIBLE IT'S CRITICAL.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THEY CAN IS GONZALEZ FLETCHER MR
MATHIS YOUR RECOMMENDS.
ARE YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS.
YOU KNOW LET'S THAT THE TICKET
TO A 100% RENEWABLES LIED SAW
AND GET RID OF THE CAP ON OUR
HYDROELECTRIC DAM SO WE CAN GET
UP 290% TODAY.
THIS BILL FAILS TO DO THAT.
THIS BILL DOESN'T HELP JUMPSTART
THINGS LIKE BIOMASS.
IT'S NOT A 100% THERE.
WE TALK ABOUT LET'S NOT PASS
THIS ON TO THE REPAIR LETS YOU
KNOW WE WE'VE REACHED ALL THESE
GREAT GOALS WITH.
RENEWABLES BUT AT THE SAME TIME.
OUR FAMILIES BACK HOME OF PAY
THE PRICE.
WITH AN INCREASE IN THEIR
ELECTRIC BILLS EVERY YEAR AS
WE'VE TRIED TO ACHIEVE THIS.
IF WE TRULY.
HONEST TO GOD WHEN HE GETS A
100%.
GET RID OF THE CAP ON OUR HYDRO
DAMS LET'S BUILD MORE DAMS IN
MAKE THEM HYDRO DAMS.
AND THAT'S A GREAT WAY WE CAN
GET THERE.
BUT SO FAR WILL YOU SEEN IN THE
STATE IS NO DO DAMS.
IN WERE NOT CHANGING THE CAPITA
HYDRO SO UNTIL THIS BILL
ACTUALLY DOES THAT WHICH I
SUGGESTED TO THE AUTHOR MONTHS
AGO. TO ACTUALLY GET US THERE.
IT IS NOT A 100% THEIR MEMBERS I
ASK YOU FOR NO VOTE LET'S GET
THIS RIGHT.
IF CALIFORNIA WANTS TO BE A 100%
LET'S DO IT THROUGHHYDRO.
AND NOT.
ALL THIS OTHER FAKE NONSENSE.
MISS FRIEDMAN YOUR ADDRESS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
[inaudible]
MEMBERS [inaudible]
THERE IS.
NO OTHER ISSUE BUT CLIMATE.
THERE IS NO OTHER ISSUE BUT
CLIMATE CHANGE.
CLIMATE CHANGE POSES AN
EXISTENTIAL THREAT. TO OUR
PLANET.
THE ONLY THING THAT THE
SCIENTISTS GOT WRONG.
WHEN IT COMES TO CLIMATE CHANGE?
WAS THE RATE AT WHICH IT IS
OCCURRING.
IT'S OCCURRING FASTER THAN
PROJECTIONS.
THOUGHT IT WAS GOING. TO TWENTY
OR THIRTY YEARS AGO.
CLIMATE CHANGE WAS FIRST
DISCUSSED.
IN THE PRESS AND IN SCIENTIFIC
JOURNALS AT THE TURN OF THE
TWENTIETH CENTURY.
EVEN THEN THE AMOUNT OF COAL
THAT.
COAL THAT WAS BEING PUT INTO THE
ATMOSPHERE WAS BEGINNING TO WARM
THE PLANET.
AND SCIENTISTS WERE DISCUSSING.
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN?
IF THOSE CARBON EMISSIONS
CONTINUE.
WE ARE SEEING [inaudible]
FAMINE [inaudible]
WAR [inaudible]
DISRUPTION [inaudible]
REFUGEES DISEASE ALL DIRECTLY
RELATED TO CLIMATE CHANGE ALL
OVER THE PLANET.
I DON'T NO WHAT IT IS ABOUT THE
ENORMITY OF THIS ISSUE THAT
MAKES IT DIFFICULTFOR PEOPLE.
TO UNDERSTAND AND APPRECIATE.
THE THREAT IS SO GRAVE.
THAT WE CAN'T WRAPPER ON OUR
MINDS AROUND IT.
IT'S SO OVERWHELMING THAT IT
LEADS TO A KIND OF PARALYSIS.
THAT LEADS TO PEOPLE TALKING
ABOUT.
WHY WE SHOULDN'T DO WHATEVER WE
CAN?
BECAUSE A BILL MAYBE ISN'T AS
PERFECT OR EXACTLY AS WE WERE AS
SOMEONE WOULD LIKE.
I THINK THIS IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT BILLS THAT WE ARE
GOING TO VOTE ON THIS SESSION.
I AM A PROUD AUTHOR OF SP.
ONE HUNDRED AND LET ME TELL YOU
ANOTHER REASON THIS IS SO
IMPORTANT EVEN KNOW CALIFORNIA
ONLY REPRESENTS A SMALL PORTION
OF THE WORLD'S EMISSIONS.
WHAT WE DO HERE IS NOTICED?
BY THE ENTIRE WORLD.
WE ARE THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY
ON THE BILL ON THE PLANET.
AND WE SET THE TONE.
EVEN IF THE UNITED STATES
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS ABSCONDED.
ITS ROLE AS A WORLD LEADER ON SO
MANY ISSUES WE IN CALIFORNIA CAN
LEAD THE WORLD ON THIS ISSUE.
AND THIS IS OUR CHANCE TO DO
THAT.
I WAS VERY HONORED LAST YEAR TO
BE ABLE TO ATTEND THE COUNCIL OF
PARTY'S TO THE PARIS ACCORD IS
ONE OF THE ASSEMBLY
REPRESENTATIVES.
AND I CAN'T TELL YOU THE NUMBER
OF REPRESENTATIVES FROM AROUND
THE WORLD WHO CAME AND SAID HOW
IS CALIFORNIA ABLE TO DO WHAT
THEY'RE DOING WITH RENEWABLE
ENERGY.
WE IN GERMANY WE IN.
BRAZIL WE IN MANY AN THE SO MANY
OTHER COUNTRIES WHO CAME UP TO
SPEAK.
SAID WE ARE WANTING TO FOLLOW
YOUR LEAD WE WANT TO LEARN FROM
YOU.
TODAY WE'RE GOING TO SEND THAT
SIGNAL NOT JUST A CALIFORNIA BUT
AROUND THE WORLD THAT IT'S TIME
TO INVEST.
OUR SCIENTIFIC ENERGY ARE
FINANCIAL POWER AND EVERYTHING
ELSE IN RENEWABLE ENERGIES
[inaudible]
MEMBERS PLEASE SHOW THE WORLD
WHO WAS WATCHING WHAT WE ARE
ABLE TO ACHIEVE IN CALIFORNIA
AND SUPPORT SP ONE HUNDRED TODAY
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MS FRIEDMAN MISTER
LEVINE [inaudible]
YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB
ONE HUNDRED THERE ISN'T A POLITE
WAY TO SAY.
THAT WE ARE LOSING THE BATTLE.
ON CLIMATE CHANGE.
BUT THAT'S EXACTLY WHERE WE ARE
RIGHT NOW.
AND SB.
ONE HUNDRED PUTS US ON A PATH TO
WIN THE WAR.
WE HAVE MANY OTHER THINGS WE
NEED TO DO TO SEQUESTER CARBON
TO TAKE IT OUT OF OUR ATMOSPHERE
TO SLOW DOWN THE GLOBAL WARMING
THAT'S MELTING.
THE ARCTIC CAPS AND THE GLACIERS.
AND I CHANGING THE CLIMATE ALL
AROUND THE WORLD BUT CALIFORNIA
CAN LEAD THE WAY.
AND CAN SHOW THE WORLD THAT
SOMEWHERE IN THE UNITED STATES
WE WILL TAKE THAT BATTLE ALL THE
WAY ON TO VICTORY HIGHER TONIGHT
THOUGH.
THEY WISH LEVINE MR MCCARTY
URANUS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THAT
1100% CLEAN ENERGY ACT OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN IS AN IMPORTANT TOOL IN
OUR EFFORT TO BATTLE CLIMATE
CHANGE.
A WE KNOW THAT THEY ARE TRUE
ECONOMIC ENVIRONMENT ADVANTAGES
OF A CARBON FREE GRID HUNDRED
THOUSAND JOBS AND CLEAN ENERGY
HAVE BEEN CREATED.
BY IS WHEN I TAKE US DOWN A
QUICK --
MEMORY LANE WHEN THIS FIRST THIS
ISSUE WAS FIRST PROPOSED IN TWO
THOUSAND AND TWO BY SENATOR
BYRON SHARE.
THE RENEWABLE PORTFOLIO STRATEGY
BACK THEN WAS THE GOAL OF 25%.
AND THE NAY SAYERS SAID NO WAY
[inaudible]
CAN'T HAPPEN.
AS OUR FLOOR JOCKEY FROM SAN
DIEGO JUST SAID WE BLEW PAST
THAT.
THAT'S FORTY EIGHT YEARS TO TWO
THOUSAND AND TEN SANDERSON
MIDIAN CAME BACK PUSHED UP 233%.
NAY SAYERS SAID NO WAY WE CAN DO
IT IT WILL JACK UP OUR OUR
ENERGY BILLS THAT ALL HURTS OUR
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY.
BOTH THOSE THINGS TURN OUT TO BE
FALSE FEARS LATER WE CAME UP
WITH ANOTHER MEASURE TO GO 250%.
AND NOW WE'RE GOING 21100%
BECAUSE HAVING A TRIGGER OUT
THERE AND INDICATOR TO THE
MARKETS WILL SHOW THAT
CALIFORNIA IS SERIOUS ABOUT THIS.
AND IT'LL SET A STAGE WHERE WE
CAN REALLY MAKE IT HAPPEN.
LASTLY I WANT TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUE OF ON ISSUES LIKE HYDRO
HYDRO ELECTRIC --
IN THIS IS AN IMPORTANT ISSUE
FOR RIGHT HERE IN OUR*
TERRITORY.
BECAUSE IF YOU COMBINE THE RP
ASSN HIJO R.* --
FOR EXAMPLE MINUTES OBVIOUS WHAT
POWER ENTITY BUT ALREADY HAVE
50% OF CLEAN ENERGY AND THIS
BILL ALLOWS HYDRO AND OTHER --
IT MEANS TO BE ABLE TO YOU KNOW
AND THIS WILL ALLOW US TO HAVE A
CLEANER BETTER MORE EFFICIENT.
AND RESILIENT READ AND PUT US ON
UP ON A PATH.
TO A FULLY DE CARBONIZED
ELECTRIC GRID IN A HEALTHIER AND
STRONGER CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR MCCARTY DR CHOI
[inaudible]
YOUR RECKLESS.
THANK YOU SPEAKER.
I RISE TO OPPOSE SOFT TO DISPEL.
THIS BILL LOCKYER INCREASES SIDE
THE EXISTING RENEWABLE LA PUT
FOR YOUR STANDARD ARE PURCHASING
MANDATE. FOR ELECTRICITY
SUPPLIERS SO TO A 60% BY.
TWENTY THIRTY THIS IS THE
ABOLITION ASSOCIATE POLICY TO
ACHIEVE A QUARTER OF WHAT. 100%
RENEWABLE ENERGY.
AND DOES ZERO COBB ONE
ELECTRICAL GENERATION RESOURCES
UP BY.
TWO THOUSAND FORTY FIVE NO
EVIDENCE HAS BEEN PRESENTED TO
SHOW THAT.
A 100% CLEAN ENERGY GORE IS
TECHNOLOGICALLY FEASIBLE OR IT
WOULD NOT EVEN BE AFFORDABLE.
THE MANHATTAN INSTITUTE RECENTLY
REPORTED THAT THE NEARLY ONE
MILLION CALIFORNIA HOUSEHOLDS SO
EXPERIENCED.
ENERGY OF POVERTY IN.
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE MEANING THAT
THE DAYS SPENT THE MORE THAN 10%
OF THEIR DISPOSABLE INCOME ON
ELECTRICITY AND UP NATURAL GAS.
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY AS ARE
ALREADY A CRISIS ARE IN
CALIFORNIA.
WHY WAS THIS A BODY DOUBLE DOWN
AND THE FURTHER INCREASES
[inaudible]
COSTS ON STRUGGLING CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES.
WHEN ARE WE GOING TO RECOGNIZE
THAT THAT THE POLICY IS SO
ADOPTED THE HERE HAVE A DRASTIC
ON INTENDED TO CONSEQUENCES?
CALIFORNIA ALREADY HOUSE AT RAFT
ALL FOR RENEWABLE ENERGY
MANDATES.
THAT THOUGH WE ARE GOING TO LOSE.
STRUGGLE TO A TEE.
NOW IS NOT THE TIME FOR MORE.
IF YOU ARE CONCERNED.
ASKED WE MANY PEOPLE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT US SAVINGS ARE
AND THE RENEWABLE ENERGY AND
THOUGH COBOL NOT MONOXIDE.
WE VOLUNTARILY YA DO SO.
I STRONGLY URGE AND THE
RESPECTFULLY ASK MY COLLEAGUES
TO JOIN ME IN OPPOSING SP YEAH
[inaudible]
ONE HUNDRED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER KALRA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AND I WANNA THANK OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN DIEGO.
OF PRESENTING THIS BILL AND ARE
SENATE COLLEAGUE LOS ANGELES.
OF MO FOR AUTHORING THE BILL I'M
PROUD TO BE A CO AUTHOR OF OF SP.
ONE HUNDRED AND I THINK WE'VE
ALREADY HEARD FROM OTHER
COLLEAGUES OF HOW PRESSING THE
ISSUE OF GLOBAL CLIMATE CHANGE
IS.
WE KNOW WHAT THE SCIENCES THE
SCIENCE A MATTER WHERE YOU STAND
ON THE POLITICAL SPECTRUM DOES
NOT CHANGE.
LAST WEEK FOR THE FIRST TIME
EVER IN RECORDED HISTORY.
NORTH OF GREENLAND.
THE ARCTIC ICE OF FOOD THE
ARCTIC ICE NORTH OF GREENLAND
BROKE APART.
THIS IS NOT JUST AN EXISTENTIAL
THREAT AS TO WHAT COULD HAPPEN
OR A THEORETICAL THREAT.
THE DAMAGE IS ALREADY AND HAS
ALREADY BEEN DONE.
AND THE DAMAGE WILL CONTINUE TO
BE DONE AS LONG AS WE REFUSE TO
ACT.
AND SO THERE ARE NO MORE
TOMORROWS LEFT WE'VE ALREADY SET
OUR FUTURE GENERATIONS ON A
COURSE A DISASTROUS COURSE.
THAT WE NOW MUST WORK.
NO REALLY BIG ORIGINALLY TO
CHANGE COURSE.
AND AS YOU ONE HUNDRED IS BOLD
BUT THE REALITY IS THAT.
STILL AS YOU IN THE YEARS AHEAD
OF IT STILL IS NOT GONNA BE
SIMPLY ENOUGH WHAT IT DOES IS
SETS EXPECTATION.
IT'S AS THE MARKET EXPECTATIONS
THAT ALLOWS FOR INVESTMENT TO
MOVE US IN A POSITIVE DIRECTION
AND YES POLICIES WE ADOPT HERE
DO HAVE IMPACTED DOES HAVE AN
IMPACT ALL THE PAUSE WE DOT.
HAVE IMPACTS ON CALIFORNIA'S BUT
ALSO WHAT WE DON'T DO.
HAS AN IMPACT ON CALIFORNIANS AS
WELL.
SO WE MUST ENSURE THAT WE'RE
DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN. TO MOVE
US IN A POSITIVE DIRECTION.
WE CANNOT IGNORE NOT JUST THE
SCIENCE NUYS ECONOMIC VITALITY
OF SP.
ONE HUNDRED OTHER COUNTRIES ARE
INVESTING HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS
OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS INTO
CLEAN ENERGY.
COMING FROM SILICON VALLEY I
KNOW THAT SILICON VALLEY AND THE
WHOLE STATE.
AS EXCITED ABOUT THE OPPORTUNITY
TO INVEST IN RENEWABLE
TECHNOLOGY IN CLEAN ENERGY WE
MUST GIVE THEM.
THAT REASON TO INVEST WE MUST
SET THE EXPECTATION SO THAT WE
CAN MOVE AWAY FROM FOSSIL FUELS
AND MOVE TOWARDS A CLEAN ENERGY
FUTURE WITH THAT.
I RESPECTFULLY URGE MY
COLLEAGUES TO VOTE YES ON AS TO
ONE HUNDRED AIMS KALRA MISTER
DALLI YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I STAND IN OPPOSITION BUT I WANT
I WANT TO TALK FOR A MINUTE
ABOUT.
DO I WANT TO BE 100% RENEWABLE
ABSOLUTELY I THINK THERE'S
THAT'S A GREAT GOAL [inaudible]
BUT HOW WE DO THAT.
THE DEVIL'S IN THE DETAILS THEY
MATTER.
I WILL SHARE WITH YOU.
WE WENT 250% --
RENEWABLE BY TWENTY THIRTY WE
HAVE THE TWENTY TWENTY GOALS
WHICH WE HAVE MATT.
BUT I WILL SHARE WITH YOU THAT
YOU KNOW IS A COUPLE YEARS AGO
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE WHEN WE
EXTENDED THE SOLAR CONTRACTS.
AND THE TAX CREDITS FOR SOLAR IN
THE STATE.
THERE WAS TO MEMBERS WHO STOOD
UP AND SAID WE DON'T NEED TO DO
THIS YET.
WE NEED TO WAIT IT WAS EVEN UP
IT WAS TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN AND
EXTENDED A TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
THERE'S NO REASON FOR IT WEST
HASBRO.
LIKE MY GOOD COLLEAGUE FROM THE
SECOND ASSEMBLY DISTRICT THEN
SAID HEY.
WE NEED WE NEED TO SLOW DOWN
YOUR LOVE IT SO I WANT TO SHARE
WITH YOU WHAT WE'RE DOING IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW.
WE ARE STE THE RATEPAYERS IN
CALIFORNIA.
WE HAVE THIS THING CALLED THE
DUCK CURVE OF YOU SEE NOT
DOCHARBOR WERE PRODUCING TOO
MUCH ENERGY DURING THE DAY.
AND NOT ENOUGH WHEN THE SUN
ISN'T SHINING IN THE WIND'S NOT
BLOWING.
WE'RE GONNA ADD TO THAT IS HOW
WE DO IT.
THAT MATTERS.
THE RATEPAYERS IN CALIFORNIA ARE
PAYING A BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
RIGHT NOW IN RATES. TO OFFSET
THE COST GOING TO OTHER STATES
BECAUSE WHAT WOULD YOU WOULD YOU
PUT A ONE ELECTRON AND ONE COMES
OUT.
AND WHEN YOU HAVE TOO MANY YOU
HAVE TO SEND IT SOMEWHERE AND
WE'RE SENDING OUR ELECTRICITY.
TO ARIZONA TO NEVADA TO OREGON
AND WE'RE PAYING TO DO THAT AND
IT'S DRIVING THE COSTA.
MANY REMEMBER WHEN I WAS ON THE
ENERGY COMMITTEE I TALK ABOUT MY
MOM'S PGD BILL.
SHE IS LOOKING FOR NEW ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BECAUSE IT'S GOING TO AYE
AND ACTUALLY SHE MOVED ARIZONA.
SHE GIVES HIM THAT FREE ENERGY
THAT WERE PAID FOR NOW IN
ARIZONA.
THIS IS POLICY IS NOT THE TIME
IT'S NOT PUT WELL THOUGHT OUT.
THE TIMING OF WHEN WE USE THOSE
ELECTRONS AND I WILL GUARANTEE
YOU WE PASSED THIS THAT THE
RATES WILL GO UP AND WE'RE NOT
GOING TO TAKE AWAY FROM THE
CLIMATE.
THAT GOAL IS TO REDUCE CARBON IN
THE ATMOSPHERE.
WHAT GOT YOU THIS GO ON THE
PORTICO LOOK THEIR SMOKE ALL
OVER THE PLACE IT'S FROM FOR
SPIRE?
THIS WILL DO NOTHING TO CURB
THAT CARBON.
WHICH IS THE NUMBER ONE A MINUTE
OF CARBON IN THE WORLD.
SO MEMBERS I STE I THINK THIS IS
THE WRONG TIME HASN'T BEEN WELL
THOUGHT OUT DO I WANT TO GET
THERE SOMEDAY I DO.
BUT THIS IS NOT THE TIME.
CALIFORNIANS CANNOT AFFORD IT
AND WE'RE NOT DOING THE RIGHT
THING AT THE BOTTOM AT THE SAME
TIME I I URGE YOU KNOW VOTE.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THIS IN THE
FUTURE WHERE WE CAN ACTUALLY LAY
OUT A PLAN THAT WE'RE NOT.
PAYING OTHER STATES TO TAKE OUR
LECTURES THE WE'RE NOT REALLY
REALLY MIAMI HERE.
WHERE IT'S A FEEL GOOD YOU'RE
GONNA GO HOME TO SAY WE PASSED
IT AND WE'RE LEADING?
THE COST IS GOING TO DESTROY THE
STATE.
IT'S NOT THE RIGHT TIME URGENT
OBOE.
SURE GLORIA YOU'RE RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
THIS MORNING IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB ONE HUNDRED AS ONE OF ITS
CO AUTHORS.
APPRECIATION OF THE SENATOR FROM
LOS ANGELES FOR INTRODUCING IT.
OF MEMBERS ARE WE HAVE HEARD THE
ARGUMENTS AGAINST --
THE OUR PS OF FOR OVER A DECADE.
AND EACH OF THOSE ARGUMENTS OVER
TIME HAS BEEN SYSTEMATIC PROVEN
TO BE INCORRECT.
THEY'LL SAY ON THE ONE HAND IT'S
IMPOSSIBLE AND YET HERE WE ARE.
CAN WE NOT ONLY MEETING THOSE
GOALS BUT OFTEN EXCEEDING THEM
AHEAD OF SCHEDULE THEY SAY THAT
IT'LL RUIN OUR ECONOMY AND YET
ALL OF US TAKE GREAT PRIDE IN
HELPING TO LEAD THE FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY.
IN THE WORLD.
WE KNOW THAT THIS COMMITMENT TO
OUR ENVIRONMENT IS A PART OF
WHAT SETS US APART AS THE GOLDEN
STATE IT'S WHAT IS A PART OF OUR
QUINTESSENTIAL BRAND AS
CALIFORNIA WE STAND UP FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT WE BELIEVE IN
SCIENCE WE INVEST IN THE FUTURE.
AND THAT'S WHAT S. B. ONE
HUNDRED IS ABOUT AND WHAT HAVE
WE GOT FOR WILL IS YOU'LL GET
SIGNIFICANT DIVIDEND MEMBERS OF
THE FASTEST GROWING ECONOMY IN
THE COUNTRY.
WE HAVE CLEANER AIR BECAUSE OF
OUR COMMITMENT TO OUR CLIMATE
POLICIES AS WELL AS A HALF A
MILLION.
GREEN IT GREEN CLEAN ENERGY JOBS
AND THAT IS THE GROW IT'S THE
FASTEST GROWING PART OF OUR JOB
MARKET HERE IN CALIFORNIA
MEMBERS THIS WAS NO ACCIDENT.
IT WAS THE CONSCIOUS DECISION OF
OUR PREDECESSORS IN THE
LEGISLATURE TO SET US ON THIS
PATH AND NOW WE'RE BEING ASKED
TO TAKE THE NEXT STEP AND I
BELIEVE THAT WE SHOULD.
BECAUSE EXACTLY THOSE FOLKS WHO
SAID NO THAT WE COULD NOT DO
WOULD HAVE BEEN PROVEN WRONG
BECAUSE THE DIRE CONSEQUENCES
HAVE NOT PROVEN TO BE TRUE.
AND BECAUSE THE ALTERNATIVE OF
DOING NOTHING IS SO ABSOLUTELY
TERRIBLE.
BUT EXCITED ABOUT THE NUMBERS I
WANT TO TALK ONLY TO HEAR FROM
MY OWN COMMUNITY WHEN I SERVED
AS THE MAYOR OF SAN DIEGO I
INTRODUCED THE CLIMAX A PLAN TO
COMMIT SAN DIEGO TO MOVING
21100% RENEWABLE ENERGY.
THAT WAS IN TWENTY FOURTEEN FAST
FORWARD TO TODAY WORTH BY THREE
OF THE FIVE CITIES IN MY
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT HAVE ALREADY
MADE THIS COMMITMENT
[inaudible]
BY.
CASTING THE STATE'S A LOT IN
WITH THE SMALLER COMMUNITIES
THEY COULD WE CAN HELP THEM
ACTUALLY ACHIEVE THESE GOALS
THAT THEY'VE ALREADY COMMITTED
THEMSELVES.
TO THINK ABOUT WHAT THE MARKET
SIGNAL THAT WE WILL SEND A TO
FOLKS WHO ARE PINE NEARING THE
TECHNOLOGY TO MAKE THIS POSSIBLE
TO DO THIS WORK.
WE MUST PUT OURSELVES OUT THERE
TO DO THIS BECAUSE AS WE SEE
EVERY SINGLE DAY THE
CONSEQUENCES OF CLIMATE INACTION
ARE ALL AROUND US IT JUST IN MY
OWN DISTRICT OVER THE SUMMER
WE'VE.
MEASURED EIGHTY DEGREE WATER
TEMPERATURE THE HIGHEST EVER
RECORDED OFF THE COAST OF THE
SEVENTY EIGHT ASSEMBLY DISTRICT.
THIS IS THE FACTS AS WE KNOW
THEM.
BUT THE ARGUMENTS AGAINST THIS
HAVE NEVER BEEN PROVEN CORRECT.
AND THE FAX AGAINST NOT DOING IT
ARE SO VERY MUCH IN OUR FACE
THAT WE CANNOT IGNORE.
AND WE CANNOT FAIL TO ACT SO
MEMBERS I ASK YOU TO SUPPORT THE
SMALLER COMMUNITIES ACROSS OUR
STATE THAT ARE ALREADY MAKING
THIS GOAL FOR THEMSELVES.
LET'S TAKE FIRM ACTION TO GROW
OUR ECONOMY INTO STIMULATED
FURTHER AND CREATE MORE JOBS
HELP PEOPLE TO REDUCE THEIR
ENERGY COSTS BY ALLOWING THEM TO
GO TO SOLAR AND OTHER FORMS.
OF INERT CLEAN ENERGY AND LASTLY
LET'S DO IT FOR OUR CHILDREN AND
OUR GRANDCHILDREN WHO ARE GOING
TO UNDOUBTEDLY PAY THE PRICE OF
THE CARBON ECONOMY THAT WE ARE
TRYING. TO TO NOT LEAVE THEM
LET'S MOVE IN ANOTHER DIRECTION
WE MUST DO THIS TODAY I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS VERY
IMPORTANT PIECE OF LEGISLATION
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
THANK YOU AS GLORIA.
CARILLO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT AS A CO AUTHOR OF S. B.
ONE HUNDRED AND THINK MY STATE
SENATOR.
FROM LOS ANGELES BURN IT
INTRODUCING THIS LEGISLATION AS
WELL AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
DIEGO FOR BRING IT UP TO THIS
FLOOR.
MY DISTRICT IS CRISSCROSSED BY
SIX MAJOR FREEWAYS AND MAJOR
TAILPIPE EMITTER SOME UGLY
POLLUTION THAT OUR KIDS BREATHE.
INTO THEIR LUNGS EVERY DAY FOR
ALL OF YOU THAT LOVE TO GO TO A
DODGER GAME.
I ALSO ENCOURAGE YOU TO GO ON A
RIDE ALONG WITH ME ON THE FIVE
THE TEN THE ONE TEN THE FIXED
THE THE ONE THIRTY FOUR OR THE
TO FREEWAYS AND SEE HOW IT.
CRISS CROSSES ALL OVER THE
EIGHTY THE DISTRICT THE CARBON I
THINK OUR GREATEST LOW HANGING
FRUIT IT IS THE EASIEST THING
THAT WE CAN DO.
OUR STATE HAS ALREADY HARDNESS
CLEAN ENERGY THROUGH GREEN
TECHNOLOGY SUCH AS HYDRO POWER
WIND TURBINES AND SOLAR PANELING.
THIS IS THE FUTURE OF ENERGY
PRODUCTION WE NEED TO MAKE ARE
CUTTING IT INNOVATION THE
STANDARD THROUGH INCREASED USE
OF NEW METHODS OF ENERGY
PRODUCTION LIKE BIOMASS.
AND GEOTHERMAL PLANTS. 1100%
RENEWABLE ENERGY MEANS THE
CLEANER AND BRIGHTER FUTURE FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS IT IS OUR
RESPONSIBILITY AND OUR DUTY. TO
ALL RESIDENTS TO ENSURE SAFER
MORE SUSTAINABLE TECHNOLOGY.
THAT IS USEFUL TO POWER OUR
SCHOOLS ARE HOMES BUSINESSES AND
SO MUCH MORE.
I AM SURE THAT TOGETHER WE CAN
HELP CREATE THOUSANDS OF HIGH
QUALITY JOBS AND ENSURE THAT WE
CONTINUE TO CLEAN ENTERED.
THE CONTINUE TO LEAD THE CLEAN
ENERGY DEVELOPMENT THROUGHOUT
THE PRODUCTION OF 1100% CARBON
FREE ELECTRICITY.
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW THE AREAS OF
OUR STATE HIT HARDEST BY
POLLUTION AND POOR HEALTH IS
OFTEN.
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES AND LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
S. B..
ONE HUNDRED WILL MAKE GREAT
STRIDES TO GUARANTEED THEM THE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE THAT THEY
DESERVE.
OUR STATE HAVE ALREADY FAR
SURPASSED THEIR PREVIOUS TARGETS
FOR CLEAN ENERGY AND CLIMATE
CHANGE PREVENTION.
WE ARE CURRENTLY ON TRACK TO
DELIVER 50% OF ENERGY FROM
RENEWABLE OR ZERO CARBON SOURCES
BY.
TWENTY TWENTY WELL I KNOW THAT
TWENTY FORTY FIVE MAY SEEM LIKE
A LONG TIME FROM NOW TIME GOES
BY REALLY QUICKLY.
SB ONE HUNDRED ESTABLISHES A
CLEAR MESSAGE THAT CALIFORNIA'S
COMMITTED TO ACTING WITH URGENCY
AND SPEED REQUIRE TO ADDRESS
CLIMATE CHANGE AND THE
CARBONIZED.
ARE CONDAMINE OUR DRIVE TO
SECURE A BRIGHTER SAFER MORE
SUSTAINABLE FUTURE WILL HELP
INSPIRE SIMILAR CHANGE.
ACROSS THE COUNTRY ENOUGH
CALIFORNIA GOES SO DOES THE
NATION AS THE UNITED STATES GOES
SO DOES THE WORLD WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY.
CREATE AMAZING CHANGE IN OUR
STATE AND REALLY LEAD THE WAY SO
I I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE ON SB ONE HUNDRED THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MS GRILL MISTER
THURMAN CURE RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
SB ONE HUNDRED PROUD TO BE A CO
AUTHOR.
AND I AM PROUD TO ADD MY VOICE --
IN -- UNISON
WITH THOSE THAT YOU'VE HEARD
FROM IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE --
YOU KNOW THE LANGUAGE OF THIS
BILL IS COMPLEX.
BUT IT'S MESSAGES IS VERY SIMPLE.
IT SIMPLY SAYS THAT WE SHOULD
HELP TO CREATE A BETTER TOMORROW.
IT SAYS THAT THE CLOCK IS
TICKING.
AS WE CONTINUE TO SEE.
NEGATIVE IMPACTS ON OUR
ENVIRONMENT.
AND THAT WE'VE GOT TO MAKE A
DECISION NOW ABOUT WHAT WE ARE
GOING TO DO SLOW DOWN THAT CLOCK.
TO PRESERVE FOR OUR CHILDREN AND
FOR OUR CHILDREN'S CHILDREN AND
FOR FUTURE.
CALIFORNIANS AND IN MANY WAYS
FOR OURSELVES.
YES THERE IS PROBABLY SOME PRICE
TO WHAT THIS MEASURE ASK.
FOR BUT I'D ASK YOU THIS.
WHAT PRICE WOULD YOU PUT?
ON A GOOD QUALITY OF LIFE.
WHAT PRICE WOULD YOU PUT ON A
GOOD QUALITY OF LIFE THIS BILL
SAYS?
THAT WE SHOULD DO EVERYTHING IN
OUR POWER [inaudible] TO PROVIDE.
A GOOD QUALITY OF LIFE
[inaudible]
ITS ASPIRATIONAL.
IT IS SEEKING TO DO THE BEST.
AND MAYBE WE WON'T GET THERE.
IN THE YEARS THAT HAVE BEEN SET
AS TARGETS MAYBE WE WON'T GET
THERE AND TWENTY TWENTY SIX
MAYBE WE'LL GET THERE BY.
TWENTY FORTY FIVE WHY NOT STRIVE
FOUR WHAT IS THE BEST.
WHEN WE KNOW THAT WE ARE SEEING
A DETERIORATION IN OUR
ENVIRONMENT?
WELL WE KNOW THAT WE'VE SEEN THE
MELTING OF THE SNOW PACK WHEN WE
KNOW THAT WE'VE SEEN.
CHALLENGES AND OUR AIR QUALITY
MORE WE KNOW THAT WE'RE FACING.
SEA LEVEL RISE AND OTHER
CHALLENGES IN OUR ENVIRONMENT.
MY TWELVE YEAR OLD DAUGHTER SAYS
THAT SHE'S A SCIENTISTS.
AND SHE OTHER ANYTHING IN
RESEARCH.
OR ANY PUBLICATIONS BUT EVEN SHE
KNOWS THAT CLIMATE CHANGE IS
REAL.
IF REST TO THE NOT SCIENCE AND
WHAT'S BEFORE US.
IS REALLY IRRESPONSIBLE IN IF
YOU'RE NOT A SCIENTIST.
NOT SO MY DAUGHTER IF YOU GONNA
BE A SCIENTIST IS TO RULES CLEAN
UP AFTER YOUR EXPERIMENTS AND
DON'T BLOW UP OUR HOUSE.
BUT SHE UNDERSTANDS THAT WE NEED
TO DO SOMETHING. FOR HERSELF AND
FOR FUTURE GENERATIONS.
EVEN IF YOU DON'T KNOW ANY
SCIENTIFIC THEORY YOU KNOW
COMMON SENSE AS YOU CAN SEE THAT
IT'S GETTING HOTTER.
THE TEMPERATURES HAVE BEEN MORE
EXTREME THAN WE'VE EVER EVER
SEEN.
WHEN I WAS ON THE CITY COUNCIL?
WE STARTED A CONSTRUCTION JOB
TRAINING PROGRAM THAT FEATURED
SOLAR PANEL INSTALLATION.
AND WE WORK CLOSELY WITH OUR
BUILDING TRADES IN OUR LOCAL
COMPANIES TO MAKE THAT AVAILABLE
TO OUR CONSUMERS.
AND IT BECAME THIS GREAT
OPPORTUNITY TO DO SOMETHING GOOD
FOR THE ENVIRONMENT AND TO
PROMOTE ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE UNDEREMPLOYED. TO
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK IN.
I BELIEVE THAT THIS IS THE SAME
OPPORTUNITY FOR US THESE ARE NOT
MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE GOALS WE CAN
PRESERVE OUR ENVIRONMENT.
AND PROMOTE CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AT THE SAME
TIME CALIFORNIA IS A LEADER IN
RESEARCH AND TECHNOLOGY AROUND.
RENEWABLE ENERGY AROUND NEW
PATENTS WERE NEW FORMS OF CLEAN
ENERGY AND THIS IS OUR
OPPORTUNITY FOR CALIFORNIA TO
LEAD NOT JUST THE NATION BUT THE
WORLD WITH THE ACTIONS THAT WE
TAKE.
AND WE DON'T GET THERE BY TWENTY
FORTY FIVE WE CAN ALWAYS DEVISE
THIS BUT I ASK YOU AGAIN WHAT'S
THE PRICE YOU WOULD PUT.
ON A GREAT QUALITY OF LIFE I
SUBMIT TO YOU THAT THIS IS OUR
OPPORTUNITY TO HELP PROVIDE THAT
FOR ALL OF OUR CHILDREN AND OUR
CHILDREN'S CHILDREN.
AND TO HAVE A QUALITY OF LIFE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON THIS BE.
ONE HUNDRED THANK YOU MS THURMAN
DOCTOR QUIRK.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU SPEAKER.
SO I HEAR A NUMBER.
OF CONCERNS HERE.
BUT I DON'T HEAR ANYONE DENYING
CLIMATE CHANGE.
AND THAT'S PROGRESS. ONE OF THE
ONE THING THAT'S BEEN BROUGHT UP
BY PARTICULARLY THE MEMBER FROM
BEAVER ARE REPUBLICAN LEADER.
WHAT'S THE CONCERN ABOUT FIRES.
AND THAT IS IN IN THIS BILL.
BUT I GUESS.
MANY OF US HAVE BEEN WORKING
WITH.
THE LEADER WITH THE MEMBER FOR
BEAVER AND WILL CONTINUE TO WORK.
DO SOMETHING ABOUT FIRE AND
BRING BACK THOSE BIOMASS PLANTS
SO WE HAVE A PLACE TO PUT.
THE DEBRIS FROM THE FOREST THAT
WERE THINNING.
SO THAT'S THAT'S THAT THAT'S
WITH THIS WE'RE GOING TO DO THAT.
THE OTHER THING I HEAR ABOUT IS
IS THIS REALLY FEASIBLE.
I I AM A SCIENTIST AND I KNOW
HOW DIFFICULT THIS IS IT'S GOING
TO BE MUCH HARDER TO GO FROM 33%.
250%.
TO SEVENTY FIVE TWO HUNDRED BUT
THIS BILL AND I WOULDN'T SUPPORT
IT IF IT WEREN'T IN HERE
SPECIFICALLY SAT.
THAT THE COMMISSION SHALL
MAINTAIN AND PROTECT THE SAFETY
RELIABLE OPERATION AND BALLOTS
YOU NEED THE ELECTRIC SYSTEM.
THIS IS WHAT'S KNOWN AS AN OFF
RAMP IF WE CAN'T HAVE RELIABLE
ELECTRICITY WE'RE NOT GONNA DO
THIS.
AND I DON'T KNOW WHETHER WE CAN
OR NOT.
BUT THIS IS A WAY TO GET US TO
TRY.
SO THAT'S IN THEIR IN IF IT
WEREN'T IN THERE I WOULD BE
SUPPORTING IT.
THE SECOND THING.
THAT'S IN THERE IS COST
CONTAINMENT.
AND AGAIN IF IT WEREN'T IN THERE
I WOULD NOT BE SUPPORTING IT.
BUT IT'S IN THERE.
AND PARTICULARLY IT SAYS THE
COMMISSION WILL LOOK AT EACH
ELECTRICAL OUR UTILITY.
AND IT WILL DETERMINE THAT THERE
SHALL NOT BE DISPROPORTIONATE
INCREASES [inaudible]
IN [inaudible]
OUR COST [inaudible]
FURTHER IT TALKS ABOUT THE
MINIMALIST CHANGES IN COST LATER
ON AND AGAIN IF IT WEREN'T IN
THERE I WOULD BE SUPPORTIVE.
SO THIS IS PROTECTING OUR
ELECTRICAL GRID THIS IS
PROTECTING [inaudible]
ARE CONSUMERS [inaudible]
AND FURTHER.
WE ARE JUST SEEN SO MANY IMPACTS
[inaudible]
CLIMATE.
THAT I CAN TELL YOU WHEN WE
LOOKED AT THIS IN THE SEVENTIES
THAT WE NOT.
WE JUST DIDN'T ANTICIPATE.
THE MEMBER FROM GLENDALE VERY
ACCURATELY SHED WE HAD NO IDEA
HOW FAST THINGS WOULD CHANGE AND
WE HAD NO IDEA.
THAT YOU COULD GET FIRE
TORNADOES.
AND WHY ARE WE GETTING THESE.
IT'S VERY SUBTLE.
BUT WHAT'S REALLY ONE OF THE
BIGGEST PROBLEMS WE HAVE WITH
FIRE [inaudible]
IS THAT.
WHEN YOU GET GREENHOUSE WARMING?
WHEN YOU GET WARMING FROM
GREENHOUSE GASES?
IF PREFERENTIALLY KEEPS THE
TEMPERATURES UP AT NIGHT MORE
THAN THE DAY.
WHAT THAT MEANS IS WE'RE NOT
GETTING A COOLER NIGHT WHEN YOU
GET PATRICIA WHEN YOU GET
[inaudible]
ARE DO.
AND YOU GET SOME WETNESS AND THE
FIREFIGHTERS USED TO SAY LOW THE
FIRES GO TO BED AT NIGHT THEY
DON'T ANYMORE.
AND THAT'S WHY WE SEATS UP THAT
SUCH TERRIBLE --
DAMAGE AROUND READING AND AROUND
OTHER PARTS OF OUR OF OUR GREAT
STATE AND WE'RE GOING TO SEE
THIS IS NOT THE NEW NORMAL IT'S
JUST GONNA GET WORSE.
SO WE HAVE TO BE A LEADER WE
HAVE TO SHOW WHAT CAN BE DONE IF
WE CAN GET TO A 100% RENEWABLES
OTHERS WELL IT'S WELL.
PLEASE SUPPORT SB.
ONE HUNDRED THANK YOU DOCTOR
QUIRK [inaudible]
MS RACE.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
I TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB.
ONE HUNDRED AS A PROUD CO AUTHOR.
CLIMATE CHANGE ISN'T JUST AN
ENVIRONMENTAL CAUSE PRICES BUT A
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS AS WELL.
THAT'S WHY BROAD COALITION OF
PUBLIC HEALTH EXPERTS ARE YOU
URGING THE PASSAGE OF SB.
ONE HUNDRED PUTTING CALIFORNIA
ON A PATH 21100% CLEAN ENERGY IS
PUTTING CALIFORNIA ON A PATH TO
SUBSTANTIALLY.
CLEANER AIR FUTURE.
THAT'S WHY THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION IN CALIFORNIA
STRONGLY SUPPORTS SP.
ONE HUNDRED CARVING A PATH TO A
CLEAN ENERGY GRANT WILL LEAD TO
CLEANER AIR AND HEALTHIER LONGS
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
RIGHT NOW OUR LUNGS ARE BEING
THREATENED BY AIR POLLUTION.
ACCORDING TO THE LUNG
ASSOCIATION STATE OF THE AIR OF
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN REPORT.
CALIFORNIA HAS THE DUBIOUS
DISTINCTION OF BEING HOME TO THE
MAJORITY THE TOP TEN U. S.
CITIES THE WORST.
OZONE AND PARTICLE POLLUTION.
CHILDREN ARE PARTICULARLY
VULNERABLE TO THE RISKS FROM
POLLUTION MADE WORSE BY CLIMATE
CHANGE.
THEIR LUNGS AND THEIR BODIES
DEFENSES ARE STILL DEVELOPING.
AND THEY BREED MORE AIR PER
POUND THAN ADULTS. FOR MANY
SENIORS ARE POLLUTION CAN BE
DEADLY.
CLIMATE CHANGE HAS AN ESPECIALLY
DANGEROUS IMPACT ON LOW IMPACT
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
THESE COMMUNITIES ARE MORE
SUSCEPTIBLE TO HEALTH THREATS
BECAUSE OF WHERE THEY LIVE OR
WORK.
INCLUDING YOUR PLACES THAT HAVE
HIGHER LEVELS OF POLLUTION OR
BECAUSE THEY HAVE A HARDER TIME
GETTING MEDICAL CARE.
LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS ARE MORE
LIKELY TO HAVE CHRONIC DISEASES
LIKE ASTHMA AND FACE GREATER
CHALLENGES COPING WITH EXTREME
WEATHER EVENTS.
THE REALITY IS CLIMATE CHANGE IS
ONE OF THE GREATEST PUBLIC
HEALTH CHALLENGES OF OUR TIME.
TO MEET THE CHALLENGE AND
PROVIDE OUR CHILDREN WITH A
HEALTHIER FUTURE WE MUST
TRANSFORM THE WAY WE PRODUCE AND
CONSUME ENERGY.
AFTER YEARS OF INCREASING OUR
RENEWABLE ENERGY [inaudible]
TARGETS.
IT'S TIME TO THINK BIG AND PUT
OUR GREAT STATE ON A PATH TO ONE
HUNDRED CAN PERCENT CLEAN ENERGY.
FOR OUR CHILDREN WHEN FOR FUTURE
GENERATIONS.
AYE URGENT AYE VOTE.
HE WAS RESIDENTS HER OBERNOLTE.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
MISTER SPEAKER I DON'T THINK A
SINGLE MEMBER OF THIS BODY WOULD
DISAGREE.
WITH THE NEED TO INCREASE
RENEWABLE ENERGY GENERATION IN
CALIFORNIA I DON'T THINK A
SINGLE MEMBER WOULD DISAGREE
WITH THAT.
BUT THE CONCERN THAT A LOT OF US
ARE RAISING.
IS THAT WE HAVE TO HAVE A
CREDIBLE PLAN FOR GETTING US
FROM WHERE WE ARE. TO WHERE WE
WANT TO BE.
WE NEED TO COME UP WITH A PLAN
THAT STRIKES A REASONABLE
BALANCE BETWEEN.
THE GOAL WE'RE TRYING TO ACHIEVE.
AND THE COST OF THE IMPACTS OF
OUR STATE.
AND UNFORTUNATELY THIS BULL THIS
BILL DOESN'T EVEN COME CLOSE TO
DOING THAT.
BUT LET'S START BY TALKING ABOUT
WHAT IT WOULD BE REQUIRED TO GET
US 2100% RENEWABLES.
WE ALREADY OVER GENERATE FROM
RENEWABLES DURING THE DAY.
AND WE UNDER GENERATE AT NIGHT
GETTING 21100% WOULD REQUIRE US
TO ADD AN INCREDIBLE AMOUNT.
OF ENERGY STORAGE AND WE HIT
RIGHT NOW HAVE NO PLAN ON HOW TO
DO THAT WE DON'T EVEN KNOW IF
IT'S POSSIBLE TO DO THAT.
DON'T WE OWE IT TO CALIFORNIANS
TO AT LEAST HAVE THOUGHT OUT HOW
WE'RE GOING TO GET THERE.
BEFORE WE WRITE THIS RULE IN
STONE THERE WERE TO GET 2100%.
BUT I HAVE AN EVEN BIGGER
CONCERN.
WITH THIS PROPOSAL.
AND MY CONCERN INVOLVES A TOPIC
THAT'S BEEN RAISED BY NUMBER OF
THE PROPONENTS OF THE BILL IN
THIS DEBATE AND THAT'S
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE.
WE HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE MANDATES THAT WE
PASS IN THIS CHAMBER DO NOT FALL
DISPROPORTIONATELY ON THE
PORTION OF OUR STATE THAT CAN
LEAST AFFORD IT [inaudible]
AND UNFORTUNATELY MANY OF THE
THINGS WE DO IN THIS CHAMBER DO
THAT.
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE THE HIGHEST
POVERTY RATE OF ANY STATE.
IN THE COUNTRY AND ACCORDING TO
US CENSUS BUREAU THE REASON FOR
THAT POVERTY PREDOMINANTLY IS
THE HIGH COST OF LIVING HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
NOW IT'S BEEN ASSERTED.
BY THE PROPONENTS OF THIS BILL
THAT PREVIOUSLY PREVIOUS
INCREASES IN THE RENEWABLE
PORTFOLIO STANDARD.
HAVE NOT RESULTED IN THE THE
CONSEQUENCES THAT THE DETRACTORS
SAID I COMPLETELY DISAGREE WITH
THAT. ONE OF THE PRIMARY OUR
CONCERNS THAT WE HAD WHEN WE
RAISE THIS PORTFOLIO STANDARD
THE PAST.
IS THAT ELECTRICITY RATES WOULD
GO UP AND THEY HAVE.
NO ONE CAN DISPUTE THAT THEY
HAVE RIGHT NOW.
THE AVERAGE CONSUMER IN
CALIFORNIA PAYS 40% MORE FOR
ELECTRICITY THAN THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE.
AND FOR INDUSTRIAL ELECTRICITY
IT'S ALMOST 80% MORE.
THOSE COSTS ARE BORNE.
BY THE PAY MORE IN OUR STATE AND
EVERY TIME WE ADOPT ANOTHER
MANDATE ANOTHER REGULATION THAT
RAISES THE COST OF LIVING HERE.
INEVITABLY WE DRIVE A GREATER
PERCENTAGE OF OUR POPULATION IN
A POVERTY.
I WOULD SUPPORT.
THE BALANCE PROPOSAL THAT HAVE A
CREDIBLE PLAN FOR GETTING US
2100% WITHOUT PASSING THOSE
COSTS ON TO CONSUMERS BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THIS BILL DOES NOT
ACHIEVE THAT BALANCE I URGE A NO
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE MISS
WALDRON.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS --
YOU KNOW WE'VE HAD A A A LOT OF
FOR I THINK --
MANAGEMENT POLICIES IN THIS
STATE WHEN IT COMES TO THANK YOU
ARE HELPING THE ENVIRONMENT
THINKING WE'RE DOING THINGS THAT
ARE GONNA HAVE AN IMPACT BUT
THEY ACTUALLY HAVE AN ADVERSE
AFFECT JUST LOOK AT THE FIRES
WE'VE DONE MORE EMISSIONS INTO
THE AIR.
THIS YEAR WITH A MILLION PLUS
ACRES BURNED.
THROUGH POLICIES THAT YOU KNOW
IN AN EFFORT TO TRY.
TO HEALTH THE ENVIRONMENT
ACTUALLY HEARD OF WORSE --
ELECTRIC ELECTRICITY RATES ARE
JUST GONNA GO UP WITH THIS
LEGISLATION ONCE AGAIN --
I'M A BUSINESSOWNER I HAVE A
MANUFACTURING RETAIL BUSINESS
ALREADY PAY SUPER HIGH RATES THE
GET HAVE TO BE PASSED ON TO MY
CUSTOMERS IN MY PRODUCT --
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS ALREADY PAY
AMONG THE HIGHEST PER KILOWATT
HOUR RATES FOR ENERGY IN THE
NATION.
AS OF APRIL LAST YEAR OF
INDUSTRIAL RATE PAYERS PAY A
PREMIUM OF 68% FOR ELECTRICITY
AND 73% FOR NATURAL GAS.
OVER THE NATIONAL AVERAGE THAT'S
OVER IN THE NATIONAL AVERAGE.
BUSINESSES FARMING FOOD
PROCESSING CUSTOMERS PAY A
SIMILAR PREMIUM WHICH IMPACT
THEIR ABILITY TO BE COMPETITIVE.
IN THE NATIONAL AND
INTERNATIONAL MARKETS ADDITIONAL
MANDATE WITH ANOTHER GOAL ON TOP
OF ANOTHER GOAL COMPLICATES AND
INCREASES COST RATEPAYERS AND
ALL CLASSES AND GUESS WHAT.
IT'S ARE HARD WORKING CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES THAT ARE GOING TO PAY
ONCE AGAIN SO I URGE A NO VOTE.
THEY WAS WATER MISTER BRO
[inaudible]
THERE RECOGNIZE.
YEAH THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER --
I RISE IN OPPOSITION BUT I WANNA
GO BACK AND LOOK AT A LITTLE
HISTORY HERE SO I THINK UP.
IF YOU BACK TO THE NINETEEN
NINETIES A LOT A NEW
ENVIRONMENTAL POLICIES CAME UP
WHERE.
WE LET TREES DIE NATURALLY --
IN DECAY IN THE FOREST WE RAN
THE LOGGERS OUT OF CALIFORNIA
THAT USE TO OPEN UP THESE
FIREBREAKS FOR US.
AND IN THE MID NINETIES
PRESIDENT CLINTON WAS --
ROUNDLY CRITICIZED BY THE
ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY FOR
LETTING A FIRE BURNING
YELLOWSTONE.
BUT I AFTER THAT FIRE FIVE YEARS
LATER HE WAS PROVEN CORRECT WITH
THE SOOT.
AND THE FUEL IN THERE.
PRODUCED A NEW ROUND OF SAPLING.
AND I WOULD --
I WOULD SAY THAT THE FIRES AND
EVERYTHING WERE HAVING RIGHT NOW
IS A DIRECT RESULT OF THESE
FAILED POLICIES FROM THE
NINETEEN NINETIES.
WE CAN HAVE THE BEST.
POLICY WE HAD AB THIRTY TWO
WE'VE INCREASED WE WANT TO
INCREASE AGAIN WE CAN HAVE THE
PERFECT [inaudible]
POLICY.
BUT UNTIL WE GET OUR FORESTS
HEALTHY.
IT'S NOT GONNA WORK BECAUSE THAT
FOREST IS WHAT'S GOING TO TAKE
THE GASES.
OUT OF THE AIR.
SO WE REALLY NEED TO GET THIS
FIRE --
LEGISLATION GOING TO REALLY
CHANGE THE POLICIES AND
MANAGEMENT IN OUR FORESTS.
BUT THE OTHER THING WE NEED TO
DO IS WE NEED TO DIVERSIFY WE'VE
GOT AS WAS SAID TO MUCH
ELECTRICITY --
WE HAVE VERY LITTLE STORAGE WE
NEED TO INVEST IN STORAGE WE
NEED TO INVEST IN BIOMASS.
I HAD A NUCLEAR PLANTS SANTA NOW
FOR CLOSE A DIABLO CANYON
CLOSING THE TWENTY TWENTY SIX
CLEAN NUCLEAR IS GOING TO BE
GONE FROM CALIFORNIA WE NEED
THAT.
NOT RELIANT JUST SOLAR AND WIND
AND THE COOL KIDS THEY GET THE
SUBSIDIES BUT WE REALLY NEED TO
INVEST IN BIOMASS IN SOME OF
THESE OTHER ENERGIES TO HELP US
OUT.
AND ONE FACT IT.
YOU CANNOT DISPUTE IS THAT THIS
DOES INCREASE COST THIS ENTIRE
MONTH I'D BE GETTING CALLS IN MY
DISTRICT OFFICE.
FROM RAT RESIDENTS IN THE
SEVENTY THIRD DISTRICT --
PARTICULARLY PLACES LIKE LADERA
RANCH WHERE PEOPLE ARE PAYING
ELEVEN HUNDRED DOLLAR A MONTH
[inaudible]
ELECTRIC BILLS.
SO THE COST YOU CANNOT DISPUTE.
THAT THIS IS GONNA BE PASSED ON
TO THE RATE PAYERS --
IN CALIFORNIA.
ANOTHER THING WE TALK ABOUT
BEING THE WORLD'S LEADER.
WELL WE ARE THE WORLD LEADER
BECAUSE NO ONE ELSE IN THE WORLD
IS DOING ANYTHING CHINA INDIA
THESE OTHER MATTERS.
ARE THE WILD WILD WEST WHILE WE
PENALIZE OUR OWN COMPANIES WHO
ARE DOING THE RIGHT THING.
SO CHINA AND INDIA CAN
MANUFACTURE PRODUCTS IN GOODS
AND SERVICES AND SELLING CHEAPER
THAN OUR CALIFORNIA AND U. S.
COMPANIES.
AND I DON'T THINK CALIFORNIA
RATEPAYERS SHOULD FOOT THE BILL
FOR THE REST OF WORLD SO LAST
FOR NO VOTE.
DOCTOR WOULD YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE I'M I RISE TO
SUPPORT SB.
ONE HUNDRED BUT I WANT TO POINT
OUT SOME SOME THINGS THAT HAVE
BEEN POINT OUT BY A LOT OF
PEOPLE HERE TODAY --
IN MY DISTRICT WE HAVE WE HAVE
BIOMASS WHICH I KNOW TO SOME
PEOPLE IS A IS A PROBLEM.
WE HAVE AYE GEOTHERMAL ENERGY
[inaudible]
WHICH DOESN'T GET ENJOYED SOME
THE SUBSIDIES THAT THAT WE SEE
WITH WIND AND SOLAR.
BUT THOSE TWO ENERGY SOURCES
PROVIDE BASELINE ENERGY THEY
DON'T REQUIRED SUN THEY DON'T
REQUIRE THE WIND AND THEY'RE
THERE ALL THE TIME.
ANY OTHER MORE EXPENSIVE.
BUT THEY ARE PART OF THE ENTIRE
PORTFOLIO AND I THINK WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO LOOK CLOSELY AT THAT
AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
I ALSO HAVE REPRESENT A
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE UP A
PUBLIC UTILITY THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA POWER AUTHORITY AND
POWER AGENCY.
AND THEY HAVE.
LARGE LARGE GEOTHERMAL I'M NOT I
MEAN EXCUSE ME LARGE A LARGE
HYDRO.
THAT DOESN'T ACCOUNTED.
I UNDERSTAND THAT THAT BOAT
SAILED ALONG TIME AGO --
BUT AS A AS A CITY COUNCIL
MEMBERS SITTING HEALDSBURG IF WE
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO COUNT OUR
LARGE HYDRO.
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN PUT US IN
THE PROBABLY 64% RENEWABLE --
AND THAT WAS SEVERAL YEARS AGO.
SO THAT THAT THAT SALE BY GET IT
AND AND WORK AND I'M I CAN LIVE
WITH THAT --
I GREW UP IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
I EXPERIENCED THAT POOR AIR
QUALITY OF AIR POLLUTION IN PART
TAILPIPE EMISSIONS AND I I GET
THAT.
I MOVED OUT OF THEIR TO THE
CLEAN AIR OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
WHY CLEAN AIR NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW IS PRETTY
AWFUL?
WE'VE BEEN STUCK IN SMOKE FOR
THE LAST THIRTY PLUS DAYS.
A FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY NINE
THOUSAND ACRE FOREST FIRE
STARTED IN MY DISTRICT.
AS 50% LARGER THAN THE LARGEST
FOREST FIRE ON HISTORY WHICH
HAPPENED LAST YEAR.
IN THE IN THE MEMBER FROM SANTA
BARBARA'S DISTRICT.
WE HAVE TO CREATE A BALANCE IF
WE'RE GOING TO DO THIS AND SO
LATER THIS WEEK YOU'RE GONNA GET
A CHANCE. TO HELP US.
SPEND POTENTIALLY PENNIES ON THE
DOLLAR COMPARED WHAT WE SPEND ON
A LOT OF OTHER THINGS. TO HELP
IMPROVE FOREST HEALTH AND AND
AND OUR OUR LAND MANAGEMENT
PENNIES ON THE DOLLAR.
SO I WANT TO SUPPORT THIS AND I
BELIEVE A 100% IN THE MISSION
HERE.
BUT I HOPE AT THE END OF THE DAY
THAT THIS HOUSE RECOGNIZES THAT
THE POOR AIR QUALITY PROBABLY
THE WORST AIR QUALITY IN THE
HISTORY OF MY DISTRICT.
AND THE MINORITY LEADERS
DISTRICT.
WE'VE BEEN EXPERIENCE. FOR A
MONTH.
SO SOME CONSIDERATION THE FUTURE
ABOUT HOW WE GO FORWARD --
WOULD BE APPRECIATED WE'RE GOING
TO CREATE A BALANCE HERE FOR
GOING TO ACTUALLY DO WHAT WE
NEED TO DO THAT'S REDUCE CARBON
OUTPUT.
WE HAVE TO WE HAVE TO LOOK AT
THIS HOLISTICALLY AND AYE AYES
AYE ASPIRIN AYE VOTE TODAY.
BUT I ASK FOR YOU TO REALLY
CONSIDER GOING FORWARD THAT WE
SEE.
INVEST IN THE THINGS THAT WE
KNOW WE'RE GONNA HELP REALLY
OFFSET CARBON IN THE STATE AND
THAT'S REDUCING FIRES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WOOD MISTER
MURATSUCHI.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER.
YOU KNOW AYE WANT.
TO THANK AND ACKNOWLEDGE
ESPECIALLY ALL OF THE COMMENTS
FROM OUR REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES --
ADDRESSING THE CONCERNS ABOUT.
THE ENERGY COSTS THAT
CALIFORNIANS A PAY ARE PAYING
[inaudible]
OUR MANUFACTURERS.
I ALSO WANT ACKNOWLEDGES ALL THE
CONCERNS ABOUT.
THE RAGING FIRES IN CALIFORNIA
AND THE DESPERATE NEED.
THE DOUBLE DOWN ON FORCE
MANAGEMENT.
AND I WANT TO MAKE IT CLEAR.
THAT THOSE CONCERNS ARE
BIPARTISAN CONCERNS.
I'M JUST AS CONCERNED AS ANYONE
ABOUT.
KEEPING OUR ENERGY COSTS UNDER
CONTROL I'M JUST AS CONCERNED
ABOUT ANYONE ABOUT ADDRESSING
THESE RACING CALIFORNIA FIRES.
MANY OF YOU KNOW THAT I HAVE A
LOT OF REPUBLICANS IN MY
DISTRICT [inaudible]
BUT I STAND PROUDLY TODAY AS A
CO AUTHOR OF THIS BILL S. B..
ONE HUNDRED AND LET ME TELL YOU
WHY.
WE HAVE [inaudible]
TO TRUST [inaudible]
SCIENCE.
WE HAVE TO TRUST THE FACTS.
OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF
SCIENTISTS AROUND THE WORLD.
AGREE THAT WE ARE FACING A
GLOBAL CRISIS MAN MADE CLIMATE
CHANGE.
AND MANY OF THOSE SCIENTISTS ARE
SAYING THAT WE HAVE.
PERHAPS ALREADY PASSED THE
TIPPING POINT.
FROM WHAT'S THERE IS NO RETURN.
THE TIPPING POINT [inaudible]
WHEN OUR?
STILL CAPS ARE MELTING.
SEE LEVELS RISING [inaudible]
CLIMB MEN.
I COMING MORE AND MORE EXTREME.
AND WE'RE SEEING THAT RIGHT HERE
IN CALIFORNIA.
WHEN WE HAVE OR EXTENDED
DROUGHTS WHEN WE HAVE?
HOTTEST SUMMERS THAT WE'VE
EXPERIENCED FIVE OF THE SEVEN
HOTTEST SUMMERS AND RECORDED IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA BEING IN
THE PAST SEVEN YEARS.
SOMETHING IS HAPPENING HERE AND
WE NEED TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
[inaudible]
SO.
THIS BILL I BELIEVE IS ONE OF
THOSE LANDMARK BILLS.
WHERE PEOPLE ARE GOING TO SAY
WHERE ARE MY DAUGHTER AND YOUR
CHILDREN AND THEIR CHILDREN ARE
GOING TO SAY?
WHAT DID YOU DO WHEN YOU'RE IN
THE STATE ASSEMBLY IN THE STATE
LEGISLATURE WHAT DID YOU DO TO
ADDRESS CLIMATE CHANGE WHAT DID
YOU DO?
A FIGHT CLIMATE CHANGE
[inaudible]
I BELIEVE.
IF NOT NOW WHEN WE NEED TO
SUPPORT.
SP. ONE HUNDRED FOR OUR CHILDREN
FOR FUTURE GENERATIONS FOR OUR
PLANET.
MS MELENDEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER --
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN A LARGE.
PIECE OF THIS PUZZLE THAT IS
THAT YOU ALL ARE TRYING TO SOLVE
THAT WE ARE TRYING TO SOLVE IS A
AS A LEGISLATURE.
WITH RESPECT TO CLIMATE CHANGE A
LARGE PIECE OF SOLVING THAT IS --
RENEWABLE ENERGY INVOLVING.
WIND TURBINES RIGHT ENERGY FROM
THE WIND OKAY.
SO WHILE EVERYONE ELSE HAS
TALKED ABOUT THE ECONOMICS OF
THIS ISSUE I WANNA SWITCH GEARS
A LIMIT JUST TALK ABOUT HOW THIS
KIND OF POLICY AFFECTS THE LIVES
OF YOUR FELLOW HUMAN BEINGS.
WIND TURBINES DEPEND TO BE MADE
THEY DEPEND ON RARE EARTH
MATERIALS BATTERED MIND IN CHINA
95% FROM THE MATERIALS NEED FOR
THESE WHEN TURBINES ARE MIND IN
CHINA.
THE PROCESS OF EXTRACTING THESE
MATERIALS OPPOSES WRETCHED
ENVIRONMENTAL AND PUBLIC HEALTH
IMPACTS TO LOCAL COMMUNITIES
THERE ENVIRONMENTALISTS WENT
THERE TO SEE TO LOOK AT THESE
MINES IN THESE FACTORS NEED
DUMPING GROUNDS ASSOCIATED.
WITH THEIR RARE EARTH INDUSTRY.
AND HIS COMMENTS WERE THE BANKS
GREW HIGHER THE LAKE GREW LARGER
AND THE STENCH IN FUMES GREW
MORE OVERWHELMING [inaudible]
WITH THE WEEPS THE PLANTS WE
PLANTED JUST WEATHERED.
AND THEN THE ANIMALS STARTED TO
SICKEN AND DIE PEOPLE TO BEGIN
TO SUFFER.
VILLAGERS SAY THEIR TEETH BEGAN
TO FALL OUT THEIR HAIR TURNED
WHITE AT A YOUNG AGE AND THEY
SUFFERED FROM SEVERE SKIN AND
RESPIRATORY DISEASES CHILDREN
WERE BORN WITH SOFT BONES IN
CANCER RATES SKYROCKETED.
AND OFFICIALS CARRIED STUDIES
OUT FIVE YEARS AGO IN ONE OF THE
VILLAGES WHERE THEY'RE UNUSUALLY
HIGH RATES OF CANCER ALONG WITH
HIGH RATES OF OSTEOPOROSIS AND
SKINNER RESPIRATORY DISEASE THIS
IS THE LAKES RADIATION LEVELS
WERE TEN TIMES HIGHER.
THAN IN THE SURROUNDING
COUNTRYSIDE.
SO I JUST WANT YOU TO THINK
ABOUT.
THE EFFORTS THAT YOU'RE CHOOSING
TO MAKE.
THE EFFECT THAT THAT'S GOING TO
HAVE ON FELLOW HUMAN BEINGS.
BECAUSE AS THIS.
PARTICULAR ENVIRONMENTALISTS
STATED THERE IS NOT ONE STEP A
RARE EARTH MINING PROCESS THAT
IS NOT DISASTROUS FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT.
SO I HEARD A LOT OF TALK TODAY
ALSO ABOUT DOING THIS FOR THE
CHILDREN IN DOING THIS FOR
CONSTITUENTS IN TAKING CARE THE
ENVIRONMENT AND MAKING SURE.
WE CAN ANSWER WHEN SOMEONE ASKS
WHAT DID WE DO TO SAVE
[inaudible]
THE PLANET [inaudible]
YOU ARE.
BY ENGAGING IN THIS PROPPING UP.
A CORRUPT AND BRUTAL GOVERNMENT
IN CHINA.
THEIR HUMAN RIGHTS ABUSES THERE
IT'S THE LIST IS VERY LONG.
THEY JAIL PRO DEMOCRACY
ACTIVISTS THEY FORCED GAY MEN TO
GO TO UNDERGO CONVERSION THERAPY
AGAINST THEIR WILL THERE IS JUST
A CASE LAST YEAR INVOLVING THIS.
THEY SPEAK AGAINST THE
GOVERNMENT IF YOU SPEAK AGAINST
THE GOVERNMENT YOU GET JAIL
GONZALEZ OR AT YOUR WRITINGS AYE
AYE I'M AND HAS ALSO PUT YOUR
SPEECH POINT WHERE I WOULD ASK --
THE SPEAKER TO KEEP TO THE
SUBJECT OF THIS BILL WHICH IS
RENEWABLE ENERGY STANDARDS.
THIS GONZALEZ FLETCHER THAT
POINT ORDERS WILL TAKE
ADMISSIBLE AND AS I UNDERSTAND
THE LINK AT YOUR MAKING CHINA
BUT LET'S FOCUS ON THE POLICY
MATTER BEFORE THIS WELL THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND I IMPOSE
FOCUSING ON THE POLICY BECAUSE
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THIS BILL.
CONTEMPLATES THE FX.
ON THE ENVIRONMENT WHERE THE
REDUCE SOMETHING OR YOU DON'T
AND I AM POINTING OUT THE
EFFECTS ON THE ENVIRONMENT IF WE
DO THIS.
IF YOU SPEAK AGAINST A
GOVERNMENT IN CHINA YOU GET
JAILED.
IN MARCH AN ARTIST WAS SENTENCED
TO FOUR YEARS IN PRISON IN
CONNECTION WITH HIS EFFORTS TO
COMMEMORATE THE TIANANMEN SQUARE
MASSACRE.
YOU GET SAME LETTERS AS WELL AS
I AM RULED ON THE MATTER LET'S
FOCUS ON THE BILL.
IN FRONT OF THE BODY.
IT THEN.
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT I WOULD
LIKE TO APPEAL THAT RULING.
THAT TAKES A SECOND US MELENDEZ
ON MAY APPEAL THE RULING THAT'S
SECONDED BY MISTER MATHIS.
S. IS APPEALING DECISION OF THE
CHAIR ON MY RULING --
IN THIS CASE MISS MELENDEZ IS
MOVING AND MR MATHIS SECONDS
[inaudible]
THE ON THE APPEAL OF THE
DECISION OF THE CHAIR THE
QUESTION BEFORE THE BODY IS
SHALL THE DECISION OF THE CHAIR.
BE OVERRULED SELF SHALL THE
DECISION OF THE CHAIR.
LOBBY OVER RULED IN THIS CASE MS
MELENDEZ IS ASKING FOR DIVERT A
MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING FOR A
KNOW THEM.
AND MS MELENDEZ YOU GET TWO
MINUTES 2% ON THE APPEAL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
YOU KNOW IT IS INTERESTING TO ME
THAT --
WHENEVER WE START TALKING ABOUT
SOMETHING THAT'S A LITTLE
SENSITIVE.
SUDDENLY PEOPLE STAND UP AND
DECIDE THAT THAT'S NOT GERMANE
TO THE TOPIC WHAT I AM TALKING
ABOUT OUR HUMAN RIGHTS
VIOLATIONS.
THINGS THAT ARE HAPPENING TO OUR
FELLOW HUMAN BEINGS THAT WITH
THIS BILL WERE ALL TALKING ABOUT
SAVING THE PLANET IN SAVING.
THE LIVES OF OTHER HUMAN BEINGS
FROM AND FUTURE GENERATIONS FROM
THE DAMAGES CAUSED TO THE
ENVIRONMENT BY POLICIES PUT IN
PLACE.
SO I AM SPEAKING DIRECTLY MAYBE
I'M NOT SPEAKING ABOUT THE
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA.
BUT THIS DOES HAVE A DIRECT
EFFECT ON HUMAN LIVES WHETHER
THEY'RE HERE OR IN CALIFORNIA
WHICH IS WHY I AM POINTING OUT
SOME OF THESE ABUSES.
AND SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
PERHAPS YOU HAVEN'T THOUGHT
ABOUT THE LIVES YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE AN EFFECT ON BY PASSING
THIS BILL.
BECAUSE OVER AND OVER AGAIN IN
THESE CHAMBERS WE HEAR TALK
ABOUT WE WE'VE HAD BILLS ABOUT
CONVERSION THERAPY WE'VE HAD
BILLS ABOUT PRO DEMOCRACY WE'VE
HAD BILLS.
ABOUT THAT THE PROTECTION OF
RELIGIOUS FREEDOM ALL OF THESE
THINGS THAT WE SUPPOSEDLY HOLD
NEAR AND DEAR TO OUR HEARTS IN
CALIFORNIA WORK TO PROTECT.
WITH THIS BILL.
IN THESE EFFORTS WE'RE TAKING
THAT AWAY FROM OTHER PEOPLE.
THAT IS MY POINT WITH THIS THAT
I MEAN YOU CAN'T SAY YOU CARE
ABOUT EVERYBODY YOU CARE ABOUT
ALL THESE RATES IF IT'S ONLY THE
PEOPLE IN YOUR OWN BACKYARD ARE
THE YOU CARE ABOUT HUMANITY OR
YOU DON'T.
SO IT IS GERMANE TO THE TOPIC
AND WITH THAT MISTER SPEAKER.
I WOULD ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE ON
MY APPEAL OF THE RULING OF THE
CHAIR.
THANK YOU MISS MELENDEZ AND I
PROVIDED MY REASONING. FOR THE
RULING THAT DECISION OF THE APP.
QUESTION FOR THE BODY SHELL THE
DECISION OF THE CHAIR BE
OVERRULED MISS MELENDEZ IS
ASKING FOR NINE MISTER CALDERON
IS ASKING FOR NOW THIS.
REQUIRES A MAJORITY PRESENT
VOTING CLERK WILL OVER THE
ROLL-ON.
MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING FOR A
NO VOTE.
AND MS MELENDEZ IS ASKING FOR AN
I..
THIS IS A PROCEDURAL VOTE THIS
IS APPEALING THE DECISION OF THE
CHAIR.
REQUIRES A MAJORITY PRESENT AND
VOTING.
MISS MELENDEZ IS ASKING FOR AN
I. AND MISTER CALDERON IT'S
ASKING FOR NO [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL EYES EIGHTEEN KNOWS
[inaudible] FIFTY CHAIR'S
RULING IS UPHELD [inaudible]
AND MS MELENDEZ.
THIS MIGHT AS HAVE A MINUTE
FIFTY TWO ON THERE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER SO.
COLLEAGUES LECH.
THIS BILL WE'VE HEARD ABOUT ALL
OF THE ECONOMICS I HAVE
ATTEMPTED TO POINT OUT THE
AFFECTED GOING TO HAVE ON HUMAN
BEINGS WHETHER NOT THEY'RE HERE
IN CALIFORNIA DOES HAVE AN
EFFECT ON THOSE HUMAN BEINGS AND
I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING.
THAT YOU SHOULD CAREFULLY
CONSIDER THEIR OF OTHER MEMBERS
WHO POINTED OUT THAT THIS.
THIS BILL IS ATTEMPTING TO DO
SOMETHING THAT WE DON'T EVEN
HAVE THE TECHNOLOGY TO DO
ANYMORE AND I AM SUGGESTING IN
ADDITION.
TO ALL OF THE ECONOMICS BEHIND
THIS.
NO ONE IS DENYING THE SCIENCE BY
THE WAY.
THAT YOU THINK ABOUT THE EFFECT
YOU ARE GOING TO HAVE ON HUMAN
LIVES NOT JUST IN THIS STATE.
BUT IN THIS WORLD BECAUSE WE
HAVE PARTNERSHIPS CALIFORNIA'S
PARTNERSHIPS WITH OTHER
COUNTRIES SO CLEARLY IT WITH
RESPECT TO CLIMATE CHANGE AND
AND IN TRYING TO SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM.
SO IF IT'S NOT IMPORTANT WE DO
THIS ON THE GLOBAL SCALE WHILE
WHY THEN WOULD YOU IGNORE.
THE INFORMATION THAT I'VE GIVEN
YOU TODAY.
ABOUT THE EFFECT IT'S GOING TO
HAVE ANOTHER HUMAN BEINGS ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE WORLD THAT TO
ME JUST MAKES NO SENSE EITHER
YOU ARE FOR HUMAN BEINGS ARE YOU
ARE GETS EASIER FOR GAY RIGHTS
BE AGAINST YOUR FOR RELIGIOUS
LIBERTY.
OR YOU'RE AGAINST YOUR FOR
DEMOCRACY ARE YOU AGAIN SHE
CAN'T SAY THE SAME THING YOU
CAN'T YOU CAN'T HAVE IT BOTH
WAYS.
YOU CANNOT HAVE IT BOTH WAYS
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU
KNOW ABOUT.
THANK YOU MS MELENDEZ MISTER
GARCIA.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES
I'VE BEEN ENLIGHTENED THAT THIS.
AFTERNOON BY THE CONVERSATION
WE'VE HAD ON ONE AND WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT.
HOW IMPORTANT IT IS?
TO BE CONCERNED WITH CHINA AND
THEIR PRACTICES.
AND I'M FULLY CONFIDENT THAT OUR
PRESIDENT WILL TAKE CARE OF
THOSE PROBLEMS.
I'VE ALSO HEARD IN WELCOME NOW
NEW ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ADVOCATES ON THIS FLOOR AND I'M
EXCITED TO BE ABLE TO WORK --
ACROSS THE AISLE ON THESE TYPES
OF ISSUES I'VE ALSO HEARD.
THE NEED TO ADDRESS THE DUCK
CURVE BY OUR MINORITY LEADER AND
I THINK WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
PRIOR TO OF FINISHING UP THIS
SESSION.
TO ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES BUT LET
ME TELL YOU WHY I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SB.
ONE HUNDRED I REPRESENT A COUNTY.
THAT HISTORICALLY HAS SUFFERED
FROM CHRONICLE UNEMPLOYMENT
RATES UP TO TWENTY EIGHT
PERCENTILE AT TIMES AND ON A
GOOD DAY SOMEWHERE WITHIN
FOURTEEN OR 15%.
AND IT'S BEEN THE INCREASING OF
THE RP ASSN THE INVESTMENTS THAT
HAVE GONE.
TOWARDS THOSE AREAS THAT HAVE
ACTUALLY PUT US IN A BETTER SPOT
NOT IN A GREAT SPOT BUT IN A
BETTER SPOT.
AND SO HERE WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE TO
STIMULATE.
AN ECONOMY OF RENEWABLE ENERGIES
AND TECHNOLOGIES BUT WE ALSO
HAVE TO BE MINDFUL AND IT'S BEEN
BROUGHT UP TIME AND TIME AGAIN.
THAT WE HAVE TO DO IT IN A WAY
IN WHICH WE CAN DIVERSIFY THE
PORTFOLIO.
A BALANCED RELIABLE GREAT SYSTEM
THAT WILL ALLOW US NOT ONLY.
TO ADDRESS THE OVER GENERATION
ISSUES BUT ALSO CREATE ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES IN PLACES OF
ECONOMIC NEEDS.
WHETHER YOU'RE IN LAKE COUNTY OR
IN IMPAIR OAK COUNTY.
OUR CLIMATE CHANGE POLICIES HAVE
TO BE INTENTIONAL.
THEY HAVE TO BE ABLE TO CREATE
NOT ONLY THE OBJECTIVES THAT
WE'RE SHOOTING FOR BUT THE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ECONOMIC
GROWTH AND DEVELOPMENT.
AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT.
DEBATE SHOULD BE ABOUT.
I THINK THAT WE HAVE A UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS.
THIS ISSUE OF THE DUCK CURVE THE
OVER GENERATION BY INTRODUCING.
OTHER RENEWAL BALLS THAT ARE
BASED LOW FLEXIBLE AND RELIABLE.
AND YOU KNOW FOR SOME PEOPLE THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE FIRES HAS
FORCED US TO GET TO A PLACE IN
WHICH BIOMASS IS A CONVERSATION
THAT'S TAKING PLACE. FOR MANY
IT'S AN UNCOMFORTABLE PLACE BUT
FOR SOME OF US IT'S AN EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT ONE NOT JUST TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF THE FIRES.
BUT THE ISSUE OF JOBS ON AN
ONGOING BASIS AND SPECIFIC PARTS
OF THE STATE.
WE ALSO HAVE A UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADVANCE.
SOME OF THE SOLAR WIND
OPPORTUNITIES PRIOR TO THE TAX
CREDIT.
ASPIRING AND YES MAKING SURE
THAT WE CONTINUE TO EMPLOY
PEOPLE IN THOSE SECTORS.
BUT I THINK THAT BY INCREASING
THE RP YES THAT'S HOW WE BRING
ABOUT THOSE OPPORTUNITIES AND AS
THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL WOULD SAY
WE MUST BE INTENTIONAL.
HOW WE MOVE FORWARD HE SAYS THE
WORD INTENTIONALITY?
WE MUST BE INTENTIONAL WITH OUR
POLICIES TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
CAN.
DIVERSE SYFY THE PORTFOLIO AND
WILL HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY. TO
MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN THAT ARENA
OF THE EFFORTS TO FIND THE
PORTFOLIO AND MAKING SURE THAT
ALL OF CALIFORNIA.
BENEFITS FROM MY CLIMATE CHANGE
POLICIES IT IS ABOUT EQUITY.
IT IS ABOUT DIVERSIFYING THE
PORTFOLIO BUT IT IS ALSO ABOUT
PEOPLE AND THAT'S ONE THING THAT
EVERYONE HERE HAS MENTIONED THAT
WE MUST LOOK OUT FOR THE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF
CALIFORNIANS.
WHEN WE'RE THINKING ABOUT OUR
CLIMATE CHANGE POLICIES HERE AND
THAT'S WHY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE?
AIMS GARCIA MISTER IS AREA YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER --
I WAS GONNA GET UP AND TALK
ABOUT AN ASPECT THAT I WAS
SOMEWHAT SURPRISED NO ONE
BROUGHT UP ESPECIALLY.
FROM MY COLLEAGUES FROM THE
OTHER SIDE AND I'M VERY GLAD
THAT MY COLLEAGUE FROM COACHELLA
VALLEY JUST THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK. TWO HOW EXACTLY IT
IMPACTS HIS DISTRICT.
COLLEAGUES I'LL JUST GIVE YOU A
QUICK LITTLE SUMMATION OF THE
THINGS THAT I LOOK AT IN MY OWN
DISTRICT AND EVERYWHERE ELSE I
GO.
WE'RE USING TECHNOLOGIES FROM
OVER A HUNDRED YEARS AGO WHEN
WE'RE STILL USING.
HOLES ON OUR STREETS TO CARRY TO
TRANSMIT ELECTRICITY.
AND EVERY GENERATION OR OTHER
GENERATION EXPANDS AND BUILDS
UPON THE PREVIOUS GENERATIONS
[inaudible]
INFRASTRUCTURE.
NOT ONLY TO ADVANCED TECHNOLOGY.
BUT TO ALSO ALLOW FOR JOB
CREATION.
WHEN YOU SET GOALS INTO THE
FUTURE YOUR GIVING ENOUGH OF A
SPACE? FOR MORE TECHNOLOGY FOR
MORE ENHANCEMENT FOR MORE
[inaudible]
OPPORTUNITIES.
A TO BE MET IN THAT TIME LIFE.
AND WERE ABLE TO ACHIEVE A GREAT
DEAL MORE BECAUSE OF THOSE
TARGETS.
YET THAT'S NOT BEING TALKED
ABOUT.
WE'RE NOT ADDRESSING HOW MANY
MORE JOBS IT WILL BE CREATED
BECAUSE OF THIS.
AND NOT JUST THE JOBS OF
INNOVATION BUT THEN THE JOBS
THEREAFTER IN MAINTENANCE.
SO WITH THAT I HUMBLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE AND MAYBE TO SOME
EXTENT.
WE ALSO ARE NOT EVEN GOING FAR
ENOUGH BECAUSE WHEN YOU'RE
LOOKING AT THE TIMELINE OF
TWENTY EIGHT YEARS.
I'M SURE THAT ACCOUNTS FOR HOW
THE INDUSTRY IS GONNA CHANGE BUT
MAY NOT EVEN BE ACCOUNTING FOR
THE TECHNOLOGIES THAT ARE GOING
TO BE.
COMING UP IN THE NEXT TWENTY
YEARS THAT COULD SUBSTANTIALLY
EVEN.
ADVANCE THE ABILITY. TO GET TO A
100% OUR PS IN A MUCH SHORTER
PERIOD OF TIME.
THANK YOU MISTER.
MR CHAVEZ YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR SPEAKER.
LOOKING A DISCUSSION.
JUST LIKE TO CLARIFY A COUPLE
POINTS BRING IDEAS AND I THINK.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT LOS ANGELES
IN THEIR TRAFFIC OR CONFUSING
TRANSPORTATION.
WITH THE GREAT SYSTEM.
I WE HAD THAT PROBLEM LAST YEAR
AND THE DISCUSSION AND CAP AND
TRADE THOSE ARE TWO DIFFERENT
THINGS.
ISSUE ABOUT CHANGING OUR ENERGY
POLICIES IN THIS NOT HAVING AN
IMPACT.
IT CLEARLY IS HAVING AN IMPACT
JUST GO TALK TO ANY
MANUFACTURING COMPANY.
AND ASK THEM HOW THEIR ENERGY
COST IS AND HOW THEY COMPARE IT.
THAT'S THERE ARE NATIONAL
ORGANIZATION I'LL SHOW YOU
ENERGY BECAUSE YOU HAVE A
CALIFORNIA TO SOMEWHERE ELSE.
AND I REMEMBER TALKING TO A
GENTLEMAN SAYING WHAT HE REALLY
FEARS IS THAT THE PEOPLE THESE
PAN USE TRIES GIMMICK GOOD WAGE
TWENTY THIRTY DOLLARS AN HOUR.
BUT HE KNOWS THE ENERGY COSTS
THEIR PAIN IS SIGNIFICANTLY
HIGHER YOU SAYS I DON'T KNOW HOW
THEY'RE MAKING IT ON THESE WAGES.
SO THERE IS AN ENERGY COST TO
THE WORKING POOR.
AND WE NEED TO LOOK AT THE ONE
THE BIG DISCUSSION RARELY TALKED
ABOUT AS REGIONALIZATION OF THE
WESTERN GRID HOUSE GOING IMPACT.
CALIFORNIA SYSTEM.
AND SO THAT YOU NEED TO THROW
THAT IN THERE.
AND I KNOW SOME OF YOU JUST LIKE
I DO LIKE TO LISTEN TO A PODCAST
THIS WEEK GOD FEEDS A CARI.
HE WAS TALKING ABOUT FUSION
INTERNATIONAL EXPERIMENT GOING
IN EUROPE WERE ACTUALLY UNITED
STATES PARTICIPATING.
AND LOOKING AT FUSION ENERGY TO
SOLVE THE ENERGY PROBLEMS OF THE
WORLD IN THE LOOKING AT DOING
THAT WITHIN A DECADE.
IT'S GOING TO CHANGE A WHOLE
DISCUSSION.
BUT LET'S GO TO THIS ISSUE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT RIGHT NOW.
IT'S NICE TO SEE THERE WAS WITH
CLIMATE CHANGE UP FIVE YEARS AGO
AS A REPUBLICAN STANDING UP
SAYING I BELIEVE IN CLIMATE
CHANGE.
EVERYBODY START THROWING THINGS
AT ME NOW EVERYBODY'S ONBOARD A
REPUBLICAN APPRECIATE THAT
[inaudible]
THE BUT REALITY IS CALIFORNIA'S
ONLY 1% OF THE CARBON OUTPUT IN
THE WILL AND THE IN THE WORLD.
AND SO WHEN I WAS TALKING TO
GOVERNOR BROWN WE'RE GOING CAP
AND TRADE I SAID WHAT IS THE
REAL ROLE OF CALIFORNIAN THIS IN
A REAL ROLLER CALIFORNIA.
IS TO BRING A LEADERSHIP ROLE.
THE SHOW THAT YOU CAN CHANGE
YOUR GRID SYSTEM.
YOU CAN CHANGE RENEW IT TOURING
NOBLE SYSTEM WHILE STILL
MAINTAINING A STRONG ECONOMY.
WAS BACK IN JULY OF LAST YEAR
WHEN THE PROPONENTS OF THIS BILL
pI TOLD THEM.
IF YOU WOULD PUT IN THE SAME
SAFEGUARDS THAT WE PUT IN CAP
AND TRADE I'LL BE A CO AUTHOR OF
THIS BILL.
WE SUBMITTED THOSE TO THEM
NOTHING CAME BACK.
WE SUBMITTED A MEGA WATT LATER
AND NOW I LOOK AT IT INFORMED ME
TODAY.
AND IT SAYS IT IN GENERALITIES
THERE'S NO SPECIFICS DEL WITH
RELIABLE SUSTAINABLE.
AND COST EFFECTIVE ENERGY.
IT TALKS A GENERALITY THERE
DOESN'T REQUIRE THAT THE LA OPEN
CABINET TRADE HAS TO REPORT TO
S. ON THE ECONOMIC IMPACT THIS
DOESN'T HAVE THAT.
IT DOESN'T SAY THAT OF THOSE A
DROP IN THE ECONOMY THAT WE
WOULD TAKE AND OFFRAMP AND SLOW
IT DOWN.
IT DOESN'T SAY THAT IN ANY
DETAIL.
SPEED BUMPS ARE THERE THE
LEADERSHIP WE HAVE HERE.
THE LEADERSHIP WE HAVE HERE.
IS TO PASS A BILL.
THAT WE CAN SHOW THE WORLD.
ON HOW TO DO IT.
I'M ALL FOR THE 100% I'M ALL FOR
SAVING THE WORLD.
I'M ALL FOR MAKING US LEADERS IN
THE WORLD AND SHOWING THE WAY
FORWARD.
BUT THIS DOESN'T KNOW IT.
I'D ASK FOR NO VOTE [inaudible]
ESTHER GRAY.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THEY MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
[inaudible]
RECENTLY.
A STAFF MEMBER MIND WAS IN A
MEETING IN THIS BUILDING IN.
WAS RAISING A QUESTION WITH
ANOTHER STAFF MEMBER THAT.
ATTENTION ALL OF THE TWO
COUNTIES I REPRESENT SENSE ABOUT
BEING LEFT OUT OF A BILL.
AND THE RESPONSE THEY GOT WAS
WHEN NOBODY LIVES THERE.
THE AUTHOR OF THIS MEASURE
BEFORE US RIGHT NOW.
WHAT SAID TO THE LA TIMES?
WHY BUILD ANYTHING OUT THERE
THERE'S NOTHING BUT TUMBLEWEEDS?
THAT IS THE DISRESPECT.
AND DISREGARD THIS INSTITUTION
SHOWS. TO THOSE ABOUT TO ROCK
AND AND THIS IS YET ANOTHER.
IN A LAUNDRY LIST OF BILLS.
SCREAMING A TORY [inaudible]
WHY REPRESENT?
HE WON'T TALK ABOUT HOW 2%
RENEWABLE ENERGY WE'VE HAD A
100% RENEWABLE ENERGY IN
PORTIONS OF MY DISTRICT FOR
YEARS.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT REWARD.
WE'VE RECEIVED FOR MAKING THOSE
INVESTMENTS.
HAVING EXCLUDED FROM THIS BILL
AND EVERY BILL THAT'S BEEN DONE
ON THE SUBJECT.
POOR PEOPLE IN MY DISTRICT PAY
TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
[inaudible]
HIGHER RATES.
SO THAT WE CAN.
LOOK TO THE FUTURE SO THAT WE
CAN HAVE ASPIRATIONAL
LEGISLATION SO THAT WE CAN GO
HOME.
AND SAY TO THE BERNIE CRAPS OR
WHOEVER ELSE THAT WE'RE
PROGRESSIVE AND WE DID SOME.
WHAT YOU DID IS RAISE UTILITY
RATES ON CORPORATE?
AND EVERYBODY ELSE.
WE ALL PAY ON THIS.
DOES THAT MEAN.
CLIMATE CHANGE IS AN IMPORTANT.
NO CLIMATE CHANGE'S SERIOUS.
CLIMATE CHANGE REQUIRE SERIOUS
PEOPLE.
IT'S SERIOUS SOLUTIONS.
NOT TALKING POINT BILLS.
THOUGH WE CAN ALL PATTERSON WAS
ON THE BACK AND PRETEND LIKE
WE'VE DONE SOMETHING.
IF I WERE TO ASK THE AUTHOR THIS
BILL.
WHY IS HYDROPOWER NOT INCLUDED
WHY IS IT NOT CONSIDERED
RENEWABLE?
THERE'S NO SCIENCE TO SUPPORT
THAT POSITION.
AND WE GET SOME NONSENSE.
EXCUSES TO WHY WE COULDN'T DO
THIS YOU COULDN'T DO THAT.
COULDN'T BE INTELLECTUALLY
HONEST IN OUR JOB.
THEY WERE JUST GOING TO DO THE
TALKING POINT DEL AND SET THESE
ASPIRATIONAL GOALS IT GETS
TIRESOME.
PEOPLE WERE I LIVE DRIVE LONGER
HOURS TO WORK THEY PAY MORE FOR
GAS.
THEY LIVE IN A CLIMATE THAT'S
HARDER WE PAY MORE FOR UTILITY
RATES.
WE'RE ON THE CUSP OF HAVING TO
DEAL WITH A SERIOUSLY.
SERIOUSLY DIFFICULT ISSUE ON
WILDFIRES [inaudible]
PRODUCED MORE.
GREENHOUSE GAS ISSUES.
THAN ANYTHING WE'VE SITE.
BUT WE'RE JUST GONNA.
SKATE OVER THE FACTS.
YEAH AT A TIME WHEN THERE'S SO
MUCH DISHONEST IN POLITICS.
LET'S NOT TRY NOT TO JOIN THE
PARTY.
I WOULD ASK YOUR NO VOTE TODAY.
MR MACE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
MEMBERS I'VE ACTUALLY REALLY
APPRECIATED THE CONVERSATION A
TODAY ON THIS TOPIC AND I LIKE
OF THE MEMBER OF FROM FROM
OCEANSIDE.
I'M I AM SOMEBODY WHO BELIEVES
THAT CLIMATE CHANGE IS REAL --
AND I'M A CONSERVATIVE.
I THINK WE'VE GOTTEN WE'VE GONE.
A LONG WAY IN A VERY SHORT
AMOUNT OF TIME WITH THAT BELIEVE
SYSTEM.
AND LIKE MY COLLEAGUE FROM.
UP FROM MERCED.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US
THE FOR THAT TO TO LOOK AT THIS
IN A WAY THAT ADDRESSES ALL OF
THE NEEDS OF OF CALIFORNIANS.
YOU I VOTED NO ON THIS BILL IN A
COMMITTEE.
BUT IT WASN'T BECAUSE I DON'T
BELIEVE IN THE EFFORT AND THE
BECAUSE IN FACT I THINK THAT WE
NEED TO GET TO A POINT TO OUR
LOGICAL SYSTEM IS.
A 100% RENEWABLE THAT IT IS
CLEAN AND THAT IT IS ZERO CARBON.
THE REALITY IS GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS ARE NEGATIVE
EXTERNALITY AND WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY ALL OF US HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO FACTOR THAT IN
OUR OWN LIVES.
AND TRY TO RID THAT NEGATIVE X.
NOW DO WE KNOW IT IS HAVING AN
IMPACT ON OUR STATE.
AND OUR COUNTRY.
IN OUR WORLD AND YES WE ARE
LEADER HERE IN CALIFORNIA AS
WELL.
BUT I THINK THIS BILL HAS A FEW
ERRORS IN IT IN FACT.
BEARS ARE THAT.
WE'RE PICKING WINNERS.
AND WE'RE PICKING LOSERS AND I
THINK OUR GOAL NEEDS TO BE TO
WORK IN A BIPARTISAN WAY.
WE DON'T NEED TO VOTE FOR THIS
BILL TODAY [inaudible]
WE HAVE TIME NEXT YEAR AND I'M
COMMITTED MYSELF I KNOW THERE'S
A HANDFUL OF OTHER REPUBLICANS
THAT ARE COMMITTED TO THIS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN COME UP
WITH A PROGRAM.
THAT IS TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL.
THEN MAKE SURE THAT WE GET RID
OF THAT NEGATIVE EXTERNALITY
WHICH IS GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AND MAKE SURE THAT WE
CAN PROVIDE FOR A HEALTHY.
AND I BY AN ECONOMY ARE GOING
FORWARD.
SO I'D ASK THAT TODAY THAT'S
JUST HIT THE PAUSE BUTTON LET'S
BEGIN WORKING IN THE FALL MAYBE
NEXT YEAR I'LL TRY TO PUT A
BIPARTISAN PLAN TOGETHER. FOR
TODAY I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
OBOE [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
THEN A LONG DISCUSSION BUT I'D
LIKE TO ECHO THE POINTS MADE BY.
MY COLLEAGUE FROM [inaudible]
MERCED.
WHEN YOU PICK WINNERS AND LOSERS?
IN LEGISLATION THAT MANDATES
CERTAIN THINGS.
ARE OKAY UNDER THE LAW AND OTHER
THINGS ARE NOT.
THERE ARE CONSEQUENCES TO THAT.
AND MY DISTRICT IS GOING TO FEEL
THE CONSEQUENCES OF A DECISION
MADE.
MANY MANY YEARS AGO. TO NOT
INCLUDE NUCLEAR POWER IN THE
RENEWABLE PORTFOLIO STANDARD.
DIABLO CANYON THE LAST NUCLEAR
POWER PLANT LEFT IN CALIFORNIA
WHICH PROVIDES. 9% OF THE
STATE'S ELECTRICITY WITH ZERO
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS LET ME
SAY THAT AGAIN 9%.
THE STATE'S ELECTRICITY WITH
ZERO GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS.
WHITE HYDRO POWER THERE IS NO
SCIENCE SUPPORTING THE LACK OF
INCLUSION OF NUCLEAR POWER.
IN THE RPF STANDARD.
NOW THAT'S HISTORY THAT'S FINE
BUT I JUST OFFER THAT
ILLUSTRATION BECAUSE IN TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE DIABLO CANYON IS
GOING OFF LINE IT'S SHUTTING
DOWN IT WILL BE DECOMMISSIONED
OVER [inaudible]
DECADES.
MY COMMUNITY WILL LOSE FIFTEEN
HUNDRED HEAD OF HOUSEHOLD JOBS
AND A BILLION DOLLARS OF
ECONOMIC.
ACTIVITY IN MY DISTRICT
[inaudible]
I HOPE.
IT IS NOT LIKE THE CLOSING OF
THE STEEL MILLS IN PITTSBURGH.
BUT I FEAR IT MIGHT BE.
SO WHEN YOU PICK WINNERS AND
LOSERS IN LEGISLATION
[inaudible]
PLEASE REMEMBER.
THAT THERE ARE LOSERS.
AND ISRAEL AND IMPACTS THE
COMMUNITY.
IN A MAJOR MAJOR WAY.
THAT IS NOT TO SAY I DON'T
ACCEPT SCIENCE AYE DEGREE IN
PHYSICS.
STOOD WITH PEOPLE.
THAT SHOWED TREMENDOUS COURAGE
LAST YEAR CROSSING THE AISLE TO
ENACT A SIGNATURE.
PIECE OF LEGISLATION BUT A LOT
OF US PAY THE COST. FOR FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT FOR THE ECONOMY.
I ACCEPT SCIENCE.
I THINK CLIMATE CHANGE NEEDS TO
BE ADDRESSED.
BUT OTHER THINGS HAVE TO BE
ADDRESSED TO PUTTING ECONOMICS.
I ASKED YOU TO HIT THE PAUSE
BUTTON WHAT'S GO BACK TO WORK ON
THIS.
AND NEXT YEAR WHAT'S ENACT
SOMETHING THAT THE ENTIRE WORLD.
WE'LL LOOK AT AS A MODEL. FOR
HOW THE ENTIRE WORLD IS GOING TO
SOLVE EXISTENTIAL PROBLEMS.
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION.
OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
MS GONZALEZ FLETCHER YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU I DO WANT TO
ADDRESS A FEW THINGS THAT WERE
BROUGHT UP BECAUSE IN SOME WAYS
IF I LISTEN TO ALL OF YOU IT
SOUNDS GOOD.
BUT IT'S NOT NECESSARILY TRUE.
THERE'S NO PLAN I HEARD.
THE SAME PERSON WHO SAID THERE'S
NO PLAN SUGGESTED IN TEN YEARS
WILL HAVE COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
TECHNOLOGY.
THAT'S WHY WE CANNOT PRESCRIBE.
WHAT TYPE OF POWER THIS'S?
THAT'S WHY WE CAN'T SPECIFICALLY.
DO MORE THAN SET THE GOALS.
BECAUSE THAT PLAN HAS TO
CONTINUE TO BE WRITTEN AND RE
WRITTEN AND BROUGHT BACK TO THIS
LEGISLATURE BECAUSE WE ALL KNOW
IN TWENTY EIGHT YEARS.
OUR SOURCES OF POWER ARE GOING
TO CHANGE THAT THINGS ARE GOING
TO CONTINUE TO CHANGE.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT TYPE OF
PRESCRIPTIVE PLAN.
YOU WOULD WANT OR COULD VOTE ON
AND THAT'S ALL WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT IS CUTTING OFF LITTLE
PIECES OF PORK FOR EVERY
INDIVIDUAL DISTRICT IN THE TYPE
OF POWER.
THAT YOU WANT IN YOUR DISTRICT
AND IF YOU TALK ABOUT COST
CONTAINMENT THAT'S NOT GOING TO
DO IT.
IT DOESN'T ITS TECHNOLOGY
NEUTRAL.
IT HAS TO BE BECAUSE OUR
TECHNOLOGY IS CONSTANTLY
CHANGING.
AND BECAUSE IT IS OUR NEXT
GENERATION WHO ARE GOING TO NOT
ONLY.
BENEFIT FROM THIS AS FAR AS
CLIMATE CHANGE BUT BENEFITS FROM
THIS BECAUSE THERE THE
INNOVATORS WE'RE GOING TO BE
CHANGING.
HOW WE SEE?
ELECTRICITY IN THE FUTURE.
BUT WE KNOW IT'S POSSIBLE WE NO
THAT WE CAN GO CARBON FREE WE
KNOW WE HAVEN'T HAD PROBLEMS
MEETING THOSE.
RENEWABLE STANDARDS.
WE KNOW THIS.
SO THIS ALLOWS A PLAN TO COME
BACK TO THIS LEGISLATURE.
AFTER WE MEET OUR 60% CALL.
THAT MAKES SENSE.
IT'S A LOT LIKE AT THAT POINT WE
ARE.
THOSE FOLKS TO WILL REPLACE AS
CAN ASPIRIN ALEJO ANALYSIS.
WE CAN CONTINUE TO HAVE THIS
DISCUSSION WHAT TODAY IS ABOUT
THE SAME ARE WE GONNA HOLD OUR
FEET TO THE FIRE ON THIS ISSUE.
HOPEFULLY ON FRIDAY WE'RE GOING
TO ASK IF WE HOLD OUR FEET TO
THE FIRE ON THE WILDFIRE.
BECAUSE FOR THE FOLKS WHO SAID
IT'S NOT JUST ELECTRICITY YOU'RE
RIGHT.
BUT THAT'S NOT AN EXCUSE TO NOT
DEAL.
WITH THE ELECTRICAL GRID.
IT'S THE EASIEST ONE IT'S A
LOWEST HANGING FRUIT ABSOLUTELY
ARE WE GOING TO HAVE TO CONTINUE
TO LOOK AT TAILPIPES ABSOLUTELY
ARE WE GONNA HAVE TO CONTINUE TO
LOOK AT WILD FIRES ABSOLUTELY.
BECAUSE WE CAN'T AFFORD NOT.
TO AND EVEN IF FOR JUST A LITTLE
CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE SHOWING BY EXAMPLE THAT
THIS CAN BE DONE.
SINCE ARNOLD SCHWARZENEGGER
SIGNED HIS EXECUTIVE ORDER IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT THE COST OF
SOLAR HAS COME DOWN 77%.
AND LET'S TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT ENERGY BILLS BECAUSE I'VE
HEARD A LOT TODAY.
BUT I WILL TELL YOU IF YOU LOOK
AT THE U. S. ENERGY.
INC [inaudible]
INFORMATION ADMINISTRATION.
YOU'LL FIND S..
WE PAY ONE THIRD PER HOUSEHOLD.
FOR ELECTRICAL UTILITY RATES AS
TEXAS.
WE PAY A HALF.
OF WHAT LOUISIANA PAYS.
THERE ARE INCREASES IN
ELECTRICITY I UNDERSTAND THIS I
LIVE IN A DISTRICT WHERE THIS IS
HAPPENING AND YOU KNOW WHY.
BECAUSE WE'RE DOING SOMETHING
THAT WE NEVER DEAD.
WHEN I WAS GROWING UP RUNNING
AIR CONDITIONERS?
ALMOST ALL THE TIME.
AND THAT'S BECAUSE OF CLIMATE
CHANGE.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT POOR
FAMILIES AND HOW THIS AFFECTS
POOR FAMILIES I LIVE IN A
COMMUNITY OF WORKING CLASS
FAMILIES I REPRESENT A COMMITTEE
WORKING CLASS FAMILIES?
FIRST WELL LET'S BE HONEST WE
HAVE A GREAT.
PROGRAM THERAPY YOU SEE THAT
HELPS OUR POOREST FAMILIES PAY
THEIR UTILITY BILLS FIRST OF ALL
[inaudible]
BUT SECOND.
THEY'RE HAVING A
DISPROPORTIONATE [inaudible]
CHALLENGE.
BECAUSE OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
A LOT OF OUR HOUSES DON'T EVEN
HAVE ELECTRICITY SO YOU HAVE
FANS AND PEOPLE TRYING TO SAVE
ENOUGH MONEY TO ACTUALLY PUT AN
ELECTRIC ARE PUT IN AIR
CONDITIONING BECAUSE WE DON'T
EVEN HAVE A IT WASN'T EVEN.
IMAGINED THAT IF YOU LIVE IN
COASTAL SAN DIEGO THAT YOU WOULD
NEED AIR CONDITIONING.
AND NOW YOU CAN'T LIVE WITHOUT
IT.
THAT'S REALITY AND SO WHEN YOU
HAVE TO RUN IT ALL THE TIME IT
DOES MAKE YOUR ENERGY RATES GO
UP IT MAKES YOUR UTILITY BILL GO
UP.
THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING I KNOW
IN MY AND IN IN MY NEIGHBORING --
IMPERIAL COUNTY.
THERE IS A THIRTY SECONDS MISS
FLETCHER.
SO I APPRECIATE WHAT WAS SAID
TODAY A LOT OF IT IS ARGUING A
DIFFERENT POINT.
BUT THIS IS ABOUT OUR FUTURE AND
I JUST ASK FOR ONE THING YOU
DON'T HAVE TO LIKE THE AUTHOR.
I DON'T CARE.
THIS IS ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT.
I THINK HE'S A GREAT GUY BUT
THIS IT IS ABOUT.
WHETHER OR NOT WE WANT TO SET
GOALS.
THAT WE CAN REACH.
AND BE PROUD OF OURSELVES TO
REDUCE.
THE AFFECTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA IF WE CAN BE
BOILED IN LEAD THE WAY IT'S
SUPPORTED BY BY FORMER VICE
PRESIDENT AL GORE THE FORMER.
REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR OF THIS
STATE ARNOLD SCHWARZENEGGER AND
BY EVERY SCIENTIST WHO'S LOOKED
AT IT.
THIS IS WHAT WE NEED TO DO WE
NEED TO LEAD THE WAY I ASK THAT
YOU DON'T PLAY GAMES TODAY I ASK
THAT YOU VOTE FOR THE FUTURE AND
VOTE I WITHOUT THE CLERK LOCAL
THE ROLE.
ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE ON
THE WRIST VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
THIS GONZALEZ FLETCHER MOVES A
CALL.
MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF MS RACE.
WE WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME
BRIGHTEST STAR INK A GROUP WHICH
SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT HAS BEEN
COMMITTED TO BUILDING THE DREAMS
AND SELF ESTEEM A FOSTER IN AT
USE AT RISK YOUTH.
IN THE INLAND EMPIRE WITH US IN
THE GALLERY TODAY.
IS LEAH CASH THE FOUNDER AND
PRESIDENT.
AND C. E. O. O. BRIGHTEST STAR
FOUNDATION AS WELL AS STUDENTS
FROM THE ORGANIZATION'S LEADER
IN THE PROGRAM.
WHICH FOCUSES PROVIDING YOUTH
LEADERSHIP DEVELOPMENT PROMOTING
SELF ESTEEM AND POSITIVE
ACADEMIC PROGRESS WE HAVE WITH
US IN THE CHAMBER TODAY ROBERT
HOUSTON.
DANNY PERERA ERIK ESTRADA SAMUEL
PARIAHS AND CODY PHILLIPS PLEASE
JOIN ME IN GIVING MISS CASH IT
IS REMARKABLE YEAH IF THEY WERE
ARMED ASSEMBLY. TWELVE CREATES
PLAINTIFFS STAR
.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MOTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY SIX
TO WITHDRAW THE FOLLOWING BILLS
FROM THE BUDGET COMMITTEE IN
ORDER THEM PLACE ON THE IN FILE.
AS BA FORTY SIX S. B. EIGHT
SIXTY TWO S. B. EIGHT SEVENTY
THREE SB THIRTY FOUR SB.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN MISS WALDRON
WE OPPOSE THAT MOTION AND THAT'S
PEARL CALL MISS WALDRON IS
WITHHOLDING UNANIMOUS CONSENT
MEMBERS THIS IS A PROCEDURAL
VOTE MISTER CALDERON MOVES.
MISTER BONTA SECONDS ON THE
RULES SUSPENSION CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLL-ON CALDERON IS ASKING
FOR AN AYE VOTE MISS WALDRON NO.
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR MY AND
MISS WALDRON AND NO.
TAKES FORTY ONE ON THE ROLL
SUSPENSION [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE.
I CITY.
TOO KNOWS TWENTY RUN ONE THE
RULES ARE SUSPENDED.
IT'S CALDERON HERE AGAIN
RECOGNIZE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE FIFTY ONE I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RE REFER S.
B. NINE THIRTY NINE PORTANTINO
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
[inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND JOINT WILL SIX TO A THE
FILE NOTICE REQUIREMENT TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE TO
HEAR AB NINE NINETY EIGHT
GRAYSON AND AB TWELVE FOURTEEN
STONE TODAY UPON CALL THE CHAIR
IN ROOM.
ONE TWENTY SIX THE CLERK WILL
NOTE.
THE REQUESTED MENACE CONSENT TO
ADOPT THE FOLLOWING CONCURRENT
RESOLUTIONS ON THE THIRD REALLY
FILE.
ITEM ONE FORTY EIGHT ACR TO
FORTY THREE EDUARDO GARCIA ITEM
ONE FORTY NINE ACR TO SIXTY ONE
KALRA ITEM ONE FIFTY ACR TWO
SEVENTY ONE ACOSTA.
ITEM ONE FIFTY TWO HR ONE TWENTY
THREE EGGMAN ITEM ONE FIFTY
THREE ACR ONE FIFTY EIGHT BAKER
AND ITEM ONE FIFTY FOUR ACR TWO
SEVENTY FOUR GABRIEL.
MEMBERS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR OF
ADOPTING ITEMS.
WHEN 481-409-15150 TWO ONE FIFTY
THREE AND ONE FIFTY FOUR PLEASE
SAY AYE?
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT.
THOSE RESOLUTIONS ARE DOTTED
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF COMMITTEES.
THAT WILL BE MEETING WHEN WE
BREAK FOR LUNCH.
WHICH MAY BE [inaudible]
MOMENTARILY.
THEY OUR BUDGET.
IN ROOM FORTY TWO A TWO
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND TOXIC
MATERIALS ROOM.
FOR FOR FOR GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION AND ROOM.
FOR THIRTY SEVEN PRIVACY AND
CONSUMER PROTECTION AND ROOM.
FOR FOUR SEVEN PUBLIC SAFETY IN
ROOM.
ONE TWENTY SIX AND WHILE I'M AT
IT MEMBERS UPON ADJOURNMENTS
UPON ADJOURNMENT THE NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE WILL BE
MEETING IN ROOM.
FOUR FOUR SEVEN CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE WILL BE UPON CALL.
MEMBERS CORRECTION THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE WILL NOT BE MEETING.
YOU MAY THANK MISTER TANK
.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO BE
BREAKING FOR LUNCH AND FOR THOSE
COMMITTEE MEETINGS THAT I LISTED
WE WILL RETURN TO THE FLOOR AT
ONE THIRTY PM PROMPTLY WILL
RETURN TO THE FLOOR.
AND RESUME BUSINESS AT ONE
THIRTY PM.
WE ARE IN RECESS
.
THE HOUSE'S BACK IN ORDER
MEMBERS PLEASE RETURN TO THE
ASSEMBLY CHAMBERS
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
THE SESSION IS ON SCHEDULE WAS
IN SESSION PLEASE RETURN TO THE
FLOOR IMMEDIATELY.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO FILE
ITEM ONE SEVENTY NINE S. B. TEN
EIGHTY FIVE MISTER CLERK PLEASE
READ.
SENATE BILL TEN EIGHTY FIVE BY
SENATOR SKINNER ACCOLADE
REPUBLICAN POINT THANK YOU SOME
MEMBER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE
PRESENT S. B. TEN EIGHTY FIVE BY
SENATOR NANCY SKINNER THIS BILL
RECOGNIZES THAT EMPLOYEES WHO
ARE STEWARDS OF THEIR UNION
SOMETIMES NEED TO TAKE.
TIME OFF FROM REGULAR JOBS TO
PERFORM UNION RESPONSIBILITIES
HOWEVER SOMETIMES.
EMPLOYERS AREN'T WILLING TO
NEGOTIATE LOST TIME FOR
EMPLOYERS EVEN WHEN UNIONS US
YOU REPORT HE'S WE EVEN WHEN
UNION --
PAYS FOR ALL COSTS THIS BILL
SOLVE THAT THAT PROBLEM BY
REQUIRING PUBLIC EMPLOYERS TO
GRANT LEAVE OF ABSENCE FOR AN
EMPLOYEE TO PARTICIPATE IN UNION
ACTIVITIES WITHOUT LOSS OF
COMPENSATION AND BENEFITS.
REQUIRING THE UNION TO COVER ALL
COSTS OF THE EMPLOYER FOR THAT
PAID LEAVE ALLOWING THE
EMPLOYEES RIGHT OF RICH
REINSTATEMENT WITHOUT LOSS OF
SENIORITY RANKLE CLASSIFICATION.
AND ALLOWING THAT THE EMPLOYEE
TO END THEIR LEAVE OF ABSENCE
AND RETURN --
TO WORKPLACE AT ANY TIME THANK
YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MEMBER BAKER.
THINKING OUR SPEAKER I RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE ON THE
FLOOR JUST READ VERY INSTRUCTIVE
OF THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
ATTAIN THE KIND OF FLEXIBILITY
WITH THEIR TIME OFF YOU CAN.
WITHOUT COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
FOR EXAMPLE IN MOST WORKPLACE
SETTINGS YOU ARE GIVEN A CERTAIN
NUMBER OF DAYS THAT YOU CAN USE
FOR VACATION FOR SICK DAY FOR
GOING TO YOUR KIDS SCHOOL AND
VOLUNTEERING.
OF FOR VOLUNTEERING ON CAMPAIGNS
OF POLITICAL ACTIVITY THAT'S THE
SAME TYPE OF RIGHTS THAT --
MOST CALIFORNIANS HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO SECURE WITHOUT THIS MEASURE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU KNOW VOTE.
SOME NEVER CALDERON WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE --
APPRECIATE THE PERSPECTIVE OF MY
COLLEAGUE BUT STILL RESPECTFULLY
ASTRONAUT OPENS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MISTER QUIRK PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL-ON DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MISTER CALDERON MOVES THE CALL
.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO ITEM TO
TWENTY EIGHT SP ELEVEN TWENTY
FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL ELEVEN TWENTY FIVE
THE MINUTES BY SOME REMEMBER
ARAMBULA THINK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ARAMBULA THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER.
S. B. ELEVEN TWENTY FIVE WOULD
DISMANTLE BARRIERS TO MENTAL
HEALTH PATIENTS IN CALIFORNIA
FACE BY ALLOWING COMMUNITY
HEALTH CENTERS TO BILL MEDICO.
FOR MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ON
THE SAME DAY THAT THEY PROVIDE
OTHER MEDICAL SERVICES.
THE AMENDMENT AT THE DESK
RESOLVE CHAPTER RING ISSUES WITH
AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY EIGHT BY
OUR GOOD ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM
SAN DIEGO.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU SEEING NO DISCUSSION
NOR DEBATE WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
THE AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED IN
THE BILL ITSELF PRETTY BACK ON
FILE
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING BACK
IN ORDER TO ITEM ONE SIXTY NINE
S. B. TO TWENTY FOUR THE CLERK
WILL READ.
SENATE BILL TWO TWENTY FOUR BY
SENATOR JACKSON AND OTHERS AND I
BELIEVE THE PERSONAL RIGHTS
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAYOS.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
THERE'S A FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT FOR
EVERY MAN WOMAN TO SAFELY PURSUE
ECONOMIC SECURITY ADVANCEMENT IN
PROFESSIONAL OPPORTUNITIES FREE
FROM HARASSMENT AND ABUSE.
S. B. TWO TWENTY FOUR BY SENATOR
HANNAH BETH JACKSON ADDRESSES
THE UNIQUE RELATIONSHIP THAT
EXISTS BETWEEN INVESTORS AND
ENTREPRENEURS IN THE VENTURE
CAPITAL INDUSTRY.
AS WELL AS RELATIONSHIPS THAT
EXIST IN OTHER INDUSTRIES OR
HARASSMENT HAS BEEN PERVASIVE.
S. B. TWO TWENTY FOUR
ESTABLISHES CIVIL LIABILITY FOR
SEXUAL HARASSMENT IN BUSINESS
SERVICE OR PROFESSIONAL.
RELATIONSHIPS BY EXPLICITLY
INCLUDING BEST INVESTORS.
ELECTED OFFICIALS LOBBYISTS
DIRECTORS AND PRODUCERS AMONG
THOSE LISTA PERSONS WHO MAY BE
LIABLE FOR SEXUAL HARASSMENT
UNDER CIVIL CODE SECTION FIVE
ONE POINT.
NINE CALIFORNIA MUST TAKE EVERY
STEP TO MAKE IT CLEAR THAT
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT IS NOT
ACCEPTABLE.
AND I RESPECTFULLY RECAP REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN THE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES I FIFTY FIVE
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
.
MEMBERS I AM PREPARED TO LIFT
THE CALL ON ITEM ONE SEVENTY
NINE SP TEN EIGHTY FIVE MISTER
CLERK PLEASE POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE
[inaudible]
WHAT?
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELLING THE VOTES EYES FORTY TWO
NO TWELVE THE MEASURE PASSES
.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING BACK IN
FILE ITEM ORDER TO ITEM ONE
SEVENTY SIX S. B. TWELVE SIXTY
FIVE MISTER QUICKLY ST.
SENATE BILL TWELVE SIXTY FIVE BY
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE YOU
NATURALLY BECOME [inaudible]
DEVELOPMENTS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
SENATE BILL TWELVE SIXTY BY
STRENGTHENS THE DEMOCRATIC
GOVERNANCE AND CALIFORNIA'S OVER
FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATIONS.
UNFORTUNATELY SOME MAJOR WAY
BOARDS MANIPULATE ELECTIONS BY
FAILING TO NOTICE ELECTION.
FAILING TO DELIVER A BALANCED
ALL RESIDENTS AND THROWING OUT
BALLOT BALLOTS IN FACT
COMPLAINTS HAVE COME IN FROM UP
AND DOWN THE STATE FROM LARGE
WAYS TO SMALL ONES.
AND THERE HAVE EVEN BEEN
INSTANCES WHERE THE AGE WE
DOESN'T HOLD ELECTIONS AT ALL.
S. B. TWELVE SIXTY FIVE
ESTABLISHES REASONABLE REFORMS
THE LAWS GOVERNING THESE
ELECTIONS AND WITH THAT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
BOAT.
SEEING A REQUEST TO SPEAK MISTER
QUICK PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE
.
MISTER KALRA MOVES A CALL.
MOVING NOW TO ITEM ONE EIGHTY
SIX S. B. THREE TWENTY SEVEN
MISTER CLERK PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL THREE TWENTY SEVEN
BY SENATOR JACKSON ANOTHER
PERSON I BELIEVE TO INFER
PRIVACY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN.
Q. VERY MUCH MADAM SPEAKER I
RISE TO PRESENT TO S. B. THREE
TWO SEVEN BY SENATOR JACKSON.
THIS BILL IS EXACTLY MY BILL AB
NINETEEN OH SIX WHICH WAS --
OF SUPPORTED BY THE MAJORITY OF
YOU ON THE FLOOR.
AB NINETEEN OH SIX CREATED A
REASONABLE SECURITY STANDARD FOR
THE INTERNET OF THINGS DEVICES
SUCH AS SMART THERMOSTATS SMART
DOOR LOCKS AND SMART TOYS.
BOTH BILLS WERE RECENTLY AMENDED
TO CLARIFY THE ELEMENTS OF THE
REQUIREMENT TO INCLUDE BLUETOOTH
DEVICES.
THIS BILL ALONG WITH AB NINETEEN
OH SIX ADDRESS THE DOLE CONCERNS
OF CYBERSECURITY AND PRIVACY BY
ENSURING THAT DEVICES WE ARE
ADDING TO OUR HOMES OFFICES AND
CITIES WILL NOT BE USED AGAINST
US.
THIS LEGISLATION IS THE RESULT
OF OVER A YEAR OF COMBINED
EFFORTS BY TECH BUSINESS AND
CONSUMER COMMUNITIES THE
EXTENSIVE CLAVELL AT
COLLABORATION BY MY OFFICE.
AND THOSE STAKEHOLDERS WAS
CRITICAL TO ADDRESS THREATS THAT
ARE FORECASTED TO ONLY GET WORSE.
THIS MEASURE WHEN ENACTED WILL
SECURE ARE SMART HOMES AND SMART
CITIES FROM BEING LEVERAGED
AGAINST US I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAKER.
THANK YOU I JUST I DO HAVE A
QUESTION THE AUTHOR AND I
APOLOGIZE FOR NOT ASKING IT OFF
THE FLOOR BECAUSE I I KNOW WE
HAD SOME DISCUSSION ABOUT THIS
IN THE PRIVACY COMMITTEE.
AND THAT IS IF PHAM YOU WERE
ABLE AT THE AUTHOR WAS ABLE TO
RESOLVE THE ISSUE WITH RESPECT
TO CALIFORNIA BASED
MANUFACTURERS AND WILL THIS
DISADVANTAGED THEM.
WHEN IT COMES --
TO CHINA FOR EXAMPLE WHERE WE
FOUND THAT --
WE HAD EXTENSIVE CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT THIS AND PRIVACY I DON'T
SEE THE PROVISIONS AND AGAIN I
APOLOGIZE TOOK A COLLEAGUE OF
FROM VENTURA FOR NOT ASKING YOU
BEFORE IT SNUCK UP ON ME ON THE
FLOOR IF YOU COULD ADDRESS THAT
PLEASE [inaudible]
BE GRATEFUL.%
THANK YOU SO MEMBER IRWIN YOUR
CLOTHES PLEASE --
YES I OF WE DID ADDRESS THAT TOO
WE THINK THAT WE'VE ADDRESSED
THAT I I'VE.
THAT'S THE BEST I CANDO ON THAT
WE DID THERE WE HAVE MADE
CHANGES TO ADDRESS THAT.
AND I'M SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR I THANK YOU MISTER QUIRK
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
.
MISSOURI MOVES THE CALL.
ITEM ONE EIGHTY SEVEN PASS
TEMPORARILY MOVING TO ITEM ONE
EIGHTY EIGHT S. B. EIGHT TWENTY
FOUR MISTER QUICK PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL EIGHT TWENTY FOUR BY
SENATOR LLOREN OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE TO INSURANCE SOME NEVER
AGUIAR-CURRY GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS.
S. B. EIGHT TWENTY FOUR WILL
PROHIBIT AN INSURER FROM
COUNSELING OR NON RENEWING A
HOMEOWNER'S INSURANCE POLICY FOR
ONE YEAR.
AFTER A DECLARED STATE OF
EMERGENCY IF THE PROPERTY IS
LOCATED WITHIN.
A FIREPROOF PERIMETER DETERMINED
BY CAL FIRE OR A ZIP CODE
ADJACENT TO THE FIRE PERIMETER.
THIS WILL ENSURE THAT HOMEOWNERS
DON'T HAVE TO STRUGGLE WITH A
SUDDEN NON RENEWAL OR
CANCELLATION IMMEDIATELY AFTER
CATASTROPHE.
S. B. EIGHT TWENTY FOUR ALSO
AUTHORIZES THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE TO CONDUCT A DATA CALL
ON INSURED LOSSES.
RELATED TO FIRES IN WILDFIRES.
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE ASSEMBLY
HAVE BEEN CAREFULLY NEGOTIATED
WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS ANNOUNCED
RESULT THEIR IS NO LONGER ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WALDRON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
HAVING BEEN THROUGH --
SOME BIG WILDFIRES BACK --
A FEW YEARS AGO WHERE.
OVER THIRTY SIX HUNDRED
STRUCTURE WE'RE LOST IN SAN
DIEGO COUNTY --
IT WAS VERY SCARY ONE LOTS OF
FOLKS STARTED LOSING THEIR
HOMEOWNERS INSURANCE WHICH IS
BASICALLY.
THEIR YOU KNOW THEIR LIFE
SAVINGS INVESTED IN THEIR HOME --
SO BEING ABLE.
TO PUT A PAUSE ON THAT ALLOW
FOLKS TO WORK THROUGH THEIR
ISSUES -- AS
WELL AS INSURANCE COMPANIES GET
A HANDLE ON YOU KNOW WHERE THEY
ARE FINANCIALLY.
AND WITH THEIR BUSINESS MODELS --
AND CAL FIRE AND OTHERS LOOKING
AT THE RISK ASSESSMENTS OF THE
AREA -- IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE DO THAT
AND I URGE AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING NO FURTHER
REQUEST TO SPEAK MISTER CLERK
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
THIS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND HOW THE VOTES AYE SIXTY ONE
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
.
MOVING TO ITEM ONE EIGHTY NINE
S. B. NINE NINETY EIGHT MISTER
QUICKLY STREET SENATE BILL NINE
NINETY EIGHT BY SENATOR DODD
ACCOLADE TO WATER.
MISTER QUIRK YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE ON BEHALF OF SENATOR DODD.
BOB THERE ARE LIFELINE PROGRAMS
FOR RATEPAYERS FOR ELECTRIC GAS
AND TELEPHONE BILLS.
BUT THERE'S ONLY A PATCHWORK OF
LOCAL POLICIES FOR WATER PAYMENT
HARDSHIPS.
S. B. NINE NINE EIGHT PROTECT
VULNERABLE AND LOW INCOME
RESIDENTS IN THE FOLLOWING WAYS
[inaudible]
IT REQUIRES.
WATER AGENCY POLICIES ON
DEFERRED PAYMENTS ALTERNATIVE
PERMIT PLANES EXCUSE ME
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PLANS
[inaudible]
AND APPEALS REQUIRES CONTACTING
THE RATE PAYER IN THE WAITING
PERIOD BEFORE TERMINATING
SERVICE.
IT PLACES RESTRICTIONS ON
DISCONTINUATION OF SERVICE OF
FOR RATEPAYERS ON A PAYMENT PLAN.
AND CAN PROVE THERE IS A HEALTH
AND SAFETY HAZARD.
S. B. NINE NINE EIGHT INSURES
THAT THE STATE'S POLICY FOR SAFE
AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER IS
ACHIEVED.
THIS MEASURE SUPPORTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES.
RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES TO
CALIFORNIA.
THE COMMUNITY WATER CENTER AND
MANY OTHERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SEEN NO REQUEST TO SPEAK MISTER
QUIRK PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
TO QUIRK WHAT IS YOUR PLEASURE.
DOCTOR QUIRK MOVES A CALL.
ITEM ONE NINETY ONE PASS
TEMPORARILY.
ITEM ONE NINETY TO PASS AND
RETAIN.
TANE ITEM ONE NINETY THREE
PASSED EMPEROR LEE.
ITEM OF ONE NINETY FOUR PASS AND
RETAIN MOVING TO ITEM ONE NINETY
FIVE SP FIFTEEN OH FOR MR
QUICKLY ST.
SENATE BILLFIFTY NO FOUR BY THE
COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT
RETIREMENT NATALIE TO SAVE
EMPLOYMENT.
I SEVEN EVER RODRIGUEZ YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED METAL SPEAKER MEMBERS
AMID A PRESENT SP FIFTEEN OH FOR
THE SENATE PURSE COMMITTEE
HOUSEKEEPING BILL.
THAT MAKES TECHNICAL NON
CONTROVERSIAL AND CONFORMING
CHANGES. TO CLEAN UP SECTION OF
THE GOVERNMENT CODE ADMINISTERED
BY THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
HUMAN RESOURCES CALLIE CHAR.
RESPECT WE ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING THEIR REQUEST
TO SPEAK THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MR CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE RULING
TALLY THE VOTES AYE SIXTY THREE
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE MOVING TO ITEM ONE NINETY
SIX S. B..
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THE CLERK
WILL READ.
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO
BY SENATOR HILL AND OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE HEALING ARTS THINK YOU
SEVEN MEMBER LOW YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS SP
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO IS THE
DENTAL.
HYGIENE COMMITTEE SUNSET BILL
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
MISTER CLARK WAS OPEN THE
ROLL-ON.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
IT IS ARTICLE.
JAKARTA ME CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTES.
I SIXTY ONE NO ZERO THE MEASURE
ASSES [inaudible]
ITEM. ONE NINETY SEVEN THROUGH
ONE NINETY NINE PASS TEMPORARILY.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO BE
TAKING UP ITEM ONE NINETY NINE
SB.
THIRTEEN SEVENTY FOUR THE COURT
I HAVE
.
ALRIGHT WE ARE PASSING
TEMPORARILY.
NINE ONE NINETY NINE ITEMS TWO
HUNDRED THREE TO AWAY PASS AND
RETAIN WERE MOVING TO ITEM TO A
NINE FOURTEEN NINETY ONE MISTER
QUICKLY ST.
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN NINETY ONE
BY THE COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT THAT LATE HEALING
ARTS.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THAT YOUR
IMAGE MASSACRE THIS IS ANOTHER
SUNSET DON'T RESPECT THE*
RIGHT VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MISTER QUICK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MISTER CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLAND TALLY THE VOTES ICE FIFTY
EIGHT NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
ITEMS TO TEN INTO ELEVEN PASS
AND RETAIN MOVING OUT ITEM.
TO TWELVE MR QUICKLY.
THREE SENATE BILL ONE EIGHTY
THREE BY CENTER LAUREN OTHERS
AND I BELIEVE EDUCATIONAL EQUITY
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARAMBULA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
THIS BODY VOTED IN PASSED A
NEARLY IDENTICAL MEASURE LAST
WEEK.
SENATE BILL ONE EIGHTY THREE
EXPLICITLY INCLUDES IMMIGRATION
STATUS AS A PROTECTED CLASS
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA EQUITY IN
HIGHER EDUCATION ACT.
THIS MEANS THAT ALL PERSONS IN
OUR INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER
LEARNING.
ARE ENTITLED TO EQUAL RIGHTS AND
FREEDOM.
FROM DISCRIMINATION ON THE BASIS
OF THEIR IMMIGRATION STATUS.
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS MAKE IT
CLEAR THAT NOTHING IN THE ACT
REQUIRES A POST SECONDARY
INSTITUTION. TO OFFER ADMISSION
OR STUDENT FINANCIAL AID TO
CERTAIN NON IMMIGRANT FOREIGN
STUDENTS. ONE CLARIFYING
AMENDMENT INCLUDED AT THE
REQUEST OF THE ADMINISTRATION
DECLARES THAT THE BILL DOES NOT
CHANGE STUDENT ELIGIBILITY FOR
STATE FINANCIAL AID.
SENATE BILL ONE EIGHTY THREE
WILL REINFORCE CALIFORNIA'S
CONTINUED COMMITMENT TO ALL
PEOPLE LOOKING TO FURTHER THEIR
EDUCATION AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE MISTER COURT PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE
.
MISTER QUIRK MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
AND HOW THE VOTES EYES FIFTY
THREE NO SIXTEEN THE MEASURE
PASSES.
ITEMS CHIU THIRTEEN THROUGH TWO
SIXTEEN PASS AND RETAIN ITEM TO
SEVENTEEN PASS TEMPORARILY.
MOVING OUT ITEM TO EIGHTEEN S.
B. EIGHT EIGHTY ONE MISTER
CARPENTRY.
SENATE BILL EIGHT EIGHTY ONE BY
SENATOR MCCASKILL OTHERS AND I
PLAYED A FLOOD CONTROL.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KANSEN CHU YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED SICK HUMOR THEM
SPEAKERS HAVE MEMBERS SBA EIGHTY
ONE WHAT AT THE SOUTH SAN
FRANCISCO BAY.
SHORELINE PROJECT TO THE LIST OF
FLOOD CONTROL PROJECT ALSO RISE
TO RECEIVE STEP.
STATE FLOOD CONTROL [inaudible]
OF REIMBURSEMENT.
THIS IMPORTANT PROJECT TO
INCORPORATE A MULTI BENEFIT
APPROACH FOR FLOOD PROTECTION
COMBINING ENVIRONMENTAL
RESTORATION OF WET LYING A
WETLANDS AND TRADITIONAL LEVEE
CONSTRUCTION.
THE PROJECT WILL PROVIDE FLOOD
PROTECTION TO COMMUNITY IMPALA
AUTO MOUNTAIN VIEWS SUNDAY BELL
SAN JOSE AN OBESE SO.
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SEEN THAT NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE MISS CLARK
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES EYES
FIFTY NINE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES WE'RE MOVING TO ITEM TO
NINETEEN S. B. NINE THIRTY SEVEN
MISTER CLERK PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL NINE THIRTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR WE KNOW ANOTHER PERSON
ACCOLADES EMPLOYMENT IF YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AMONG YOUR
RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER S. B.
NINE THIRTY SEVEN MAKE SURE OUR
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY WORKFORCE
HAS A TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
WORKPLACE.
BY REQUIRING EMPLOYERS TO MAKE
LACTATION ACCOMMODATIONS FOR
PARENTS RETURNING TO THE
WORKPLACE AFTER CHILDBIRTH.
HAVING FAMILY FRIENDS.
FAMILY FRIENDLY WORKPLACES IS
KEY TO INFANT AND PARENTS HEALTH
EQUITY BETWEEN THE GENDERS AND
IS GOOD FOR BUSINESS THIS BILL
WILL EASE THE TRANSITION OF
PARENTS RETURNED TO WORK.
FOLLOWING THE BIRTH OF A CHILD
AND ASSIST EMPLOYEES TO
EXPERIENCE THE WORK LIFE BALANCE
WHILE GIVING EMPLOYER
SIGNIFICANT FLEXIBILITY ON HOW
TO MEET ACCOMMODATION
REQUIREMENTS.
THIS BILL HAS BEEN AMENDED TO
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS FROM THE
EMPLOYER COMMUNITY AND NO LONGER
CONTAINS A PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION.
OR A NEW REQUIREMENT TO INCLUDE
LACTATION ROOMS IN THE BUILDING
CODE.
EVEN WITH THESE SIGNIFICANT
AMENDMENTS IF PASS SP AT NINE
THIRTY SEVEN WILL BE THE
STRONGEST LACTATION POLICY IN
THE COUNTRY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING UP ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GABRIEL YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY.
IN STRONG SUPPORT AND PROUD TO
BE A CO AUTHOR OF THIS MEASURE
AS THE FATHER OF TWO YOUNG KIDS
UNDER.
THREE AND AS THE PARTNER OF A
HARD WORKING WOMAN WHO IS
CURRENTLY BREASTFEEDING OUR
ELEVEN MONTH OLD SON.
I BELIEVE THIS IS A CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT MEASURE FOR OUR STATE.
AND AS I SEE IT FUNDAMENTALLY
THIS MAY CHOICE AND IT'S ABOUT
ENSURING THAT WORKING WOMEN.
WHO CHOOSE TO PUMP BREAST MILK
AREN'T UNFAIRLY DISADVANTAGED IN
THEIR PLACE OF IT OF EMPLOYMENT?
AND I KNOW FROM MY WIFE'S
EXPERIENCES MEMBERS.
AS WELL AS FROM THE EXPERIENCE
OF SO MANY FRIENDS AND
COLLEAGUES.
THE PUMPING BREASTMILK AT WORK
CAN BE EXTREMELY CHALLENGING.
AND THAT TO AND TIME CONSUMING
AND THAT WOMEN WHO CHOOSE TO
MAKE THE DECISION TO PUMP CAN
SOMETIMES STRUGGLE. TO BALANCE
THEIR EXPECTATIONS AND THEIR
JOBS IFTHEY ARE PROVIDED WITH
ADEQUATE FACILITIES.
AND WITHOUT ADEQUATE FACILITIES
WOMEN MAY FEEL THAT THEY'RE
FORCED TO CHOOSE BETWEEN THEIR
CAREERS AND PROVIDING THEIR
CHILDREN WITH THE PROVEN
BENEFITS OF BREAST MILK.
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT ANY
CALIFORNIAN SHOULD BE REQUIRED
TO THAT MAKE THAT CHOICE.
ON THE CONTRARY I BELIEVE THAT
WE SHOULD SUPPORT WOMEN WHO
CHOOSE TO BREASTFEED AFTER THEY
WERE TORN TO THE LABOR FORCE.
NOT RELEGATE THEM TO A BATHROOM
STALL.
AND I WOULD ENCOURAGE MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE AISLE IF YOU SUPPORT WOMEN
IF YOU SUPPORT FAMILIES IF YOU
SUPPORT CHILDREN'S HEALTH.
IF YOU SUPPORT EMPOWERING
PARENTS TO MAKE THIS CHOICES
ABOUT THEIR CHILDREN'S
UPBRINGING AND THEIR HEALTH CARE
I RESPECTFULLY ENCOURAGE YOU TO
TO SUPPORT THIS IN PART MEASURE.
THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
TONIGHT ABOUT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SEEING NO FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE.
THE CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MR CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TELLING THE VOTES.
HIGHS FIFTY KNOW TEN THE MEASURE
PASSES.
MEMBERS I AM PREPARED TO LIFT
THE CALL PLAN FILE ITEM ONE
EIGHTY SIX S. B..
THREE TWENTY SEVEN THE COURT
PLEASE POST.
MISTER QUIRK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES AYE AYES
FORTY SIX NO.
TWENTY THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO ITEM OF
ONE NINETY ONE S. B..
TWELVE EIGHTY EIGHT THE CLERK
WILL READ.
SENATE BILL TWELVE OF EIGHTY
EIGHT BY CENTER LIVE ON OTHERS
TONIGHT LATER HEALTH AND HEALTH
HEALTHCARE FACILITIES THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THEY COMMENCEMENT HER.
S. B. TWELVE EIGHTY EIGHT WOULD
SEEK TO EMPOWER THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO ENFORCE
CURRENT.
NURSE TO PATIENT RATIOS. FOR
OVER TWO DECADES A CELL
CALIFORNIA HAS GONE WITHOUT
STRONG FORCE WITHOUT A STRONG
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM THAT
INCENTIVIZE IS HOSPITALS TO
COMPLY.
WITH TITLE TWENTY TWO
REGULATIONS.
S. B. TWELVE EIGHTIES
COMMONSENSE MEASURE THAT WOULD
ALLOW HOSPITALS TO PRIORITIZE
PATIENTS HEALTH.
AND THE SAFETY AT ALL TIMES. TO
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS BY THE
ADMINISTRATION.
THE MEASURE MIRRORS OF FINDS A
FOR SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES.
INITIALLY THERE ARE THERE ARE
MULTIPLE VIOLATIONS OBSERVED IF
THERE ARE MULTIPLE VIOLATIONS
OBSERVED IN THE SAME INSPECTION.
ONLY ONE VIOLATION WILL BE
COUNTED AND IS CONSISTENT WITH
NURSING.
A FACILITY OF PENALTIES.
AND THOSE HOSPITALS WHO HAVE NO
PRIOR OFFENSES OVER THE LAST
THREE YEARS THAT VIOLATION WOULD
BE COUNTED AS THE FIRST OFFENSE.
LASTLY THE MEASURE WOULD GIVE
SPECIAL CONSIDERATION.
A SMALLER ROLE HOSPITALS PRIOR
TO GIVEN FINES A GOOD FAITH
EFFORT IS.
IT SEEMED FRANK UNDER UNFORESEEN
CIRCUMSTANCES.
I AND SELF IMPLEMENTING LANGUAGE.
THANK YOU MEN SPEAKER I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SOME MEMBER ARAMBULA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER.
I RISE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL.
TWELVE EIGHTY EIGHT AND THE
EMERGENCY ROOM I WORKED SHOULDER
TO SHOULDER WITH NURSES AND THEY
ARE ON THE FRONT LINES OF HEALTH
CARE.
I UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF
ENSURING WE HAVE GOOD PATIENT
HEALTH AND SAFETY AND THEREFORE
WHY IT IS IMPORTANT TO HAVE A
HEALTHY NURSE STAFFING RATIO IN
PLACE.
AT ALL TIMES.
BURDENING OUR NURSES WITH
EXCEEDINGLY HIGH NUMBER OF
PATIENTS MAKES IT DIFFICULT TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE PROVIDING
EACH PATIENT WITH QUALITY CARE.
WE SHOULD MAKE SURE THAT EACH
HOSPITAL IS DOING ITS BEST TO
COMPLY WITH THE RATIOS FOR
NURSES TO PATIENTS BECAUSE OUR
STATE PATIENTS SIMPLY DESERVE TO
BE TREATED.
WITH THE BEST HEALTHCARE THAT WE
CAN DELIVER I URGE YOUR AYE
VOTES TODAY ON SENATE BILL.
TWELVE EIGHTY EIGHT THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS MEMBERS I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE EIGHTY
EIGHT CALIFORNIA'S HAD GREAT
SUCCESS AND EXPANDING ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE.
AND WE ARE PER BOOK POISED TO
MAKE EVEN MORE PROGRESS.
PATIENT HEALTH AND SAFETY MUST
BE PARAMOUNT IN OUR HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM.
HAVING THE PROPER NURSE TO
PATIENT RATIO IS AN EFFECTIVE
AND IMPORTANT FACTOR IN
PROTECTING PATIENT HEALTH AND
SAFETY.
THIS BILL HELPS ENSURE CURRENT
LAWS ARE NURSE TO PATIENT RATIOS
IS BEING FOLLOWED.
WELL WE ARE MOVING FORWARD ON
HEALTH CARE WE'RE ALSO NEEDS
PREVENT BACKSLIDING I ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE ON THIS SPEECH WHILE
THE EIGHTY EIGHT THANK YOU
WITHOUT MISTER CORPUS OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE
.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTES AYE AYES FORTY
TWO NO TWENTY ONE THAT MEASURE.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING.
TO MOVE INTO CAUCUS.
THE REPUBLICANS WILL BE CAUCUS
AND IN THE RULES ROOM THE
DEMOCRATS WILL BE CAUCUSING IN
THE MEMBERS LOUNGE.
WE'RE THE ASSEMBLY WILL SEND
THEM A BRIEF RECESS. TO THE
MEMBERS CAN CAUCUS. TO CLARIFY
WE ARE ROOM RECESSING UNDER CALL
OF THE SPEAKER.
NOBODY IS TO LEAVE
.
MEMBERS WE ARE BACK IN SESSION
PLEASE REPORT TO THE FLOOR
IMMEDIATELY
MEMBERS.
WE ARE MOVING AHEAD AND FILE
ORDER TO ITEM TWO THIRTY EIGHT
S. B. THIRTEEN OH NINE MADAM
CLERK PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN OH NINE BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE FISHING.
THE SEVEN MEMBER DAHLE YOUR
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS.
S. B. THIRTEEN OH NINE
CALIFORNIA'S FISHING INDUSTRY IS
AMONG THE TOP SEE FOOD PRODUCING
STATES IN AMERICA.
WE'VE PROVIDE FRESH AND NEW
TRUCE WHILE CAUGHT SEAFOOD FOR
AMERICANS ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
BECAUSE OF THIS OUR FISHING
INDUSTRY IS WORTH NINE BILLION
DOLLARS.
THE JOINT COMMITTEES ON
FISHERIES AND AQUACULTURE.
A COMMITTEE FOR WHICH I AM PROUD
AND GRATEFUL TO BE A PART OF
HOLDS REGULAR HEARINGS AND FORMS
FORMS IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT WE
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT.
AND HEAR THE NEEDS OF THOUSANDS
OF HARD WORKING MEN AND WOMEN
WHO ARE THE BACKBONE OF
CALIFORNIA'S FISHING AND
AGRICULTURE.
AQUACULTURE INDUSTRY S. B.
THIRTY OH NINE ADJUSTS THE
VARIOUS FISHERY NEEDS DISCUSSED
AT THESE HEARINGS INCLUDING SUN
SETTING REGULATION PERMIT
TRANSFERS.
CRAB TRAP REGULATIONS AND
STANDARDIZING GEAR MARKING.
THIS BILL HAS ENJOYED
OVERWHELMING BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND HAS NOT RECEIVED ANY NO
VOTES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I AM SEEING NO REQUEST
TO SPEAK METACARPALS OPEN THE
MEMBERS VOTERS TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
WE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
RULING TALLY THE VOTES AYE SIXTY
THREE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
ITEM TWO THIRTY NINE PASS AND
RETAIN ITEM TO FORTY PASS
TEMPORARILY.
MOVING TO ITEM TWO FORTY ONE SP
THIRTEEN SIXTY SEVEN MADAM
QUICKLY.
THREE SENATE BILL THIRTEEN SIXTY
SEVEN BY SENATOR ACT OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO THE SAN DIEGO RIVER
CONSERVANCY.
THINK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER S. B. THIRTEEN
SIXTY SEVEN WOULD ENABLE THE
SENEGAL RIVER CONSERVANCY TO
INITIATE THE SENEGAL RIVER.
WATERSHED CONSORTIUM PROGRAM
WHICH WILL ASSIST RESTORING
THREE NEARBY RIVERS THE O. TIE
RIVER SWEETWATER RIVER AND THE
TIJUANA RIVER THIS BILL HAS
BROAD SUPPORT AND NO KNOWN
OPPOSITION RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON BEHALF OF
SENATE PRESIDENT PRO TEM ATKINS.
THANK YOU SEEING THEIR REQUEST
TO SPEAK MEADOW PARK WAS OPEN
THE WRONG ALL MEMBERS VOTE
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
RULING TELEVOTES EYES SIXTY FOUR
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
.
MOVING OUT ITEM TO FORTY TWO SB
THIRTEEN SEVENTY SIX MADAM CLERK
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN SEVENTY SIX
BY SENATOR HELEN OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO TRANSPORTATION
MAKING A PREPARATION THERE FOR
SOME A MEMBER FRAZIER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
SB THIRTEEN SEVENTY SIX INSURERS
CALIFORNIA'S DISABLED CITIZENS.
HAVE ACCESS TO UBER LIVE
SERVICES.
TECHNOLOGICAL INNOVATION OFTEN
BENEFITS THE DISABILITY
COMMUNITY.
THIS IS BEEN TRUE OF THE
TRANSPORTATION NETWORK COMPANIES
OR TNC EASE.
WHICH HAVE MADE PROGRESS IN
PROVIDING ACCESS TO DEAF AND
BLIND PERSONS AS WELL AS ELLERY
ELDERLY.
NEEDING EXTRA ASSISTANCE.
BUT WHEELCHAIR USERS ESPECIALLY
NON FOLDING MOTORIZED WHEELCHAIR
USERS HAVE NOTED IS CLEAR LACK
OF ACCESS TO THE SERVICES.
TNC IS PROVIDE.
S. BE THIRTEEN SEVENTY SIX
MANDATES THE P. YOU SEE DEVELOP.
REGULATIONS FOR TNC DISABILITY
ACCESS INCLUDING ACCESSING A
FIVE CENT FEE ON TNC STOOD FUND
A ON DEMAND WHEELCHAIR ACCESS
ALSO ALLOWS TNC USED TO OFFSET
OR BE EXCUSED FROM THIS BE IF
THEY DIRECTLY INVEST.
IN WHEELCHAIR ACCESSIBLE
SERVICES ON THEIR APPS.
THIS MEASURE HAS NO OPPOSITION
IS SUPPORTED BY UBER AND LIFT AS
WELL AS A BROAD COALITION OF
DISABILITY ADVOCATES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN NEVER CRISIS BIG
METAPHOR PLEASE OPEN THE MEMBERS
VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MADAM QUIRK YOU MAY CLOSE.
NO I'M SORRY THIS REQUIRES FIFTY
FOR ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE
.
MISTER FRAZIER MOVES THE CALL.
MOVING TO ITEM.
TWO FORTY THREE S. B. THIRTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN OUT OF HER PLEASE
READ.
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN BY SENATOR BALLOT ACTUALLY
TO BE A CALLS THINK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY
MATTER MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
S. B. THIRTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
EXTENDS EXISTING AUTHORITY FOR
THE DMV. TO CONDUCT A PILOT
PROGRAM EVALUATING OF
ALTERNATIVES TO VEHICLE LICENSE
PLATES REGISTRATION TICKET
STICKERS AND REGISTRATION CARDS
FROM JANUARY ONE TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN TO JANUARY.
ONE TO TWENTY TWENTY A PURPOSE
PURPOSE OF EXTENDING THE SUNSET
DATE IS TO ENSURE THAT THE PILOT
PROGRAM PLAYED.
HAVE SUFFICIENT MILES IN USE AND
THAT THE HARDWARE AND SOFTWARE
FUNCTIONS PROPERLY.
FURTHER SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
WILL LINE THE SUNSET DATE OF THE
PILOT MORE CLOSELY WITH THE DATE
THAT THE DMB IS FINAL REPORT AND
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE DUE TO THE
LEGISLATURE.
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THINK YOU SING A REQUEST TO
SPEAK MY APARTMENT FOR THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS WHO.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
RULING TALLY THE VOTES AYE SIXTY
THREE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING BACK TO
ITEM TWO FORTY S. B..
THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT METAPHOR
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT BY SENATOR BALLOT ACTUALLY
THE VEHICLES THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN THE LEGISLATURE CREATED
THE FIFTEEN MEMBER ROAD USAGE
CHARGE TECHNICAL ADVISORY
COMMITTEE.
A STUDY ROAD CHARGE ALTERNATIVES
GATHER PUBLIC COMMENT AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY REGARDING THE DESIGN OF A
ROAD CHARGE PILOT PROGRAM.
THE TECHNICAL ADVISORY COMMITTEE
IS SCHEDULED TO SUNSET ON
JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY NINETEEN WELL LAST YEAR
THE CALIFORNIA STATE
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY PUBLISHED
ITS FINAL REPORT ON THE PILOT
PROGRAM.
ADDITIONAL RESEARCH AND WORK IS
NEEDED TO FULLY TRANSPARENT AND
STAKEHOLDER LED PROCESS BEFORE
ANY TRANSITION INTO ALTERNATIVES
IS CONSIDERED.
THEREFORE S. B. THIRTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT EXTENDS THE SUNSET ON THE
TECHNICAL ADVISORY COMMITTEE FOR
FOUR YEARS THE BILL IF IT HAS
RECEIVED NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SING NOTICED ó I'M
SORRY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAKER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MELENDEZ YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER THE QUESTION OF THE
AUTHOR FOR THAT JOCKEY IF I MAY.
I WILL ALLOW YOU TO ANSWER ASK
IT NOW HE CANNOT RESPONDER
RESPOND AS CLOSE [inaudible]
THANK YOU --
SO WE'VE.
JUST PASSED A GAS TAX.
SO I'M JUST WONDERING WHAT.
THE NEED IS FOR THIS PANEL IF
WE'VE ALREADY PASSED ATTACKS
THAT ADDRESSES THE
TRANSPORTATION NEEDS OF THE
STATE.
HE CAN RESPOND OUR YOU CAN
RESPOND IS BECAUSE HE'S GOT NO
HAVE BEEN RESPOND MY CLOTHES
THINGS OKAY THEN ON MY END TIME --
THIS JUST SEEMS A LITTLE ODD BUT
IT SHOULD SEEM ODD EVERYONE IN
THE ROOM THAT WE PASSED THE GAS
TAX WE IMPOSED ON THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA.
DESPITE THE FACT THAT OUR BUDGET
HAS A SURPLUS AND NOW WE ARE
COULD TALKING Y. CONTINUING A
PANEL ON THE COMMISSION TO STUDY
HOW TO TAX PEOPLE.
MORE.
SO I DID SOMETHING'S NOT
PENCILING OUT HERE HOPEFULLY
EVERYONE WILL CONTEMPLATE THIS
BEFORE THEY VOTE I WOULD ASK
YOUR KNOW ABOUT.
THANK YOU SEE A SOME MEMBER
FRAZIER YOUR RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
WELL AS CHAIRMAN TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE WORK AS PART OF THE
PROCESS OF THIS THIS A BILL IS
TO EXTEND THE POSSIBILITY OF
MOVING TO OF WROTE A VEHICLE
ROAD CHARGE --
WE KNOW THAT THE GAS TAX IS A
SUSTAINABLE WHEN WE WORK TOWARDS.
OF RENEWED RENO WILL OR A ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES THAT DO NOT
USE FOSSIL FUELS AND SO WE NEED
ANOTHER METHODOLOGY WE'VE BEEN
DOING THE THE GAS TAXES.
NINETEEN TWENTY THREE AND THE
PURCHASING POWER IS BEEN
DIMINISHED.
CONSIDERABLY SINCE WE'VE US
STARTED IT.
THIS IS SEE IT SERIOUSLY TO GET
TO ANOTHER WAVE OF MAINTAINING
THE ROADS AND GOING FORWARD --
AND I URGE YOUR BUDDIES IDLE.
THANK YOU SEEN A NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN YOU MAY CLOSE YOUR
MUCH THE CHAIR OF THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE TOOK
THE WORDS RIGHT OUT OF MY MOUTH --
AND A GREAT EXPLANATION OF WHY
THIS IS CRITICALLY NECESSARY TO
EXTEND THE SUNSET DATE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU MADAM COURT PLEASE
OPEN THE MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
RULING TALLY THE VOTES EYES
FORTY TO KNOW TWENTY TWO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING NOW.
BACK AND FILE ORDER TIED INTO
FORTY FOUR SP THIRTEEN NINETY
SEVEN MADAM FOR PLEASE READ
SAMPLE THIRTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR HILL AN ATHLETE
AUTOMATIC [inaudible]
EXTERNAL DEFIBRILLATORS.
SO MEMBER BERMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES AT THREE
THIRTEEN NINETY SEVEN WILL
REQUIRE HIGH OCCUPANCY BUILDINGS
THAT UNDERGO RENOVATIONS TO BE
EQUIPPED WITH AN A E. D..
SUDDEN CARDIAC ARREST KILLS
NEARLY ONE THOUSAND PEOPLE PER
DAY IN THE UNITED STATES.
ENHANCE THE LIVES OF THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
ANNUALLY.
THE SINGLE MOST EFFECTIVE
INTERVENTION DURING SUDDEN
CARDIAC ARREST IS THE USE OF AN
AUTOMATED EXTERNAL DEFIBRILLATOR
OR OTHERWISE KNOWN AS AN E. D..
S. B. THIRTEEN NINETY SEVEN
BILLS OFF THE SUCCESS OF
EXISTING EIGHTY LAWS AND EXTENDS
A YOU'D BE INSTALLATION
REQUIREMENTS APPLICABLE TO NEW
DEVELOPMENT. TO LARGE OCCUPANCY
BUILDINGS THAT UNDERGO
SUBSTANTIAL RENOVATIONS.
S. B. THIRTY NINETY SEVEN HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND IS ENJOYED BROAD
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MEMBER RODRIGUEZ.
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS ARE RISING
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL THIRTEEN
NINETY SEVEN AS A FIRST
RESPONDER I KNOW THAT EVERY
SECOND COUNTS AND EMERGENCY.
HAVING A EDIE'S WHILE ACCESSIBLE
TO THE PUBLIC WILL MEAN THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN LIFE AND
DEATH ARCH AYE VOTE.
ON IN ABOUT THIRTEEN EXCEPT I
THINK YOU SEE NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION ABOUT AND QUIRK WAS
OPEN.
MEMBERS BOTH THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE RULING
TALLY THE VOTES AYE SIXTY EIGHT
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO ITEM AT TWO FORTY FIVE
S. B. FOURTEEN NO THREE
METAPHORICALLY THREE SENATE BILL
FOURTEEN A THREE BY SENATOR LARA
AND EXPLAIN GREENHOUSE GASES
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS.
ALTHOUGH WE'VE MADE MUCH
PROGRESS TO CLEAN UP OUR HEAVY
DUTY TRUCKS AND BUSES CLEAN
TRUCK TECHNOLOGY LACKS BEHIND
THAT OF LIGHT DUTY TRUCKS.
OR LIKE DUTY CARS.
S. B. FORTINO THREE CODIFIES THE
INCLUSION OF A HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLE ANALYSIS WITHIN THE
EXISTING THREE YEAR INVESTMENT
STRATEGY REPORTS.
THAT GUY DECISION MAKING AT THE
AIR RESOURCES BOARD. ZERO
EMISSION TRUCKS AND SCHOOL BUSES
ARE CRITICAL ELEMENT OF OUR
CLEAN AIR AND CLIMATE GOALS AND
THIS BILL WILL ENSURE.
OUR INVESTMENTS WILL CONTINUE TO
BE PRIORITIZED AND INFORMED BY
BROADER STRATEGY I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING THEIR REQUEST
TO SPEAK BUT A QUICK PLEASE OPEN
THE ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY NINE
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO ITEM TWO FORTY SIX S.
B. FOURTEEN NO SIX MADAM CLERK
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL FOURTEEN
A SIX BY SENATOR HILL AND OTHERS
IN THAT TELLING THE PUBLIC POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
S. B. FOURTEEN ZERO SIX GIVES
THE FIFTEEN EXISTING.
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WITH PILOT
PROGRAMS. TWO ADDITIONAL YEARS
TO ENROLL NEW STUDENTS.
WHICH INSURERS THE LA SO WILL
HAVE A MORE ROBUST POOL OF
PARTICIPANTS.
FROM WHICH TO EVALUATE THE
PROGRAM'S EFFECTIVENESS.
THIS WILL HELP TO BETTER DEVELOP
RECOMMENDATIONS ON HOW THE
PROGRAM SHOULD BE EXTENDED OR
EXPANDED.
CURRENT LAW REMAINS STUDENTS
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO ENROLL PASS
THE 200-018-2000 NINETEEN
ACADEMIC YEAR.
BY ALLOWING THIS PILOT PROGRAM
TO CONTINUE MORE STUDENTS WILL
BE ABLE TO ENROLL AFTER THIS
YEAR.
THIS BILL IS ABOUT THE FUTURE OF
THE WORK FORCE IN OUR STATE.
IT HAS RECEIVED BY SORT
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK MEDICAL PLEASE OPEN THE
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
MEDICARE PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY SIX
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING BACK IN
FILE ORDER TO ITEM ONE SEVENTY
SEVEN SP TWO FIFTEEN METAPHOR
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TWO FIFTEEN BY
SENATOR BALLOT ACTUALLY TODAY
DIVERSION SOME MEMBER JONES
SAWYER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBER
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
S. B. TWO ONE FIVE ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR BELL.
ROUGHLY A THIRD OF INMATES IN
CALIFORNIA JAIL SUFFER FROM
SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS TOO OFTEN
UNTREATED MENTAL ILLNESS IS THE
REASON THE UNDER THOSE HAVE
BECOME INVOLVED WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN THE FIRST PLACE.
MENTAL HEALTH DIVERSION WILL
HELP TO REDUCE RECIDIVISM BY
PROVIDING TREATMENT INSTEAD OF
JAIL WE HAVE SEEN THE SUCCESS OF
THIS APPROACH WOULD CALIFORNIA'S
MILITARY DIVERSION.
THE PROGRAM CREATED BY A. B.
EIGHTEEN TEN HAS RAISED SOME
CONCERNS AND S. B. TWO ONE FIVE
SEEKS TO ADDRESS. THREE OF THESE
ISSUES BY ADDING REQUIREMENT FOR
VICTIM RESTITUTION IT RESTRICTS
THE ELIGIBLE OFFENSES SO
DIVERGENT CANNOT BE.
INCIDENT IN CASES OF MURDER
VOLUNTARY MANSLAUGHTER RAPE OR
OTHER SEX CRIMES IT ALSO
AUTHORIZES THE COURT TO REQUIRE
I PROMISE A SHEET SHOWING THAT
THE DEFENDANT AND THE OFFENSE.
MEET ELIGIBLE REQUIREMENTS AND
ARE SUITABLE FOR DIVERSION S. B.
TWO ONE FIVE WILL HELP COURTS
AND COUNTIES DEPLOYMENT MENTAL
HEALTH DIVERGENCE SUCCESSFULLY.
MEMBERS ARE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SEEING NO REQUEST TO SPEAK MADAM
CLERK WAS OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM HER PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
ON TELLY THE VOTES EYES SIXTY
THREE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING AHEAD IN
FILE ORDER. TO ITEM.
THREE FIFTY WHICH IS S. B. TEN
FIFTY FOUR MADAM QUICKLY.
THREE SENATE BILL TEN FIFTY FOUR
BY SENATOR HERTZBERG AND
ACTUALLY THE PRE TRIAL RELEASE
AND ATTENTION.
SOME MEMBER BONTA YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED.
AND THANK YOU MA'AM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES S. B. TEN FIFTY FOUR
ADDRESSES.
ISSUES RAISED LEADING UP TO THE
DEBATE LAST WEEK ON SENATE BILL
TEN THE BILL REFORM ACT.
THE ISSUES ADDRESSED HERE THIS
BILL ONE CLARIFY THAT THOSE
ARRESTED FOR OFFENSES LISTED IN
PENAL CODE SECTION TWO NINETY
THE SEX OFFENDER REGISTRATION
ACT WILL RECEIVE.
A RISK ASSESSMENT.
AND TO ENSURE THAT THE COUNTY OF
SAN FRANCISCO'S MODEL NONPROFIT
AGENCY WHICH HAS.
BEEN RUNNING PRETRIAL SERVICES
FOR DECADES HAS SUFFICIENT TIME
TO TRANSITION TO A PUBLIC AGENCY
AS REQUIRED BY THE BILL SENATE
BILL.
TEN WAS SIGNED EARLIER TODAY AND
THE SIMPLE AMENDMENTS PROVIDE
NECESSARY CLARIFICATIONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU I SEEN A REQUEST TO
SPEAK MATTER QUIRK WAS OPEN THE
RIGHT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
PAUL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
METACRITIC YOU MAY CLOSE THE
RULING TIED THE VOTES I SIXTY
SIX NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE NOW MOVING BACK
IN FILE ORDER TIED IN TO TWENTY
SEVEN SP.
ELEVEN HUNDRED MADAM CLERK
PLEASE READ.
SENATE ELEVEN HUNDRED BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO ACTOR OF THE FIREARMS
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES SB ELEVEN HUNDRED
BY SENATOR PORTANTINO PROHIBITS
THE SALE OF ANY FIREARM BY A
LICENSED DEALER. TO ANY PERSON
BELOW THE AGE OF TWENTY ONE
UNLESS THE PERSON HAS A VALID
HUNTING LICENSE IS AN ACTIVE OR
HONORABLY DISCHARGED A MEMBER OF
THE MILITARY.
OR AN ACTIVE LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER.
CALIFORNIA LAW CURRENTLY
REQUIRES A PERSON TO BE TWENTY
ONE TO PURCHASE A HANDGUN.
BUT ONLY REQUIRES A PERSON TO BE
EIGHTEEN TO PURCHASE ALL OTHER
GUNS OVER THE YEARS LONG GUNS
HAVE CHANGE THEY AREN'T JUST
YOUR GRANDFATHER'S TWELVE GAUGE
SHOTGUN IN THE CLOSET ANYMORE
TODAY'S SEMI AUTOMATIC.
GUNS ARE MORE POWERFUL.
AND MORE LETHAL WHILE HANDGUNS
ARE USED IN THE MAJORITY OF GUN
DEATHS LONG GUNS HAVE BEEN USED
TO PERPETRATE MANY OF THE
LARGEST MASS SHOOTINGS.
IN US HISTORY INCLUDING THE
TRAGIC EVENT THAT TOOK PLACE IN
SAN BERNARDINO CALIFORNIA.
S. B. ELEVEN HUNDRED ALSO
RECOGNIZES THE FACT THAT YOUNG
ADULTS AGES EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY
ARE STATISTICALLY FAR MORE
LIKELY. TO COMMIT HOMICIDE THAN
OLDER ADULTS ADULTS EIGHTEEN TO
TWENTY REPRESENT JUST 4% OF THE
POPULATION OVULATION BUT THEY
COMMIT 17% OF GUN [inaudible]
HOMICIDES TWO OF THE WERE SCHOOL
SHOOTINGS IN AMERICAN HISTORY AT
MARJORY STONEMAN DOUGLAS HIGH
SCHOOL AND PARK IN FLORIDA AND
AT SANDY HOOK ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
IN NEWTOWN CONNECTICUT WERE
COMMITTED.
BY PERPETRATORS UNDER THE AGE OF
TWENTY ONE AFTER SEVENTEEN
PEOPLE WERE KILLED THAT MARJORIE
STONEMAN DOUGLAS HIGH SCHOOL OF
THE STATE OF FLORIDA.
ENACTED SIMILAR LEGISLATION TO
THE SIGNED BY REPUBLICAN
GOVERNOR.
COMPANIES LIKE DICK'S SPORTING
GOODS IN WALMART RECENTLY
CHANGED THEIR POLICIES TO NO
LONGER SELL FIREARMS TO
CUSTOMERS UNDER TWENTY ONE YEARS
OF AGE.
GUNS IN THE HANDS OF YOUNG
ADULTS MAY SADLY ALSO LEAD TO
MORE SUICIDE ATTEMPTS THAT
RESULTS IN FATALITIES.
DATA SHOWS ABOUT 38% OF ALL
SUICIDE BY PEOPLE UNDER TWENTY
ONE ARE COMMITTED WITH A GUN AND
MORE OFTEN THAN NOT.
A LONG GUN IS USED RATHER THAN A
HANDGUN.
S. B. ELEVEN HUNDRED IS THE NEXT
STEP IN CALIFORNIA'S LEADERSHIP
ON PROACTIVE GUN SAFETY POLICIES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
COLLEAGUES.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER HARPER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
THIS IS YET ANOTHER BILL THAT
TAKES AWAY THE SECOND AMENDMENT
RIGHTS OF LAW ABIDING CITIZENS.
WEATHER IS A TWENTY YEAR OLD
HOMEOWNER OR AN EIGHTEEN YEAR
OLD SINGLE MOTHER THEY DESERVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BUY A FIREARM
AND DEFEND THEIR FAMILIES AND
THEIR PROPERTY.
IF WE WANNA TAKE GUNS OUT OF THE
HANDS OF CRIMINALS THEN WE NEED
TO ADDRESS THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE'S BACKLOG OF ALMOST TEN
THOUSAND PEOPLE WHO WERE ARMED
BUT PROHIBITED FROM OWNING A
FIREARM.
UNDER CURRENT LAW.
WE SHOULD STOP TREATING LAW
ABIDING SIT CITIZENS AND ADULTS
[inaudible]
LIKE CHILDREN. EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD
CAN VOTE.
GET A JOB WITHOUT A PERMIT.
JOIN THE MILITARY AND THEY
CERTAINLY SHOULD BE ABLE TO
EXERCISE THEIR SECOND AMENDMENT
AND DEFEND THEIR LIFE.
AND THEIR PROPERTY.
AND THEIR FAMILIES BY OWNING A
FIREARM I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
NO VOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WALDRON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU I RISE IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL FOR MANY OTHER
REASONS STATED.
THE LAST TIME I CHECKED AND
EIGHTEEN YEAR OLDS AND ADULT
[inaudible]
I MEAN I DON'T I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY WERE TAKEN AWAY
RIGHTS OF ADULTS SO I ORIGINAL
WILL.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MELINDA'S.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER KEEP
THIS BRIEF AND I'LL JUST REMIND
EVERYONE OF THE STATISTICS THAT
I POINTED OUT TO YOU YESTERDAY
WHICH IS THAT NEARLY 85%
ACCORDING TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE'S WEBSITE.
NEARLY 85% OF CRIMES COMMITTED
WITHIN WITH THE FIRE ARM ARE
DONE SO WITH A HANDGUN NOT A
RIFLE.
I URGE YOU KNOW VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN NO FOR THE
REQUEST TO SPEAK ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BONTA WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES FOR YOUR
YOUR COMMENTS I APPRECIATE IT
I'M KEEP IN MIND FLORIDA
GOVERNOR.
REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR RICK SCOTT
SIGNED A SIMILAR BILL ACTUALLY
WENT FURTHER.
THAN THAN THIS.
ONE ARE WE ALSO KNOW THAT
EIGHTEEN YEAR OLDS CAN'T
PURCHASE TOBACCO ALCOHOL OR
DON'T USE CANNABIS THE DATA
DRIVES THIS POLICY IT SHOWS THAT.
AND THOSE BETWEEN EIGHTEEN AND
TWENTY ONE ARE MORE LIKELY TO
COMMIT.
I HOMICIDES AND SUICIDES USING
LONG GUNS AND WHILE IT IS TRUE
AS I STATED AMOUNT NOT.
TALKING POINTS THAT THOSE THAT
HANDGUNS ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
MOST -- GUN
VIOLENCE IN IN THE UNITED STATES
THE LONG GUNS ARE USED IN SOME
OF THE MOST HIGHLY --
PUBLICIZE MOST TRAGIC MASS
SHOOTING SO THIS IS BASED ON
DATA THIS IS BASED ON EVIDENCE
IS A POLICY THAT'S BEEN IT'S
BEEN USED ELSEWHERE EFFECTIVELY
IT WILL SAVE LIVES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MADAM HER PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES EYES
FORTY TWO NO.
TWENTY EIGHT THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE ARE MOVING NOW TO ITEM TWO
THIRTY TWO SP TWELVE OH FIVE
MARKER PLEASE READ.
SETTLED ALTHOUGH FIVE BY SENATOR
HILL AND ACTUALLY THE FIRE
PROTECTION ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AND PLEASED TO
PRESENT SB TWELVE A FIVE BY
SENATOR HILL I WANT TO START BY
THANKING FIREFIGHTERS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. FOR PUTTING THEIR
LIVES ON THE LINE EVERY DAY TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC.
A RECENT INVESTIGATIVE REPORTS
SHOW THAT MANY SCHOOLS IN
APARTMENTS IN THE BAY AREA
WEREN'T RECEIVING THEIR ANNUAL
FIRE INSPECTION.
AS REQUIRED BY STATE LAW THIS
BILL ENSURES THAT FIRE
DEPARTMENTS ARE COMMUNICATING
WITH THEIR GOVERNING AUTHORITY
DURING THE ANNUAL BUDGET CYCLE
ABOUT.
THEIR COMPLIANCE WITH STATE
MANDATED SAFETY INSPECTIONS THIS
DIALOGUE WILL ENSURE THAT FIRE
DEPARTMENTS ARE COMPLYING WITH
THEIR INSPECTION MANDATES AND
INCREASE THE LIKELIHOOD.
THAT THEY ARE RECEIVING THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED TO
APPROPRIATELY STAFF I CARRY OUT
STATE MANDATED INSPECTIONS THE
BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION.
AND HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING I REQUEST TO
SPEAK MEDI PARKING OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
RULE AND HOW THE VOTES I SIXTY
NINE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING BACK TO
CONCURRENCE.
ITEM ZERO ITEMS.
ONE THERE'S AN ITEM ZERO ITEM
ZERO THREE TWELVE PASS AND
RETAIN.
MOVING TO ITEM THIRTEEN A. B.
TWENTY FORTY THREE MATTER
QUICKLY ST.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FORTY THREE
BY SOME A MEMBER ARAMBULA AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY FOSTER YOUTH.
SOME NEVER ARAMBULA HERE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER.
AB TWENTY FORTY THREE
ESTABLISHES THE FAMILY URGENT
RESPONSE SYSTEM FOR FOSTER YOUTH
IN CARE GIVERS.
STATEWIDE TOLL FREE HOTLINE
AVAILABLE TWENTY FOUR HOURS A
DAY SEVEN DAYS A WEEK FOR
CAREGIVERS AND FOSTER YOUTH WHO
ARE EXPERIENCING EMOTIONAL
BEHAVIORAL OR OTHER DIFFICULTIES
AND NEED IMMEDIATE HELP.
SENATE AMENDMENTS PROVIDES THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS BILL IS
CONTINGENT UPON THE
APPROPRIATION OF THE FUNDS IN
THE EDGE ANNUAL BUDGET ACT.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED STRONG
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I ASK FOR
YOUR CONCURRENCE.
THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE HOMEOWNERS WHO.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
MEDICARE PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES I
SEVENTY NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM FOURTEEN AB
TWENTY FIVE SIXTEEN THE CLERK
WILL READ.
AS A MALE TWENTY FIVE SIXTEEN BY
SELLING MEMBER EGGMAN AND OTHERS
ACTUALLY THE DAMS AND RESERVOIRS
[inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER EGGMAN.
BUT THANK YOU MEMBERS AB TWENTY
FIVE SIXTEEN IS BY BIPARTISAN
DAM SAFETY BILL PLEASE VOTE.
FOR THANK YOU SEEING THEIR
REQUEST TO SPEAK MADAM CLERK IS
OPEN.
TO ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
YOU MAKE MEDICAL PLEASE CLOSE
THE ROLE ON TELLY THE VOTES I
SEVENTY ONE NO.
ZERO THE DAM BILL IS CONCURRED
IN.
MOVING TO ITEM FIFTEEN AB TWENTY
NINE SIXTY EIGHT MATTER PER
PLEASE READ AS A LABEL TWENTY
NINE SIXTY EIGHT BY SOME A
MEMBER LEVINE AND ACTUALLY THE
HEALING ARTS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS UNFORTUNATELY SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT IS SOMETHING THAT IS
A PROBLEM IN THE MENTAL HEALTH
CARE.
SECTOR AND BECAUSE OF THAT THE
HEALTH CARE LICENSING BOARDS ARE
REQUIRED TO PUBLISH A BROCHURE
TITLED PROFESSIONAL THERAPY
NEVER INCLUDE SEX THIS BILL IS
ON CONCURRENCE TO UPDATE THAT
THOSE DEFINITIONS ARE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING NO DISCUSSION
METAPHOR PLEASE OPEN THE RUN.
ON MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE A ROLE IN
HOW THE VOTES I SEVENTY TWO NO
ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM SIXTEEN AB TWELVE
EIGHTY NINE MADAM QUICKLY THREE
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE EIGHTY NINE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER ARAMBULA AND
ACTUALLY DO REAL ESTATE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ARAMBULA.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB
TWELVE EIGHTY NINE IS A
TECHNICAL BILL THAT UPDATES
DEFINITIONS IN THE CIVIL CODE
RELATED TO THE TRANSFER OF REAL
PROPERTY AND REAL ESTATE
DISCLOSURE REQUIREMENTS.
AMENDMENTS TAKEN ON THE SENATE
FURTHER CLARIFY SOME OF THE
DEFINITIONS AND DISCLOSURE
REQUIREMENTS.
THIS BILL HAS HAD BIPARTISAN AND
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT THROUGHOUT THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING NO DISCUSSION
MADAM CLERK WAS OPEN.
TO ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTE RETIRED ABOUT
TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES AYE.
SIXTY I SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN MOVING TO ITEM SEVENTEEN AB
TWENTY ONE SEVENTY NINE MADAM
CLERK PLEASE READ.
AT SOME LEVEL TWENTY ONE SEVENTY
NINE BY SOME THE MEMBER GIPSON
AND I PLENTY TO LOBBY SERVICE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON.
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB
TWENTY ONE SEVENTY NINE IS BACK
ON THE FLOOR FOR CONCURRENT
AMENDMENTS ADDRESS CHOPPED GREEN
OUT ISSUES --
AND OUR TECHNICAL AND IN
CLARIFYING IN NATURE
RESPECTFULLY ASK AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SING A DISCUSSION
ABOUT THE A MEMBER.
THAT IS OPEN.
TO ALL MEMBERS VOTE YOU DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRING TO VOTE THE CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE AND HOW THE VOTES
I SIXTY SIX KNOWS ONE THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
LIVING ITEM EIGHTEEN AB TWENTY
TO SEVENTY FIVE MADAM CLERK
PLEASE READ AS A LEGAL TWENTY TO
SEVENTY FIVE BY SOME REMEMBER
ARAMBULA AND ACTUALLY MEDI CAL.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARAMBULA.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
AB TWENTY TO SEVENTY FIVE
REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES TO
ESTABLISH A QUALITY ASSESSMENT
AND PERFORMANCE IMPROVEMENT
PROGRAM TO IMPROVE THE QUALITY
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES PROVIDED
BY MANAGED CARE PLANS.
AND REDUCE HEALTH DISPARITIES
THE BILL WAS AMENDED IN THE
SENATE TO MAKE TECHNICAL CHANGES
AND TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION
REGIONAL VARIATION IN QUALITY
ASSESSMENT AND PERFORMANCE.
LEVELS I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SING I REQUEST TO
SPEAK MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE THE
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND HOW THE VOTES EYES FIFTY
KNOWS TWENTY ONE THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM NINETEEN AB
TWENTY THREE THIRTY NINE
METAPHOR PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY THREE THIRTY NINE
PRICE ONLY MEMBER GIPSON AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO WATER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON.
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS AB TWENTY
THREE THIRTY NINE IS BACK ON THE
FLOOR FOR CONCURRENT AMENDMENTS
NARROW THE BILL TO FOCUS ON
THREE CITIES --
WHICH INCLUDES MONTEBELLO --
DEL MONTE AT WILLOW THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE.
ALSO INCLUDE A THREE YEAR SUNSET
THIS BILL I RECEIVED A
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING NO DISCUSSION
MADAM CLERK WAS OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND HOW THE VOTES EYES FIFTY
THREE NO EIGHT THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN ITEM
TWENTY PASS AND RETAIN A MOVING
TO ITEM.
TWENTY ONE AB TWELVE THIRTY ONE
THE CLERK WILL READ AS A LEGAL
TWELVE THIRTY ONE BY SOME THE
MEMBER BUT FAIR AND ACTUALLY THE
PUBLIC POST SECONDARY EDUCATION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER.
YES MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE TO PRESENT YOUR AB TWELVE
THIRTY ONE THE C. ISSUE MERIT
SALARY ADJUSTMENT.
IT IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE ON
SENATE AMENDMENTS AS MANY OF YOU
KNOW TWELVE THIRTY ONE WILL
REINSTATE THE 5% SO A BIT US OUR
STEPS.
FORESEE ISSUE STAFF SUPPORT
STAFF AFTER IT WAS UNILATERALLY
IF TAKEN AWAY TWO DECADES AGO
AND THEY REMAIN THE ONLY GROUP
IN THE C. ISSUE SYSTEM WITHOUT A
MERIT SALARY INCREASE.
THE AMENDMENTS PROVIDE LATITUDE
FOR BARGAINING REQUIRE THAT THE
LANGUAGE OF THE BILL BE
INCORPORATING THE FUTURE
CONTRACTS AS THEIR RENEWED
REQUIRES ANY COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH THE SALARY.
A REWARDING OF THE STEPS A BIT
NAY EXISTING RESOURCES AND ADDS
A SUNSET DATE OF TWENTY TWENTY
NINE THIS IS A SIMPLE ACT OF
FAIRNESS PROVIDING HARD WORKING
STAFF THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
REWARDED FOR THEIR PERFORMANCE.
THE BILL HAS BEEN RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN BOTH
HOUSES AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE ON CONCURRENT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALLEN YOU'RE
WRECKING MERRILEES A GENTLEMAN
THIS IS NOT A SIMPLE ACT OF
FAIRNESS THIS IS A 5% AUTOMATIC
SALARY INCREASE IF YOU WORK FOR
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM.
THINK ABOUT THIS WHAT CALIFORNIA
RESIDENT OR CITIZEN HAS AN
AUTOMATIC 5% SALARY INCREASE
JUST FOR SHOWING UP
SATISFACTORILY IN DOING THEIR
JOB EVERY SINGLE YEAR.
IS IT NO SURPRISE THERE ARE
CALLS FOR CONSTANT TUITION
INCREASES IN CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
SYSTEMS WHENBILLS LIKE THIS TO
GIVE AUTOMATIC 5% SALARY
INCREASES.
ARE ACTUALLY BEING CREDIBLY AND
SERIOUSLY DEBATE ON THIS FLOOR
I'LL TELL YOU RIGHT NOW I DON'T
SEE TO THE MICROPHONES UP SO YOU
KNOW HOW MUCH DEBATE THERE IS.
THIS IS VERY SIMPLE THERE ARE NO
JOBS IN CALIFORNIA WERE YOU
GETTING AN AUTOMATIC 5% SALARY
INCREASE JUST FOR SHOWING UP IN
SATISFACTORY DOING YOUR JOB.
THAT SHOULD CERTAINLY NOT BE THE
CASE IN ANY STATE.
FUSIONS ARE SUBJECT TO TUITION
INCREASES ON CALIFORNIA'S
STUDENTS VOTE NOW.
THANK YOU I SEE NO FURTHER
REQUEST TO SPEAK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WEBER YOU MAY CLOSE YES MADAM
SPEAKER I DON'T WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THE 3% THAT SOME GOD WHO
DON'T SHOW UP --
BUT THAT'S NOT THAT'S NOT THE
ISSUE.
THE ISSUE IS.
THE ISSUE IS VERY CLEAR.
THIS IS A MERIT INCREASE YOU
HAVE TO APPLY FOR IT IS NOT
AUTOMATIC.
AND IT WAS TAKEN AWAY FROM THIS
THIS GROUP HERE THE LOWEST PAID
GROUP IN THE CSU SYSTEM.
IT WAS TAKEN AWAY FROM THEM
ALONG WITH EVERYONE ELSE
EVERYONE ELSE GOT IT BACK THESE
FOLKS DID NOT AND YOU HAVE TO
APPLY FOR IT HAS TO BE MERIT
BASED.
AND IF YOU GET IT IT COMES OUT
OF EXISTING RESOURCES AND IT'S
NOT JUST FOR SHOWING UP IS
BECAUSE YOU HAVE BEEN EVALUATED
BY YOUR EMPLOYER OR BY YOUR
SUPERVISOR WORTHY OF AN INCREASE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR IT THIS
OUT AND I BOTH FOR A. B. TWELVE
THIRTY ONE TO ONCE AGAIN GET OUR
HARDEST WORKING PERSONS THAT ARE
SEE ISSUE THE KIND OF FAIRNESS
AND RESPECT THAT OTHERS HAVE IN
THE SYSTEM.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOU AYE
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND HOW A THE VOTES EYES FORTY
NINE NO NINETEEN THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
NINETY SIX TO WITHDRAW SB
THIRTEEN THIRTY NINE STERN FROM
THE UTILITIES AND ENERGY
COMMITTEE.
AND ORDER THE BUILT THE SECOND
READING FILE WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
ORDER AB TWENTY IF IT THREE
MEDINA TO ENROLLMENT.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND GENERAL SIXTY TWO A THE
AND ASSEMBLY RULE FIFTY SIX THE
FILE NOTICE REQUIREMENTS TO
ALLOW THE FOLLOWING COMMITTEES
TO MEET.
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE TO HEAR
S. B. TWO TWELVE JACKSON AS
BEFORE SIXTY FIVE JACKSON S. B.
NINE THIRTY NINE PORTANTINO S.
B. ELEVEN TWENTY ONE DODD AB
SEVEN SIXTEEN O'DONNELL PENDING
RE REFER OFTEN EDUCATION
COMMITTEE.
AND AB TEN SIXTY TWO LEVINE ON
WEDNESDAY AUGUST TWENTY NINTH
UPON A GERMAN OF SESSION AND
ROOM FORTY TWO OF TO THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE TO HEAR AB
SEVEN SIXTEEN O'DONNELL AB.
TWENTY EIGHT NINETY EIGHT
MCCARTY AN SCR ONE FIFTY SEVEN
PORTANTINO ON WEDNESDAY AUGUST
TWENTY NINE UPON CALLED THE
CHAIR IN ROOM.
ONE TWENTY SIX BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS TO HEAR S. B.
FOURTEEN FIFTY NINE CANNELLA AB
AT TWELVE FORTY SEVEN IS ARYAN.
AB THIRTY ONE FORTY THREE LOW A.
B. THIRTY ONE FORTY FOUR LOW AND
ON WEDNESDAY AUGUST TWENTY NINTH
AT NINE AM ROOM FORTY TO GO.
TO THE HEALTH COMMITTEE TO HEAR
AB TEN NINETY TWO COOLEY ON
WEDNESDAY AUGUST TWENTY NINE TO
NINE THIRTY AM IN ROOM.
FOUR THIRTY SEVEN THE HIGHER
EDUCATION COMMITTEE TO HEAR AB
TWENTY NINETY EIGHT MCCARTY
PENDING RE REFER ALL FROM THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE ON THURSDAY
AUGUST THIRTIETH AT NINE THIRTY
A. M. IN ROOM.
FOUR THIRTY SEVEN AND
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE TO HEAR
S. BERRYHILL AND AB TWENTY THREE
THIRTY BIGELOW A. B. THIRTY ONE
THIRTY FIVE FRAZIER AS WE FIVE
NINETEEN BELL AND S. B. SEVEN
FIFTEEN DELGADO.
ON WEDNESDAY AUGUST TWENTY NINTH
OF ROOM FOR TO BE SEVEN FUND
CALLED THE CHAIR.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
MEMBERS I AM PREPARED TO LIFT
THE CALL ON SB.
ONE HUNDRED MA'AM QUICKLY AS
POST
IT'S GONZALEZ FLETCHER
MOVES THE CALL.
WE ARE MOVING BACK AND FILE
ORDER.
ITEMS TWENTY TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE AND AND WHEN.
BEFORE PASS TEMPORARILY ITEM
TWENTY FIVE AB TWENTY FIVE
NINETY SIX MANA PER PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE NINETY
SIX BY SOME REMEMBER COOLEY AND
OTHERS AN ACTOR LINKED TO
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY SIX TASK
GOBIZ TO DEVELOP AN ECONOMIC
PLAN FOR THE STATE SENT
AMENDMENTS WERE CLARIFYING HAS
NO KNOWN.
NO OPPOSITION IRISH DRIVE VOTE.
I THINK USING THEIR REQUEST TO
SPEAK MEDICAL PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTES AYE SIXTY EIGHT
KNOWS HERE THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN MOVING TO ITEM
TWENTY SIX AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY
THREE METAPHOR PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE TWENTY
THREE BY FAMILY MEMBER DAVID
CHIU AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
TRANSPORTATION ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHIU.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER BACK ON
CONCURRENCE AB TWENTY NINE
TWENTY THREE IS A REGIONAL BILL.
ADDRESSING THE BEAR IS MOST
INTENSE CHALLENGES OF HOUSING
AND TRAFFIC CONGESTION WITH A
NARROWLY CRAFTED TRANSIT
ORIENTED POLICY.
ITS NARROW BECAUSE IT ONLY
APPLIES TO LAND OWNED BY PART
NEXT DEPART STATIONS IT IT IT
WOULD APPLY TO ABOUT TWO AND A
FIFTY ACRES.
AROUND TWENTY SIX PART STATIONS
THAT ARE CURRENTLY SURFACE
PARKING LOTS THIS BILL REQUIRES
PART TO ESTABLISH BASIC TIER DE
STANDARDS ONLY IN AREAS WHERE
RESIDENTS.
DIRECTLY ELECT PARKS BOARD
MEMBERS JORDY VOTED ON THIS
FLOOR WE CONTINUE TO ENGAGE
DEEPLY WITH THE OPPOSITION.
AND THREE THREE SENATE
COMMITTEES MADE MANY AMENDMENTS
TO ADDRESS CONCERNS AMENDMENTS
INCLUDE ELIMINATING STREAMLINING
FOR PROJECTS NOT WITHIN ONE
STORY OF EXISTING LOCAL HEIGHTS.
LIMITING THIS BILL TO LAND
CURRENTLY ON BY BART AND ON
INFILL SITES REQUIRE IMPART TO
ADDRESS COMMUTERS WHO RELY ON
PARTS COMMUTER PARKING.
EXEMPTING CITIES AT A PARTY
IMPLEMENTED SUITABLE ZONING
INCREASING THE DEPTH OF
AFFORDABILITY 420% OF UNITS THAT
HAVE TO BE AFFORDABLE EACH
STATION. 30% OF UNITS NEED TO BE
AFFORDABLE ACROSS THE PORTFOLIO.
EXPANDING LOCAL CONSULTATION
REQUIREMENTS DIFFERENT A LOCAL
SPECIFIC PLANS AND REQUIRING AN
AUTOMATIC SUNSET.
THIS BILLS EXTREMELY TARGETED
WITH NUMEROUS CHECKS AND
BALANCES ARE BURIED NEEDS
DESPERATELY TO ADDRESS OUR
HOUSING CONGESTION CRISIS WITH
THAT I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
[inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY.
I THINK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS.
I RISE TODAY TO SPEAK ON THIS
BILL ONE THAT I VOTED AGAINST IN
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE.
I'D LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
AUTHORS ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHU AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ME MEMBER
GRAYSON.
WHO MADE SIGNIFICANT AMENDMENTS
TO THE SENATE TO NARROW THE
SCOPE AND INCLUDE A ROLE FOR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES?
IT'S NOW A BETTER BILL THEN WE
HEARD THE COMMITTEE IN APRIL.
WE ALL HAVE TO ADMIT THE HOUSING
CRISIS IS REAL I UNDERSTAND THE
AUTHOR'S GOAL TO INCREASE
HOUSING AROUND BART STATIONS.
I ALSO UNDERSTAND THE NEED TO
DEAL WITH LOCAL AGENCIES.
WHO JUST DON'T SEEM TO
UNDERSTAND IF THEY DON'T DO
THEIR PART WHEN IT COMES TO
SUPPORTING APPROVING HOUSING?
THEY WILL CONTINUE TO SPUR THE
EROSION OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT
PLANNING AND APPROVAL AUTHORITY
TO FOR ALL LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
I'M STILL DEEPLY TROUBLED ABOUT
THIS BILLS PRESIDENT AND ABOUT
THE IMPACT ON ON THE
CONSTITUTIONAL ROLE ARTICLE
ELEVEN SECTIONAL LEVEL.
ELEVEN THE CITIES AND COUNTIES
HAVE MADE IN MAKING LAND USE
DECISIONS.
I'M CONCERNED THAT WE'RE TELLING
THE LOCALS.
WHO ARE ACTUALLY STRIVING TO
SITE PERMITS AND BUILD A
DESPERATELY NEEDED HOUSING THAT
THEIR EFFORTS DON'T MATTER?
THEY WILL STILL LOSE THEIR
LANDING USE AUTHORITY LIKE THOSE
WHO SHIRK THE RESPONSIBILITY.
AND I AM FEARFUL THAT OTHERS
WILL RUSH TO GRAB SUCH AUTHORITY
WITHOUT FIRST GIVING US A CHANCE
TO SEE HOW THIS VERY UNIQUE
EXPERIMENT MAY WORK IN THIS
LIMITED ENVIRONMENT.
I PREDICT YOU'LL HEAR ME REPEAT
THIS NEXT YEAR. FOR THESE
REASONS I REGRETTABLY CANNOT
SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY.
EVEN WHAT THE MAJOR IMPROVEMENTS
MADE IN THE SENATE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRAZIER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
IN OPPOSITION TO AB.
TWENTY NINE TWENTY THREE I FULLY
SUPPORT TRANSIT ORIENTED
DEVELOPMENT.
BUT AS THE CHAIR OF THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE I FULLY
UNDERSTAND THAT INCREASING
HOUSING YOUR TRANSIT.
HELPS EASE TRAFFIC CONGESTION
ARE ROSA MAKES THE DAILY GRIND.
OF A COMMUTE EVEN EASIER
[inaudible]
HOWEVER.
I CANNOT SPORTY AB.
TWENTY NINE TWENTY THREE THIS
BILL WOULD UNDERMINING VERY CORE
PRINCIPLE OF THIS STATE.
LOCAL CONTROL OVER LAND USE.
LET ME REPEAT.
LOCAL CONTROL OVER LAND USE ANY
OF YOU WHO WERE ELECTED
MUNICIPAL.
ELECTIVES ALWAYS HATED WHEN
SOMEBODY CAME IN AND TOLD WHAT
YOU WHAT YOU HAD TO DO.
HE BOWED YOUR NECK.
AND YOU SAID NO.
THEN WE HAVE THE RIGHT FOR LAND
USE.
AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY THREE
WOULD SAID A SIGNIFICANT
PRESIDENT BY GIVING SPECIAL
TRANSIT DISTRICT NOT A CITY OR A
COUNTY.
LAND USE PLANNING AND DECISION
AUTHORITY AND REQUIRE THE
SURROUNDING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
CONFORM. TWO THE BOARD ADOPTED
GUIDELINES.
MARK CURRENTLY CAN DEVELOP
BORROWED LAND AROUND THEIR
STATIONS RIGHT NOW.
WORKING COLLABORATIVELY WITH
THEIR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
THIS RARE REALITY THAT IN THE
RECENT YEARS CITIES HAVE
APPROVED THOUSANDS OF HOUSING
UNITS NEAR BART STATIONS.
AND BART HASN'T HAD A
DEVELOPMENT APPLICATION REJECTED.
OH MY GOD.
IN A DECADE.
LET'S KEEP IT THAT WAY NOT OPEN
UP THE POSSIBILITY OF
INCONSISTENT PLANNING THAT MAY
CONFLICT WITH CITY AND COUNTY
GENERAL PLANS.
AND JUST THINK ABOUT IT THIS MAY
WORK IN A MUNICIPAL OUR EXCUSE
ME UNIT IN A IRVINE OR A A VERY --
BICU DE PRIME LOCATION.
BUT NOT IN RURAL BECAUSE IT
HASN'T BEEN DEVELOPED IT CREATES
AN INCONSISTENCY FOR DEVELOPERS
AND THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING
TO HAPPEN AND NOW.
THEY'RE GONNA BE SHIRKING THE
WILLINGNESS TO GO FORWARD
[inaudible]
LET'S SOME.
KEEP IT THAT WAY NOT OPEN UP THE
POSSIBILITY OF INCONSISTENT
PLANNING.
THAT MAY CONFLICT WITH CITY AND
COUNTY GENERAL PLANS THAT WERE
PUT IN PLACE.
OVER YEARS AND YEARS OF
CONSIDERATION.
BY THEIR CONSTITUENTS ALSO.
LET'S AGREE THAT PLANNING FOR
METROPOLITAN AREAS VERSUS
SUBURBAN AREAS AS I SAID SUCH AS
MINE IS VASTLY DIFFERENT.
GENERAL PLANS FOR AVAILABLE LAND
IN THE SOBRE SUBURBS MUST NOT BE
STYMIED BY A METROPOLITAN
DEVELOPERS.
THE AIM IS APPROPRIATE FOR THEIR
REGION.
THE GENERAL PLANS WHICH LOCAL
ELECTED OFFICIALS ON THE
CONSTITUENTS HAVE AGREED UPON IN
MANY CASES HAVE TAKEN AS I
MENTIONED.
YEARS TO PLAN AND IMPLEMENT.
THOUSANDS OF MY CONSTITUENTS
BREITBART EVERY DAY AND RECENTLY
A NEW STATION OPEN IN MY
DISTRICT IN THE CITY OF ANTIOCH.
THE PLANNING FOR THAT STATION OF
WHICH I PARTICIPATED IN.
AS A LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIAL
REYES GRAVE CONCERNS. FOR ME
REGARDING BART'S PLANNING
PROCESS.
AGAIN THE BEST LOCAL ADVICE AND
STATISTICS.
BART'S NEW STATION WAS OPEN
WITHOUT PROVING.
PROVIDING ADEQUATE PARKING OR
ADEQUATE PUBLIC SAFETY FOR THE
VOLUME OF WRITERS THAT WE KNEW
WE WOULD SEE BUT THEY IGNORE.
MY CITIES OF BRENTWOOD IN
PITTSBURGH ARE OFFICIALLY
OPPOSED TO THIS LEGISLATION AND
IN FACT.
THE CITY OF BROWN WOULD SHARE
CONCERNS OVER HOW THE BILL WOULD
AFFECT ONGOING DEVELOPMENT.
PLANS FOR A POSSIBLE FUTURE E.
BART STATION.
THIS IS BEING STUDIED NOW WITH
FULL BART INVOLVEMENT.
AS STATED BY THE CITY OF BROWN
WITH THIS BILLS ENTIRELY
INCONSISTENT WITH LOCAL CONTROL
OF LAND USE POLICIES AND
PLANNING AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
WHERE IT BELONGS IN FACT CITIES
THROUGHOUT THE BOARD DISTRICT
INCLUDING CITIES AND ENTITIES
LOCATED WITHIN?
THESE AUTHORS DISTRICTS ARE
OPPOSED TO THIS LEGISLATION.
AS WE WOULD EXPECT THE LEAGUE OF
CITIES AND SEE SEC ARE
COMPLETELY OPPOSED ALSO.
I ALSO HAVE GRAVE CONCERNS THE
BOARD AMBITIOUSLY PLANNING TO
TEO DE CONSTRUCTION THROUGHOUT
THE BAY AREA.
DOES NOT HAVE THE CAR CAPACITY.
SERVE THOSE DOD'S.
OUR CURRENT PLAN FOR IS FOR ONE
THOUSAND EIGHTY CARS.
AT A TOTAL COST OF FOUR POINT
TWO BILLION DOLLARS OF WHICH THE
ONLY HAVE ABOUT 60% ABOUT FUNDED.
NOT WITHSTANDING THE FUNDING
SHORTAGE THE ADDITIONAL TRAIN
CARS WILL HOPEFULLY MEET.
THE CURRENT RIDERSHIP NEEDS AS
WELL AND TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE
FUTURE BART TO SAN JOSE WRITERS.
THIS IS AN ALMOST
INCOMPREHENSIBLE. THIRTY SECONDS
LEFT LOOK AT THE PLEASANT HILL
BART STATION ONCE DESCRIBES IT
EXEMPLARY MODEL OF TRANSIT
ORIENTED DEVELOPMENT INVITING
RESIDENTS WORKERS A SHOPPERS TO
DRIVE LESS.
AND TAKE MORE TRANSIT WELL
PLANNING FOR THE TOUR DE
PLEASANT HILL BART STATION BEGIN
THE MID NINETEEN EIGHTIES BUT
THEY THEY GET OCCUPANCY IN THE
APARTMENTS UNTIL.
TWO THOUSAND TEN FINALLY IN THE
SPIRIT PLEASE OF COURSE SEE I
WOULD HAVE HOPED THAT THE
AUTHORS OF THIS LEGISLATION WILL
DISCUSS THIS PROPOSAL WILL
MEMBERS.
WHO HAVE STATIONS IN THEIR
DISTRICT TO ASCERTAIN SUPPORT AS
WELL AS FORTY FIVE YEARS OF
HISTORICAL PERSPECTIVE ROUNDS
BART'S PLANNING AND FUNDING
CHALLENGES YOUR TIME IS UP A FEW
COLLEAGUES THIS IS A DISTRICT
BILL THE PROBLEM IS?
IT'S IN THE WRONG DISTRICT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NOBLE THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN YOUR
RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER PROUD TO RISE IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY THREE
APPLAUD MY COLLEAGUES WHO WORKED.
ON THIS INNOVATIVE APPROACH SAN
MATEO COUNTY WILL BENEFIT AS
WILL THE OTHER PART COUNTIES IN
THE BAY AREA AB TWENTY NINE
TWENTY THREE IS A TARGETED A
BALANCED APPROACH WITH IMPORTANT
GUARD RAILS.
SUCH AS A SUNSET CLAUSE.
STRONG DATA REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS AN EXTENSIVE LOCAL
COORDINATION REQUIREMENTS
MEMBERS WE HAVE AGGRESSIVE STATE
AND REGIONAL HOUSING GOALS AND
CONGESTION GOALS IN CLIMATE.
CHANGE GOALS AS WELL THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP TO ADDRESS ALL OF
THE ABOVE AND I ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAKER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AND I THINK OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FRANCISCO FOR
HIS ENGAGEMENT ON THE SPELL IT
HE DID SOMETHING THAT NOT MANY
MEMBERS DO WHEN YOU ARE OPPOSED
TO BELEIVE MET WITH MY
CONSTITUENTS --
FOR AN HOUR OVER THE JULY RECESS
I TO HEAR FROM THEM AND WHY THEY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AND I WANT TO
THINK OUR COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO FOR DOING THAT NOT
MANY US WOULD DO THAT FOR FOLKS
THAT ARE.
NOT THEIR CONSTITUENTS THE
REASON THEY CAME TO MEET WITH
THE AUTHORS IS BECAUSE THIS BILL
DRAMATICALLY AFFECTS
[inaudible]
MY CONSTITUENTS.
AND SO WHEN YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE
A BILL THAT IS THIS DRAMATIC
DEPARTURE NOT ONLY FROM OUR
PRACTICE BUT FROM OUR
CONSTITUTION AGAIN ARTICLE
ELEVEN SECTIONAL LEVIN.
CRYSTAL CLEAR.
THAT LOCAL DECISION MAKING ON
HOUSING NEEDS TO BE KEPT WITH
THE CITIES AND THE COUNTIES YOU
NEED TO HAVE VERY VERY GOOD
REASONS TO DO IT.
YOU WOULD THINK THAT ONE OF THE
REASONS MIGHT BE THAT PART HAS
BEEN SUBMITTING AGAIN AND AGAIN.
DIFFERENT PROPOSALS TO THE
CITIES THAT THEY'VE CONTINUALLY
REJECTED.
THAT IS NOT THE CASE.
AS ARE MEMBERS FROM OKLEE JUST
IDENTIFIED BART HAS NOT PROPOSED
A SINGLE PROPOSAL FOR
DEVELOPMENT THAT HAS BEEN
REJECTED BY A SINGLE ENTITY
AFFECTED BY THIS BILL.
SO IT'S NOT THAT PORTS PROPOSALS
ARE GETTING REJECTED THAT'S
THAT'S NOT A REASON TO GO
AGAINST OUR PRACTICE MAYBE IT'S
THAT THE CITIES THAT ARE MOST
AFFECTED BY THIS BILL.
ARE THE ONES THAT KEEP SAYING NO
TO TRANSIT AREA DEVELOPMENT
WHICH I FULLY EMBRACE.
AND BELIEVE WE NEED TO TO HAVE
AND PROMOTE TO HELP WITH THE
HOUSING SHORTAGE IN CALIFORNIA.
THAT IS ALSO NOT THE CASE.
THE CITY'S MOST AFFECTED BY THIS
BILLS ARE THE ONES IN THE STATE
WHO ARE THE VERY BEST AUTHORS.
OF ALL KINDS OF PROPOSALS FOR
TRANSITORY DEVELOPMENT THEY ARE
EMBRACING IT MORE THAN OTHER
CITIES AND YOU JUST NEED LOOK AT
THE FACTS.
THE CITY OF DUBLIN WHERE I'VE
LIVED FOR THE LAST FIFTEEN YEARS
HAS APPROVED OVER FOUR THOUSAND
UNITS JUST IN THE LAST FEW YEARS.
TWO THOUSAND MULTI FAMILY UNITS
ALONE ARE WITHIN A HALF MILE THE
BART STATION.
TWO THOUSAND IN FACT ARE USED TO
BE A LARGE SURFACE LOT AT THAT
DUBLIN STATION TRIPLE THE SIZE
OF THE SERVICE A LOT AND IT'S
ALL MULTI FAMILY.
UNITS HIGH DENSITY HOUSING RIGHT
NOW TODAY.
IN FACT THE CITY OF DUBLIN IS
MEETING ITS RINA NUMBERS FIVE
YEARS IN ADVANCE AND THEY ARE
THE NUMBER ONE CITY AFFECTED BY
THIS BILL.
PLEASANTON WHICH ALSO HAS A BART
STATION WITH THE SURFACE PARKING
LOT TO BE AFFECTED BY THIS BILL
HAS ALSO BUILT OVER A THOUSAND
MULTI FAMILY HIGH DENSITY UNITS
WITHIN A HALF MILE OF THE BART
STATION.
THEY WANTED TO DO MORE.
THEY WANTED TO DO MORE UNITS AND
IN FACT THEY APPROVED A PLAN FOR
MORE UNITS ALMOST THREE HUNDRED
UNITS ON BART OWNED LAND.
AND BART SAID NO.
BURKE SAID NO I'D RATHER HAVE A
COMMERCIAL OFFICE LEASE.
SO THE CITY AGAIN APPROVED
HOUSING AND BART SAID NO.
THE CITY OF WANNA CREEK IS
ANOTHER EXAMPLE.
THEY'VE APPROVED ALMOST A
THOUSAND UNITS WITHIN A HALF
MILE OF THEIR WANNA CREEK
STATION.
AND WHEN THEY WANTED TO DO MORE
THE REASON WHY THEY COULDN'T DO
MORE WAS BECAUSE OF PART.
BART DIDN'T HAVE CLEAR TITLE TO
ITS OWN PROPERTY IN ORDER FOR
THEM TO DO IT.
AND YOU NEED ONLY LOOK AT THE
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION'S OWN REPORT FROM
EARLIER THIS SUMMER THAT SAYS.
DUBLIN SAN RAMON PLEASANTON THE
TRI VALLEY CITIES MOST AFFECTED
BY THIS BILL ARE MEETING THEIR
GOALS TOWARDS HOUSING THE THREE
LOCATIONS.
IN THE BAY AREA THAT ARE NOT
MEETING THEIR GOALS ARE SAN
FRANCISCO SAN JOSE AND OAKLAND.
THEY WON'T MEET THEIR GOALS
UNTIL THE NEXT CENTURY.
THEY'RE NOT AFFECTED BY THIS
BILL EXCEPT ONE LOCATION SAN
FRANCISCO SO MAKE IT A DISTRICT
BILL.
SO IT'S NOT THE PART IS HAVING
ITS PROPOSALS REJECTED IT'S NOT
THAT THE CITY'S REJECTING
PROPOSALS.
THESE ARE THE VERY CITIES THAT
ARE DOING THE MOST TO PROMOTE
TRANSIT ORIENTED DEVELOPMENT AND
MULTI FAMILY HOUSING.
AND LET ME TELL YOU A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE AGENCY TO WHICH A YES
VOTE WILL GIVE CONTROL OVER
HOUSING.
RIGHT NOW PARTISAN THE HEADLINES
FOR STABBINGS. FOR CRYING THEY
HAVE A CRIME CRISIS THAT HAD A
41% INCREASE IN THE FIRST HALF
OF THIS YEAR IN VIOLENT CRIME IF
WE KEEP ON PACE WITHOUT.
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE A 60% 66%
RISE IN CRIME MISTER THURMAN.
WHAT IS YOUR POINT OF ORDER
MADAM SPEAKER I BELIEVE THAT
TALKING ABOUT CRIMES THAT HAVE
OCCURRED?
FALL OUTSIDE THE SCOPE OF WHAT
THIS BILL PROPOSES PLEASE DIRECT.
SPEAKER TO STAY WITHIN THE
MERITS OF THE BILL AT HAND. ONE
IS NOT WELL TAKEN YOU MAY
CONTINUE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER IN
ADDITION.
FEMA'S THIS IS THE CRIME CRISIS
THAT BART HOW'S THAT SO DRAMATIC
JUST YESTERDAY FEMA THE FEDERAL
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT AGENCY
AWARDED A GRANT OF SIX MILLION
DOLLARS.
TO IN AN EMERGENCY SITUATION TRY
TO HELP PART GET CONTROL OF ITS
CRIME.
IN ITS OPERATIONS.
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO HAVE NEW
TRACK THAT'S FUNCTIONING WELL.
JUST YESTERDAY IN THE HEADLINES
THERE'S A TRACK MALFUNCTIONING
CONTRA COSTA THAT WON'T BE FIXED
ANYTIME SOON.
THEY'RE ESCALATORS ARE OUT OF
ORDER 83% OF THE TIME IF YOU'RE
ONE OF THE MOST BUSIEST STATIONS
FOR OUTSIDERS THEY'RE OUT OF
ORDER 3% 83% OF THE TIME.
AND IN ADDITION THE NEW TRAINS
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO HAVE ARE
BEHIND SCHEDULE.
AND THEY ARE ALSO REQUIRED. TO
HAVE OVER FIVE HUNDRED FIXES IN
THE FIRST FIVE MONTHS OF THIS
YEAR.
NEVER MIND THE FARE EVASION.
AND THE BARD IS DROWNING IN ITS
OWN PROBLEMS.
THAT'S THE AGENCY THE YOU'RE
GOING TO GIVE HOUSING FROM THE
CITY'S UNDER YOUR IN I WAS A
PARTNERSHIP UP PLEASE AND
MEMBERS I WILL CLOSE WITH.
LET HER FINISH FIVE FIVE SECONDS
AS I'M CLOSING THIS IS THE
STATEMENT AND THIS IS THE REASON
WHY A THIRD OF THE PARK BOARD
OPPOSES THIS BILL IT'S THE
STATEMENT FROM ONE OF THEIR
DIRECTORS.
I OBVIOUSLY DON'T KNOW YOUR
CITIES AS WELL AS YOU DO.
MEMBERS THERE'S A BETTER
SOLUTION REQUIRE COLLABORATION
OF THESE TWO PARTIES PART IN THE
CITIES DO NOT TAKE HOUSING AWAY
FROM THEM AND GIVE IT TO AN
AGENCY THAT WILL FAIL.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND I ALSO
WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO THANK
MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FRANCISCO
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE.
AND FOR SHARING MY PASSION OF
IMPROVING THE QUALITY OF LIFE
FOR THOSE THAT LIVE IN THE BAY
AREA AND THOSE THAT VISIT THE
BAY AREA.
AND YOU DON'T HAVE TO LIKE BART
I GUESS OR ARE FEEL GOOD ON BART
TO UNDERSTAND THAT THIS STATE IS
FACING A HOUSING CRISIS WE
WORKED VERY HARD LAST YEAR. TO
POWER TO PASS A HOUSING PACKAGE
TO ADDRESS THAT CRISIS THAT IS
OVERWHELMING OUR OUR OUR STATE.
AND SO I'D LIKE TO SHARE A BIT
OF A A PERSPECTIVE ABOUT BART
WHEN IT COMES TO MY CITY --
WHILE I WAS IN LOCAL GOVERNMENT
SERVING ON COUNCIL.
BART SHOWS OUR DOWNTOWN STATION
AS A PLACE FOR CAPITAL
IMPROVEMENT AS ONE OF THEIR
SITES.
THEY COULD HAVE EASILY COME UP
WITH THEIR OWN PLANS AND JUST
RAMMED IT THROUGH BUT INSTEAD
THEY REACHED OUT THEY
COLLABORATED THEY SOUGHT FOR
ADVICE AND INPUT FROM THE CITY
COUNCIL.
WE WERE SO CRITICAL WE EVEN WENT
DOWN TO THAT TYPE OF LIGHT
STANDARDS THEY WERE GOING TO USE
ALONG THE SIDEWALK.
AND BART WILLINGLY MADE THE
ADJUSTMENTS TO THEIR PLANS TO
ACCOMMODATE THE CITY COUNCIL'S
REQUEST.
AND SO THERE IS THAT
COLLABORATIVE APPROACH BART HAS
PRODUCED GREAT TEO DE AND OUT
BUT THERE ARE SOME INCOMPLETE --
PROJECTS --
EVEN IN THE PAST TEN YEARS AS MY
FACT I'D LIKE TO THINK THE
ARGUMENT --
THANK MY COLLEAGUE FOR HER
ARGUMENT ABOUT. ONE PARTICULAR
CITY WHO HAS ALREADY.
WELL THE GOOD NEWS ON OUR BILL
IS THAT IF YOU MEET ARENA
NUMBERS YOU'RE ACTUALLY EXEMPT.
AND SO IF YOU MEET A MAN IN ALL
THE DIFFERENT --
CATEGORIES AND DIFFERENT LEVELS
SO PROJECTS ARE UNDERWAY BUT
THEY'RE EXPECTED TO TAKE A
FIFTEEN YEAR AVERAGE FROM THE
TIME OF NEGOTIATION
AUTHORIZATION TO COMPLETION.
AND WE DID TO MAKE IT EASIER TO
DEVELOP AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
BRING OUR HOUSING SUPPLY UP. TO
BETTER MEET THE DEMAND A KEY
COMPONENT TO ANY LONG TERM
SOLUTION FOR A HOUSING NEEDS.
AND IN THE LARGEST CITY THAT'S
AND MY DISTRICT THE TOTAL NET
INCREASE IN THE HOUSING FROM
200-012-22000 SEVENTEEN WAS A
HUNDRED NINE UNITS.
THAT DID NOT QUITE MEET THE
NEEDS OF HOUSING FOR OUR AREA
THIS SIMPLY IS UNACCEPTABLE AND
WE ARE FACING THIS HOUSING
PRICES.
AND BY CONNECTING AFFORDABLE
MAKES USE HOUSING PROJECTS WITH
CLOSE PROXIMITY AND
ACCESSIBILITY TO BARK WE ARE
MOVING THE BAY AREA TOWARDS A
FUTURE.
OF A WITH MORE LIVING UNITS
AVAILABLE FOR WORKING FAMILIES
FEWER CARS ON THE ROAD REDUCED
MOBILE EMISSIONS THAT HARM OUR
ENVIRONMENT AND A HIGHER QUALITY
OF LIFE FOR ALL RESIDENTS.
THE BILL THIS BILL WILL MOVE OUR
REGION FORWARD WITH TRANSIT
SMART TRANSIT ORIENTED
DEVELOPMENT THAT BENEFITS
FAMILIES WORKERS AND EMPLOYERS
ALIKE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
MEMBERS OF YOU CAN KEEP YOUR
CONVERSATIONS TO BARE MINIMUM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA YOUR
RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE AS ONE OF THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MOST DIRECTLY
AFFECTED BY.
THIS BILL AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY
THREE I HAVE.
EIGHT BART STATIONS PLUS THE
OPEN AIR PORT CONNECTOR IN MY
DISTRICT.
MANY OF THE STATIONS IN SAN
LEANDRO AND IN OAKLAND MAY BE
DIRECTLY AFFECTED BY AB.
TWENTY NINE TWENTY THREE AND I
BELIEVE THAT AB TWENTY NINE
TWENTY THREE TACKLES SOME OF OUR
GREATEST CHALLENGES HOUSING.
CONGESTION GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AND IN EQUITY.
IT DOES OWN A TARGETED WAY
FOCUSING ON CRITICAL PIECES OF
LAND WHICH FORTUNATELY ALSO
HAPPEN TO BE UNDEVELOPED.
GOVERNMENT OWNED LAND THAT MEANS
WE CAN AVOID DISPLACEMENT AND
DELIVER PUBLIC BENEFITS AT THE
SAME TIME.
WE'VE SEEN SOME GREAT
COMMUNITIES BUILT AROUND BART
STATIONS IN MY DISTRICT BUT IT
TAKES TOO LONG. FOR EXAMPLE
EXAMPLE CONSIDER FACE TO OF THE
FOOD FAIL BART TRANSIT VILLAGE
WE ANTICIPATE COMPLETION AND
TWENTY NINETEEN A FULL TWENTY
FIVE YEARS AFTER THE BART BOARD
TOOK A VOTE. TO INITIATE
NEGOTIATIONS WE CAN'T AFFORD TO
WAIT TWENTY FIVE YEARS FOR THE
REST OF OUR GREAT TRANSIT
ORIENTED.
COMMUNITIES BUT THE GREAT PLACES
THAT BART WILL NOT ONLY INCREASE
HOUSING JOBS AND SERVICES IT
WILL INCREASE SAFETY BY BUILDING
COMMUNITY OWNERSHIP.
AND INCREASING ACTIVITY IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS AND ON OUR STREETS
AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY THREE ALSO
BUILDS IN STRONG AFFORDABILITY
REQUIREMENTS STRONG LABOR
REQUIREMENTS STRONG
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW.
AND STRONG COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT.
THAT'S WHY YOU SEE SUCH A BROAD
COALITION OF SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL WE HAVE SERIOUS CHALLENGES
WE MUST BE WILLING TO TRY NEW
APPROACHES.
AND BART STATIONS PROVIDE A
UNIQUE AND IMPORTANT OPPORTUNITY
THAT WE OUGHT NOT PASS UP I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
COLLEAGUES [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I SEE NO FURTHER REQUEST TO
SPEAK ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU YOU
MAKE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER LET ME
FIRST START BY THANKING OUR
COLLEAGUES FOR THE ROBUST
DISCUSSION THAT WE HAD AS WELL
AS OUR COLLEAGUES.
WITH WHOM WE ARE NOT ON THE SAME
PAGE YET ARE AS OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM DUBLIN SAID I WAS HAPPY TO
ENGAGE WITH HER CONSTITUENTS.
AND WE ENGAGED AT LENGTH WITH --
WITH WITH.
INDIVIDUALS FROM COMMUNITIES
THAT HAS ISSUES WITH THIS
INCLUDED MANY AMENDMENTS TO
ADDRESS THAT LET ME JUST PUT
THIS.
IN CONTEXT FOLKS WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED FIFTY ACRES OF
LAND OWNED BY BART AROUND.
TWENTY SIX TWENTY SEVEN BART
STATIONS.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT SURFACE
PARKING LOTS THAT HAVE NOT BEEN
DEVELOPED FOR FORTY FIVE YEARS.
AND LET ME ADDRESS SOME OF THE
ISSUES OF AND RAISED IT'S BEEN
SUGGESTED THAT SOMEHOW THIS BILL
IS NOT NEEDED.
IT TOOK FOURTEEN YEARS TO BUILD
TRANSIT OR IN DEVELOPMENT AROUND
THE PARK STATION.
NEXT TO BERKELEY. TWENTY YEARS
IN MILLBRAE TWENTY TWO YEARS AND
WALNUT CREEK TWENTY FIVE YEARS
IN FRUITVALE IN OAKLAND FORTY
THREE YEARS IN PLEASANT HILL.
AND THOSE ARE THE COMMUNITIES
THAT ACTUALLY WANTED TO BUILD
TRANSIT ORIENTED DEVELOPMENT.
THERE'S BEEN A SUGGESTION THAT
THERE ARE CITIES THAT ARE READY
TO BUILD OR WANT TO DO
TRANSITORY DEVELOPMENT AND I
WANNA MAKE IT VERY CLEAR.
THIS BILL.
INCLUDES AN EXEMPTION FOR THOSE
CITIES IF THEY HAVE ZONED
APPROPRIATELY.
THERE WAS A SUGGESTION THAT
SOMEHOW BART WANTS TO GET RID OF
COMMUTER PARKING THAT COULD NOT
BE FARTHER FROM THE TRUTH.
PART HAS SPENT OVER THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
RECENT YEARS ON REPLACEMENT AND
EXPANSION PARKING AS PART OF THE
STATIONARY DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM.
THERE WAS THE SUGGESTION THAT
SOMEHOW THIS IS A PRECEDENT FOR
OTHER TRANSIT AGENCIES AROUND
THE STATE.
THIS BILL SPECIFICALLY CITES THE
UNIQUE FACTORS Y. IT'S TAYLOR TO
PART.
INCLUDING THE FACT THAT THE BART
BOARD IS DIRECTLY ELECTED BY
RESIDENTS OF THE PART DISTRICT
THIS IS NOT TRUE FOR ANY TRANSIT
AGENCY OUTSIDE OF THE BAY AREA.
THERE'S A SUGGESTION THAT
SOMEHOW THIS IS NOT ALLOWED IN
THE CONSTITUTION.
THESE ARGUMENTS JUST DON'T HOLD
WATER THIS BILL CLEARLY
ADDRESSES MATTERS OF STATEWIDE
CONCERN.
LET ME JUST SAY THIS.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TO UNDER
FIFTY ACRES OF SURFACE PARKING
LOTS THAT HAVE NOT BEEN
DEVELOPED IN THE FORTY FIVE
YEARS.
OF ART HISTORY WE NEED TO DO
SOMETHING.
AT ITS CORE THE ARGUMENTS
AGAINST THIS BILL OUR CALL FOR
THE STATUS QUO.
AND AT A TIME.
WHEN OUR STATE BUT PARTICULARLY
THE BAY AREA IS EXPERIENCING THE
MOST INTENSE HOUSING CRISES
[inaudible]
AND CONGESTION CRISIS THAT ARE
BAY AREA HAS SEEN WE NEED TO DO
SOMETHING.
IF WE DON'T DO SOMETHING HERE
COLLEAGUES WHAT ELSE WILL WE BE
ABLE TO DO.
WITH DATA RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CLERK YOU MAY
OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO VOTE
HOW THE VOTES AYE AYES FORTY
FOUR KNOWS TWENTY FIVE THE
MEASURE PASSED
.
MEMBERS ARE BILLS ON CALL I AM
LIFTING THE CALL ON FILE ITEM
WHEN SIXTY S. B..
NINE FIFTY EIGHT MATTER QUIRK
PLEASE POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE
ADEQUATE PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLL EYES THIRTY FOUR KNOWS
TWENTY EIGHT THE MEASURE FAILS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY
REQUEST RECONSIDERATION.
I AM PREPARED TO MOVE THE CALL.
I'M SORRY TO LIFT THE CALL ON
ITEM ONE SEVENTY THREE SB ONE
HUNDRED MADAM CLERK PLEASE POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS VOTE BUT A
PART PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTES.
AYE AYES FORTY THREE KNOWS
THIRTY TWO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
I AM PREPARED.
TO LIFT THE CALL ON ITEM ONE
SIXTY SIX S. B..
NINE SEVENTEEN BOTTOM QUICKLY SO
PLEASE.
PLEASE POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO VOTE.
MEDICAL CAN MAKE CLOSE THE
ROLAND TALLY THE VOTES EYES
FORTY ONE KNOWS TWENTY THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING OUT ITEM ONE SEVENTY SIX
S. B. TWELVE SIXTY FIVE I'M
PREPARED TO LIFT THE CALL MENA
PUT PLEASE POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE
I DON'T QUIRK PLEASE CLOSE
THE ROLE ANTI THE VOTES AYE AYES
FORTY ONE KNOWS TWENTY FIVE THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
I AM PREPARED TO LIFT THE CALL
ON ITEM ONE EIGHTY NINE S. B..
NINE NINETY EIGHT BUT A QUICK
QUIZ POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE
NOT A PERK
YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY
THE VOTES EYES FORTY ONE NO
TWENTY FIVE THAT MEASURE PASSES.
LIVING OUT ITEM TO FORTY TWO SB
THIRTEEN SEVENTY SIX MADAM CLERK
PLEASE POST.
REQUIRES FIFTY FOR ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
VOTE
.
MADAM COURT YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TELLING THE BOATS EYES
FIFTY FOUR NOS THIRTEEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
WE ARE MOVING OUT OF THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
DOES ANY MEMBER WISH.
I'M SORRY MISSED TO CALDERON
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED YOUR MOTION
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE
MOVE ITEM TWO FIFTY EIGHT S. B.
TWO EIGHTY EIGHT HERNANDEZ TO
THE ENACT A FILE WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER WE ARE NOW MOVING TO THE
SEC CALENDAR.
DOES ANY MEMBER WISH TO REMOVE
AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING ON THE CLERK
WILL READ THE SECOND THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TO EIGHTY FIVE BY SOME MEMBER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO DIAPER NEED A
WHERE'S AWARENESS WEEK THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES I SEVENTY
FIVE NO.
ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
[inaudible]
ONE FIFTY THREE YES.
I SEVENTY FIVE NO ZERO
SECULARIZATION Y. FIFTY EIGHT I
SEVENTY FIVE NO ZERO STICKER
RESOLUTION ONE SIXTY I SEVENTY
FIVE NO ZERO SENATE CONCUR
RESOLUTION ONE SIXTY FIVE I
SEVENTY FIVE NO ZERO AND SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION WHEN.
FIFTY NINE I SEVENTY FIVE NO
ZERO MEMBERS THE FOLLOWING
COMMITTEES WILL BE MEETING UPON
A GERMAN IN SESSION NATURAL
RESOURCES IN ROOM.
FOUR FORTY SEVEN CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE ON S. B. NINE NO ONE
WILL MEET UPON CALL IN ROOM ONE
TWENTY SIX THE SESSION SCHEDULE
IS AS FOLLOWS WEDNESDAY AUGUST
TWENTY NINTH THAT'S TOMORROW.
FLOOR SESSION FROM TEN A. M. TO
PM ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING
WILL BE PASS AND RETAIN ALL
MOTION SHALL BE CONTINUED.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN MISTER
CALDERON MOVES AND MISS WALDRON
SECONDS AT THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL WEDNESDAY AUGUST
TWENTY NINTH AT TEN WAIT I'M
SORRY.
WHAT'S GOING ON THE CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE WILL BE MEETING AT SIX
PM.
THE CONFERENCE COMMITTEE WILL BE
MEETING.
AT SIX PM IN ROOM.
ONE TWENTY SIX THANK YOU WITH
THAT THIS MEETING IS.
I'M SORRY.
IN ROOM.
FOR THOSE. FORTY TWO OH TWO
BECAUSE YOU'LL FIND YOUR WAY.
AS MANY AS A JUROR [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WHAT?
NO I HAVE NO CHANGES
[inaudible]
YOU CAN
.
VOTE CHANGES STEVEN CHOI BILL
NUMBER S. B. ON NINE THIRTY
SEVEN YES TO KNOW.
BOTH CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOI
SENATE BILL NINE THIRTY SEVEN
HEIGHTS IN NO.
VOTE CHANGE ASSEMBLY GRAYSON.
S. B. ELEVEN TWENTY NINE I TO
NOT VOTING.
VOTE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON SENATE BILL ELEVEN
TWENTY NINE I IT'S NOT VOTING.
BEAU CHANGE SIMPLY MEMBER CHAVEZ
AB TWELVE THIRTY ONE NO TO AYE.
THE CHANGE AS I REMEMBER CHAVEZ
AS LEGAL AS WELL THIRTY ONE
NOTES I VOTE CHANGE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO S. B..
THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT FROM I TO
NOT VOTING.
VOTE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RUBIO SENATE BILL THIRTEEN
TWENTY EIGHT HEIGHTS NOT VOTING.
VOTE CHANGE S. B. THIRTEEN
TWENTY EIGHT FROM I TO NOT
VOTING.
THOUGH CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARAMBULA SENATE BILL THIRTEEN
TWENTY EIGHT ITES NOT VOTING.
VOTE CHANGE QUIRK SILVA S. B.
ONE HUNDRED FROM AYE TO NO.
VOTE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK SILVA.
SENATE BILL ONE HUNDRED I TO
KNOW.
VOTE CHANGE VOEPEL SIERRA BRAVO.
ONE EIGHT THREE I TO KNOW.
BUT CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VOEPEL SENATE BILL ONE EIGHTY
THREE I TO KNOW